Okay.
I fixed it.
I think I fixed it.
Guys, I fixed it.
I just did it admin mode.
I fixed it.
Guys, we're back.
We're back.
Yeah, this is why we're on Twitch.
So how would you be?
Everything's okay.
Can you replace her with low one crook?
I wonder, I wonder who's the subs are to be fair.
LeBron James.
Karovo and standby are just to be I feel like it should be
someone that has played the game quite often because I don't
think we can do a crash course on someone that's a new
player mid-tournament mid-tournament we get a bronze player
yeah mid-tournament we never played never played any
characters before gotta learn on the during the tournament
yeah I'm just like let's hope And we do have to get a sub.
Let's hope it's not a new player.
Yes, it's moving now.
We're no longer blind.
Daredevil can see now.
Oh my God.
He can see it's a miracle.
oh all right i don't even know i don't even remember what's
going on during this fight i have all should i just all rip
it i know the wolf is close to all yeah i think i feel like
goger is gonna get grabbed by the wolf he's looking like
very angry right he missed his grab on me so i don't
remember the cooldown for a wolf grab but oh he grabbed me
like a second ago like He missed a grab on me a second ago.
Oh, I missed it.
Yeah.
I see you just joining.
We'll see.
We'll see my, um, we'll see what happens here.
We have old.
We just watch out for Mac.
Oh yeah.
Do we have, are we on, yeah, do we have bubble for me?
Do you all?
I will see what's happening here.
I'll be honest, I don't know what's happening.
Oh, I think I'm back.
I'm sorry.
Hello.
Welcome back.
I've got my fingers crossed.
for you thank you i'm sorry it happens it happens keep
apologizing as if you shut down your own internet you should
complain to a network provider i reckon i i did last year
like you're in ash clash like i put in today today it's an
important day a lot of money on the line yeah not money on
Are we R?
Yeah, we are.
Go ahead.
Okay, we're ready.
Right, you guys are all back in the lobby?
Mm-hmm.
Amazing.
Let's get the game started ASAP.
Hello.
Oh, Ojo is already here.
Hi, Ojo.
Hello, hello.
I think they're ready.
All right, so you guys are good?
Yeah.
I was just watching.
All right.
Amazing.
Good luck.
Good luck, you guys.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Fantastic.
Block in.
All right.
I think the wolf has a...
I'm pretty sure he does.
Wolf on me.
Oh, there it is.
You lift.
That's fine.
They used Jubilee.
Just play it, play it, play it, fight, fight.
But I know if you invest anything else.
Look for a kill.
Yeah, no more, no more else.
Yeah, just lose, lose, lose, lose.
They used two ults for that, so it's fine.
Yeah, they use wolf and they use you.
Jubilee.
They have Luna ult.
Come back.
Fall back.
I want to try to punish her ult, but they should block her.
Come top.
Fall me.
They should have mag still.
Yes, they have mag.
Wolf, I am.
Oh, they're contesting.
Yeah, it's here for the wolf grabber on the corner.
Yeah, he's close.
I'm gonna look through.
Wolf here, no grab.
Pushing up a bit.
Wolf on me.
I can't take this.
I blind this.
3, 2, 1, blind.
I'm alone.
I'm ready to put on my show.
Yeah.
I'm out.
Oh, all of you.
I get res.
Come back, back, back, back, back.
It's mine.
Come back.
You can catch this.
I'm not holding.
I'm not holding it.
I might if he tries to walk.
Oh, I'm down.
He can fly back.
Come out.
Drop.
Drop, drop, drop.
Wolf on me.
Yeah,
no supports.
No supports with you.
They have magos.
That's fine.
We're okay friend.
nobody's up here they're gonna match oh jibberley ahead
jibberley ahead okay push him back now we're here we're here
we're here dude what's he it's fine i'm 10 seconds why not
hold this i'm blinded i'm blinded i'm also aggressively can
we kill there we lost racket we lost racket only me only me
only uh wolf over i got hit i got No heals, no heals.
I'm funny.
I didn't see the Punisher.
I'm gonna get them.
Can you hold fine now?
Do we have portal?
Someone needs a TP.
I can do it.
Should I?
Yes, yes, yes.
Someone TP, someone TP.
Someone else has picked it.
I'm dead.
Who picked TP?
Yeah, the pause.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I picked it but I unpicked it instantly with odds.
But I think odds were no longer spawner than me.
Yeah, no, I was.
I was like, yeah, I'm lucky.
It's okay, happens.
Yeah, we're close to support ults.
Yeah.
I did not see where the Punisher came from.
I got shotgun.
It's okay.
First match is always warm up.
The first match is always warm up, guys.
The one win was...
Maybe that's the...
Maybe that's the strat.
I just don't show my screen.
I think the bosses can also throw us off a little bit too.
Yeah, they did.
It's unfortunate.
in double pauses yeah yeah
that's the strat i just gotta be a dare double i guess
that's all we have to do i think we did pretty well but um
second point we kind of fucked up third point we just got
too many dcs and that kind of fucked us up i think that one
fight they were a little bit more prepared after the unpause
i think also taking high is kind of i think taking high was
also kind uh duff because odds was just getting shot at and
just getting cooked oh i saw odds i'll start in a really
unlucky way he like kind of got stuck between like just an
empty space there and like the where the i'm so sorry about
that guys that's unlucky i'm sorry i'm just gonna tell you i
know it's i i know you all need to focus on your own thing
but this is a scenario that we just have now gone over and i
don't know what to do in that situation there's a catwalk
there i don't know if i should be walking it down which if i
do i've died and i tried it a couple times or if i should be
staying back and i feel like i'm not helping my team i might
make it just don't go just don't go in front of us like you
just keep like i feel like a lot of the times you're just
like so confused on what to do which i understand but like
genuinely all you have to do is like don't over complicate
and just follow like stay behind the mag and stuff like okay
nobody expects you to go down first ever like nobody expects
that from you just don't go especially against these comms
they have so much damage we just as said before you just
need to live like you don't need to go down the stairs by
yourself you're like like you don't need to overcome it's
that simple that's it that's yeah sorry i died after the
pause i died when i got stuck and i died no it's okay man
it's fine it's fine really it's okay like you're doing great
uh just we have to move bodies oh yeah just don't panic uh
we're playing gill gill team the team is scrimmed
like it really isn't your fault just like it's not you just
follow the she got dc'd like twice it's whatever who cares
it's a tournament for fun everybody needs to have like
everybody needs to have fun like not really stress about it
it's like nobody's gonna die here if we lose a match you
just need to like we just need to relax and just play our
game okay it's really not that complicated in the sense that
like you're overcomplicating it again nobody expects you to
be the first pushing in nobody expects you to be creating
space nobody expects anything from you just like live and
stay alive and like like genuinely your number one like
that's it that's that's all nobody expects uh lebron james
levels of play here and that's fine and that will be good
enough yay look at that good vibes good vibes where's the
lobby you join the lobby now oh yeah lobby is ash clash too
is it yeah this is her second lobby yeah oh yeah you're
right we're all here i hope so i see happy teams here Yeah.
Can you invite me?
Honestly, that was a really good match from us.
Like, we just got lucky.
We just, like, genuinely just got lucky.
It's whatever.
We just got to play, like, how we played first round.
First round was great.
Second round was also great.
It was just, unfortunately, we fucking fat-fingered him.
Should have happened.
I mean, it's true.
Like, it's true.
It's whatever.
I'm no blaming all of it.
I've seen pro players do it as well.
It's just, genuinely just bad luck.
Shit happens.
And it's unfortunate.
Huge card.
Yes.
twice like nobody should feel bad about this yep it's
genuinely it doesn't like like we get it all the way for a
scheme that's not it's just not gonna happen after that yeah
it's fine like nobody should think about it first game
things like things like this happen all the time it's really
whatever
all right the reason why i'm streaming on twitch is that i
don't my not on my setup right now i don't i mean as you
guys can see we had a lot of we were playing the game at a
black i have two fucking bonds of this stream team gail are
team bulgaria are and two different streams yeah just focus
on the next game like last game is whatever it's okay we
look for some wins here uh we've screamed this team quite a
bit and i think this is one of our better maps i think we
can really like do some good stuff here um we know what to
ban they know what to ban just play our best they like to
flank a lot you know just genuinely just don't panic just
don't panic
and of course it's this map i mean getting my yeah getting
my monthly streams into and then i disappear yeah i think
without the pen is gonna be easier for sure uh but they're
dad's back for their monthly visitations
i don't know if we're playing triple i think a tank pool is
probably fine i honestly up to you whatever you feel like um
who's doing the bandscare am i doing the bands i hope i have
the lead i think i see you which hero do you think you want
to be huge oh my god
Oh, is it because she was in the lobby first?
Now, who am I going to finish from this match?
All right, what is she going to press?
Can I, should I ban Penny?
Ban Penny first?
Yes, ban Penny first.
Sorry, I am not.
Guys, this tournament's looking great.
This is, this is, this is, this is.
good start i saw you immediately oh god it's okay we fix it
yeah you guys it's okay it stops here it said the scuff
stops here this is where it stops it's it's nice that i saw
it because like in other events sometimes it just gives a
random person the the lead and they forget to ban it's
always good
oh okay i think we're right are now you have the captain
flag now thank you
you're right maybe what if i just end stream
guys i i feel like uh i don't like i want you guys to
understand that you gotta have fun here and we like no
stress here we start stream every match it's a game of rank
these people are playing it's really what do you think you
want to be today why would i be stressed Now you're making
her...
Now you're making her more stress!
I know you're in your head, blaming yourself for the DCs.
Genuinely, from the bone of my heart, nobody cares about
DCs.
Don't worry, I'll DC mid-game.
I'll DC just to join you in solidarity.
I'll DC mid-match.
Nobody cares.
Shit happens.
Don't think about it.
Just focus on the game.
Like, genuinely, whatever.
It's solidarity.
Really inconsequential, but it's spelled Y-O-O-J.
o-o-j huge yeah because that's that's why it's spelled like
that okay uh what was the second band here uh elsa are you
asking us you're the cat i'm asking my other captain sorry i
was muted my bad yes it's elsa and uh we're protecting thing
i guess yeah okay let's go sorry i was it's fine
and what do we ban here third ban
it was like the cat or a tank I can't is a good ban you just
ban the cat yeah I think it's really annoying for a bit I
mean it did like true did say that I mean he can play
whatever heroes but I still think it's a good idea to sprint
cut because it's just so for the buckling like you know what
i i feel like you want to play grude here olive uh i can't
yeah yeah yeah i kind of like i don't know i think yeah it's
not i think you can do more on grude than the emma on this
map what is this combo oh it's not all wait so it's not all
domination maps no only the first one i see that's
interesting you would think you would feel like best of one
like it's best of one guys and i oh wait my hat's last man
wait mod can you take can you turn off the timer for the
hatsune miku colorful stage magman i'm a bad man i think i
think so much agency actually yeah It's a honeymoon bag
That's a colorful stage You go What do you want Me to play?
Oh Mantis is not Do you want to play Mantis you feel
confronted with Mantis here?
We can like if you want to play a Mantis here You can damage
Booth's neck and You can give Snowflake a neck and You play
like this The issue is I think it might be a little bit hard
Against the dive like if there are anyone That's true or
something let me see i might stick stick to i mean that's a
good good good character play here i just can't stick next
to i can't play next to you huge okay yeah lock in here guys
yo oh it's lock in we're locked up yeah yeah yeah we play
defending first wepa yeah okay wepa uh i can all swap the
hood here if it doesn't work i don't know what to play here
though i can can maybe play Emma with Amanthus open guys I
think it's a PC issue because how the fuck am I getting this
is the most frames I've ever got playing rivals and
streaming and streaming with as with my skin suit I this is
definitely my PC issue like how is this possible what corner
are you guys interested in defending for is this very first
one over here just play play with our group play with our
group don't know what company play with our group that's it
yeah if you can look out for bad one so I have to play like
this.
I will do that.
Around what?
Watch out for us.
Yeah, I hope I do.
Oh, wild off, followed up.
I got hooked.
I need care.
Help him.
Help him, right there.
Oh my god, I got pulled.
I'm good.
Break while.
I should be good.
We good.
We're good.
Yeah, spider.
Come back.
I'm walking.
I'm coming.
Kill him.
yeah look good nice nice nice nice falling down oh spider
behind i got you i got you i got you back come back bye bye
thank you focus up guys that's a curse party it pulls very
good i like this i'm actually i'm just going to put my wall
down if they have this many grabs yeah i normally like using
it for now they have widow like we don't know Watch out,
hook again.
I'm trying to bring the walls for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can press the hook down.
Hey, can you guys chill for a second?
I can chill for a second.
Yeah, hold off.
I'm trying to.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, well, no.
I have to give this corner.
I slept somewhere.
I'm hitting here.
93, 93, 93.
I'm 93, 93, 93, 93.
Up here, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, Everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone.
Shoot them, shoot them, shoot them.
They're all low, they're all low!
Damage boosted, I'm not sure.
Emma, Emma.
Oh, Emma dropped.
She might be behind us.
Emma's behind us, we need to kill her, by the way.
I'm getting the Groot.
Groot one, Groot one.
The Emma's looking for an ult behind us.
Emma should be behind.
Oh, is she like out of here?
She's here, she's here, she's here.
She's on our Luna.
I slept right, I slept.
Oh, she yet.
Don't chase don't chase I'll get him.
Okay.
Yeah.
I gave you damage I'll pick I'm gonna pop alt I'm gonna pop
alt and go their back line and you get to walk One support
I'm trying to I'm trying to heal you I'm big one big one
close Big one, I'm out.
I'm out, I'm out.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
Solo heals, solo heals right now.
I'm almost back.
I saw DD behind.
Kairi or Luna?
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
It's okay, it's okay.
There's a big wall in front of us.
He just plays slow.
Okay, you only have Mantis heals.
I'm not gonna waste my leaves.
I'll give one damage boost.
I must have another critle.
I'm putting my big wall right here.
Wait, they're in point!
Yeah, yeah, chill, chill, chill.
I think I got hit.
I'm getting hit.
I got hit.
There's a black pounder.
BP, BP, BP.
Yeah.
No, I can.
I'm dying point.
We need a portal for this.
Can we get a kill here by the way?
I'm sorry.
I don't think so.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Don't worry about it.
Do we need TP or no?
Hard.
Do we need TP?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just play on the back lane.
That's all you do.
Do we need TP?
And I tried.
I tried to ground him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's switch.
We have, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear Dell double to my left.
I heard the ring.
I got you.
I got you all.
Oh, they're rising them.
You guys gotta touch.
97, 97.
Touch, touch.
Keep touching, keep touching.
Keep touching.
I'm out of it.
Stay point, stay point.
Stay point.
Okay, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill,
chill, chill, chill, chill, All in, all in all in all.
Minters one, there one.
Box one, box one, box one.
Box one, box one.
Oh, you got this.
Minters in, Minters in.
I'm trying.
Looking at this.
Everyone at this.
Yeah, white fox out there.
And they use both defense forces, right?
Yeah.
He's frozen.
Oh, that was a really good defense.
Don't worry about it.
Just regroup.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
We are...
Okay.
Listen.
Again, odds, same plan.
Just sit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do.
Understood.
That's all you do.
Like, that's your only job.
Oh, shi-shi, shi, shi, shi, shi, shi, shi.
to let guys to let i need to let you just reset just reset
okay yeah reset we'll group up group up we have our support
out soon we have a better support economy they're set up
very close they're set up very close around this one you
need to be careful they're like right here we have mantis
out soon we play with that yeah i'm shooting this thing by
the way very strange old though i'm I'm big on things.
Yeah, careful stranger.
I'm waiting on the DD.
I can't.
Oh, I can't help you over there.
I will.
Oh, reset.
Oh, that's my bad.
I'm not getting out of here.
Help us out?
Help us out.
Look DD, look DD.
That's my bad.
They used thing alt, though.
I shield you.
We need to re...
We got one.
Play this.
We need to...
We need to touch this.
Okay, uh, going in, going in.
Going to touch, yep.
No, yeah, no, yeah.
We have time.
It comes out super hard.
I'm gonna hold this.
Stay fine.
I'm dropping walls for you.
Dropping walls.
I'm melting it.
I got my Vox.
One more.
Yeah, nope.
Please, Mario.
Send them up here.
They should have thing out here.
No.
They didn't?
They used it?
They used it.
Cool stuff.
They're...
Yeah, they could TP.
They were in the corner.
No TP.
Oh yeah, I'm with you.
I'm trying to go through the wall.
Very good.
He's out.
What's that?
Yeah, I'm taking damage.
Babysit back on still.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll do.
We'll do.
I'm right here.
I'm literally not going anywhere else.
Yeah, I'm giving damage.
Sure.
We need to farm that sword, okay?
That's all we need.
Things have.
They're trying to build walls too.
I'm not gonna poke.
Odds!
When the big fox comes out, Odds!
It's on!
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead here too.
I'm 88.
TP, TP, TP, TP.
We have time.
Can we make it?
Yeah, just go for the TP.
Yeah, I have, I have, I have, I have.
Don't worry.
Just start TPing.
Ducey ping.
Oh, it has to be you.
I just...
I don't know.
Nobody.
Yeah, I can't TP.
I had my own.
Don't TP.
Just come back.
Come back.
Come back to me.
GG, GG, GG.
Press you, press you, press you.
Nice.
Good job.
Very good.
This should be me.
I'm sorry.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
We have tingled for the Foxhote.
We can just start with Mansoot.
I'm not going to lie.
Just call for it.
I think Didi is top left.
Didi is top left here.
I'm shooting.
He is.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
I froze him.
He's dead.
No, no, no, no.
Ding, no, no.
Kill him.
We have blue now.
Box, box.
DDN two.
I'm at this one.
Mantis one.
Brozen.
Nice.
Yeah, I have a robot.
It's fine.
Do they have a support ult?
No.
I think we can, uh, we can wipe the under all of it.
sure you don't have uh mantis yeah i can't hit too early
though i'm getting back i'm getting back oh it's on it's on
it's on it's on it's okay it's okay we have hulk they're
gonna try to hit this really hard i need help help me help
me help me help me help me okay okay look thing look thing
thing one thing one happy frozen hulk halted hulk i'm coming
i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming i'm trying to save her but
i don't have enough heals That's okay.
That's okay.
I shouldn't have altered that.
That's not bad.
I was hoping I can get Hulken there.
We don't have defensive modules.
Yeah, it's just you.
We can touch the chest.
I don't think they're...
They're focused.
I can touch, but I'll die here.
Look, Hulken, Hulken.
Go, go, go, go.
Go.
Kill him, come.
We have to start walking soon.
I got hit by Kingo.
It's okay.
You're the thing.
Go, the thing.
Go, Hulken.
Help me, help me, huge, huge!
I, I, okay.
Can't this one, right?
Yeah, she's so low.
Aw.
We have Luna.
He might have the lane.
He killed Luna!
Oh, can he die through it?
Oh, he dies through it.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Okay.
I might die here.
I'm gonna sleep.
I can.
I had a DD army.
I'm
so sorry I'm sorry I know I dropped the ball when I pushed
forward I did not understand the combo it's it happens
sometimes it's okay it's fine it's okay it's really really
decent host he's kind of I think this is probably one of our
best teams games against this team I think playing it pretty
well just a couple of unlucky fights you know a couple of
staggers here and there we're all pretty good we could win
this yeah it was good i like the Groot the Groot was really
good Groot was from big to gross yeah yeah yeah Groot
there's just a little mistakes just a little tiny mistakes
we can fix it here I mean yeah am i stupid or did they just
stop diving the back every time I looked out to prevent it I
have this I mean that's the thing that's the thing also you
don't get like you existing and preventing them like you
don't have to do anything else like that's it like that's it
like it's the moment you leave up they're like oh you're
gone so of course you're gonna die that's the thing that's
what i mean like don't overcomplicate like if you just sit
afk next to supports that's all that's everything we don't
really need genuinely just sitting afk like next to the team
is that's it we don't need anything crazy it was a good old
on the fox two times by the way just because you made a
mistake you shouldn't like it's fine thank you it's useful
when you
flame it's beautiful yeah i like it i love him that's so
cute i think it was wrong here i hope you guys will thank
you again i guess yeah i could eat uh what do you think
about the wolf here i can oh i don't know if we'll have
enough damage to be honest uh any help you should i'm out of
the map yeah yeah i'm i'm feeling i'm feeling we have dare
double on us he's frozen he's frozen sorry i hit him when
you mid froze we should get him out Yeah, I got him.
I can walk, I can walk, I can walk, I can walk.
I'm the thing.
Ding one, ding one, ding one, ding one.
Got him, got him, got him, got him.
Oh, he's not.
DD on me.
DD one, DD one, DD one.
We're up one, we're up one.
We're up one.
We can still push.
We only want to see also.
They going on, they're going on.
They're going on.
I have 95%, 95%.
Yeah, it's good.
When you get it, stay cart.
We don't need cart.
We need cart.
Yeah, I'm on cart.
I'm on cart.
Okay.
Call for the mantis salt for her.
Yeah, get ready here.
Just push guard for now and get ready for the mantis salt.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Eight, two, one.
Manta salt now.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Push, push, kill the supports.
Good.
I got grabbed.
It's fine.
You can still alive, guys.
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, look at me.
Look at me.
I'm with you.
I'm reloading.
We get them.
I'm all off a bit.
Yeah, we're down to both our supports.
I'm out.
Can you keep alive too?
We can combo.
They're gonna have Mantis, but we should be able to combo
and kill through it.
Oh no, they just use Mantis.
Yeah, yeah.
Grid Bucky.
Make sure to damage me.
Call my ult.
It's gonna be ready in a sec.
Look, clear comes.
Look for whenever Groot bubbles and just ult right after
that, okay?
Me?
Yeah, okay.
No, no, no, I'm sorry.
Okay, he bubbled, he bubbled.
We can look for a Groot ult.
I'll pull it.
Yeah, I'm looking.
I didn't care about that.
I'm big walling frontline here.
I got one.
There's a Hulk right behind us.
There's a Hulk.
There's a Hulk behind us.
behind all in all of them i'm trying to help you
gd on card dd on card dd on card dd on card dd on card you
still on but coming back coming back That's for sure.
Watch out the side.
We have good support.
Can we set up?
Mm-hmm.
I have a lot.
Ox here.
On me.
On that purple.
Okay, that's okay.
Uh, I play bouncer here.
Yeah, just keep punching.
Keep punching that door.
Yeah, good, good.
Don't let it go.
It's gonna come over soon.
Yeah, it's good.
Yeah, good.
You can luna with when they help out.
You can luna with you.
Oh, I may excel there.
Let's go.
No.
No, no.
Oh, I'm so sorry, my god.
I got it.
We all have to die here, don't we?
Yes.
Yeah.
We can, uh, we can play with Mantisoult first.
We can just play with Mantisoult.
All right, just call for it.
Yeah, I will.
DD, DD, DD.
Okay.
Thing is here, by the way.
And Hulk, they're gonna play really aggro.
He has no cooldowns right now.
They kind of can't play aggro.
Okay.
Push up, push up, together, together.
Three, two, one, Mantisoult.
I got, I got hit, I got hit!
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Oh.
That's fine.
Looking back on.
Watch out.
That's fine.
I hit you.
Uh, Hulk was Hulk.
That's a regroup.
We're gonna have to TP.
You just just, uh, trust that calm.
Even if you die, at least, uh, I have my Mantis all there.
I can, yeah, okay.
Yeah, I should have just died.
I'm sorry.
B2B?
I just died less.
Oh, TP.
I got, I just got hooked.
I got, I got it.
Yeah, I got it.
but I'm gonna die.
You got touch.
Yeah, you got a body block down by the maxile.
Okay, we're good.
I got it.
This is their side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need a thing with here, by the way, if you can land it.
I will try.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my goodness.
Is Big Mintus hit Mintus?
I wasn't on thing.
I wasn't on it.
It's okay.
It's all right.
It was honestly a lot better than the scrims.
I like the Groot Protectorate.
That did a lot.
That was really good.
Yeah, that's it.
You just need to trust the call you just.
Like, if you die, you die.
It's fine.
You die, but you still have your ult.
Yeah.
Yeah, at least we have one ult for the next.
Because I didn't ult right away just because I got stunned
by the Hulk thing, but we would have still been able to have
the Mantis ult out.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, that was good.
That was pretty decent.
I mean, that's the best we've done against them today.
so yeah i mean this team is like one of the strongest teams
and he almost respawn held them just kind of fucked up a
little bit
oh wait what's our next lobby i'm not quite sure it's
against day oh they haven't posted the lobby that we're
supposed to be in though but they said that round three is
going to be streamed yeah i have to take my dog out really
quick i'll be back in a minute let the dogs out yeah i'm
letting the dog out Oh, let the dogs out.
No, you're good, man.
Like, don't fucking overcomplicate it.
You're good, bro.
Don't worry about it.
I didn't, I feel like I didn't make a difference in this
one.
I don't feel like I fucked it horrendously, but I also feel
like you're doing good.
No, you're fine.
You're fine.
You're like, you're learning the game.
You're learning the game, so it's fine.
It's okay.
Genuinely, whatever, man.
Who cares if you fuck up?
It's, like, fine.
like we all made mistakes i had mantis ulted and the necros
is like no at mantis i was like oops well here it is so it's
not just you it's not just you it happens yeah anything
anything i can anything i can build upon i i genuinely just
the only thing i i i've told you look what your team is just
look what your team is just just genuinely like i know
you're panicking and like it's very hectic and something
changing just like don't think too much about it like it's
it's just play with your team that's it you just play with
your team play with your supports just be an entity there
like again don't panic about it like then nobody wants a
hero player from you if if you play with your team and we
lose it's on me right like whatever it's my bad call it's my
bad play it's my bad leadership um just don't overcomplicate
nobody expects you to again like kill their entire team or
like some crazy odds i'll also like land also just like
landing out on one person is good like it's fine if you see
somebody in front of you and you should i target hulk and
thing less if we go against them again what do you mean
target less you just keep punching your man just right
clicking them okay yeah just keep right clicking them you
also had good odds that game like the on defense they were i
think i think i'm not sure i think i'd be less aggressive
right yeah like i think you also get you get over like
stimulating like kind of get confused when neck is calling
to shoot yeah yeah which is we don't expect you to know that
one time that one time i jumped in i like that translated to
my head too it's the only person left let's finish the deal
and i yeah it's not though because it's not your job is
right there also it also the spawn is right there like
killing that guy doesn't matter like that's something that
doesn't that's something that doesn't register yeah yeah
neck and me can afford to shoot that guy and try to kill him
because we are long range you need to get close which means
your next their spawn which means you're dead yeah so it's
not worth it right right um i'll try to avoid things like
that hopefully i'll pick up a bit the place oh do we have
another room or we have a minute until the final one you
have a minute man you can eat some tapas you can you can you
can chill with it thank you what
do you think about the hood neck do you think it's working
should i swap i think it's fine i think if they're playing
flesh tanks i think he's really like valuable i mean last i
mean i feel like you get so much value shooting tanks don't
you yeah i feel like i did a little damage there got a few
kills with my i just really good into i think he's really
good into thing he's really good into hold so i think it was
like all right yeah i think so too and there's i don't think
there's anything better you can play if they've been so too
um what's it called i don't i mean they just banned mag and
they banned dinosaur and like i don't think there's much
else we can play there it's a dps could be but i don't know
maybe i'll put olive on dps but still olive has a nasty
olive do you feel do you think strange is just bad like we
can try strange as well going and it's like the fight
winning like the the ults you know like i mean i'll probably
hop on the strange if need be i can try that like oh my did
if you uh depends on the though i can play i can play
strange it's up to you yeah just the band line uh i like you
a lot yeah i'll maybe root and strange low key might be uh
pretty good what do you guys think for two yeah no i'm i'm
down man i'm down for whatever i'm down for whatever we can
definitely try the strange and just like try to tap their
like kill through their squirtles i'm just focusing here
asking for you that's fucked up man you're going to
interrogate you for everything you know
I think it just says you know some of the players are new so
we have to be like you know I won't put too much pressure on
them no I'm still not at my setup I might fly home today so
I could play the not today I'm flying home Tomorrow so I
could play on my said I this has to be a piece my PC issue
because I'm streaming this with Me on the screen and I'm
getting consistent 200 plus frames.
I've never seen these numbers before while streaming I Maybe
I just need like I just need a whole Rehaul of a new PC or
some shit
I feel like Yeah, I think I just need to get a brand new PC
at this point, because, like, something's up, but I don't
know what is up, but something's up, because whenever I
stream Rivals, I just assume because VTube Studio takes a
lot of stuff, like, takes a lot, and Rivals also, like, you
know, not greatly, not, like, you know, a bit poorly
optimized.
I always get like 100 frames whenever I stream rivals like
it's like 100 and sometimes it drops to like 80 frames or
something And so I don't know I do have a lot of stuff on my
OBS it could be that I don't know I don't know I've never
have like I've never had like 200 plus frames whenever I
stream rivals before so I don't know what the fuck is going
on No, I've closed my tabs I have I have guys I've actually
closed my tabs.
I don't know.
It's weird.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what's going on.
I've been having this problem for a while, too.
I just assumed.
But it's only for rivals.
I just assumed that it's because...
Oh, did they drop an optimization patch?
Maybe we'll try it.
We'll try it with myself.
with my actual setup and see it well this one is i'm on
someone else's setup right now so we could try on someone
else's setup and see how it goes
yeah but i was just like you know despite all the problems i
was having earlier uh i'm having good frames like i'm having
good frames
at least why is everybody muted in here bad vibes lock in
should bad vibe lock in talking to chat talking to chat
talking to chat I also was talking to my chat you talk to
your chat too I feel muted I hate my chat I don't want to
talk to them we know that you know hey bogus chat I'm
conversing with a higher power so come over a doki bird at
twitch i'm on twitch today come over any prime suburbs in
the doki bird chat yeah if you want streamers who don't hate
their chat this is your time to shine okay guys let's fix
the vibes here let's do a start stream together here let's
combine our nations oh true can we hear a chat too no
absolutely no no no no no no no no no no that's too yeah
we're gonna see you're not able to read any message you're
not i'm afraid of seeing messages from others yeah click on
that link i promise not a virus well now i'm scared huge
huge huge i think you shouldn't be afraid to kick click on
the link nothing bad is going to happen what's the worst
thing that's going to happen you're going to dc again don't
worry about it about it oh oh no the trauma it's fine first
game was going really well should happen second game that
was like one of the best teams and honestly woman's first
point held them i think the other games are going to be a
lot easier oh my gosh i'm intimidated i'm intimidated by
this all
right guys do not worry you're safe here this is a safe
place wait
apparently when shared chats go through though nightbot and
fossil bots start fighting yeah that share chat i don't like
share chat chad chad's cooked okay yo
come back what did i miss am i in a uh we're combining our
nations on twitch i post the link Did I do it?
Did I do it correctly?
I don't know.
And I'm waiting for the interview.
Yeah, sure, chat.
Wait, wait, you haven't been interviewed yet.
Are you still waiting?
What are you doing?
I haven't done the interview.
They just told us what's going to happen and they'll just
fuck off.
Oh.
I see.
Are you sharing an interview?
You don't get your solo interview?
Yeah, it's me and they.
Oh, and they're just going to do like trash talk.
between you and day it's a brand new day yeah we're gonna
say about him huh are you gonna trash talk spider-man one
trick that's all by the otp yes it's not his lucky day huh i
guess it's it's not gonna be his lucky day today it's okay i
really i really planted the seed of doubt him he said
because he was like how does it feel to get stoned by the by
an ignite team and i was like Will was first point held them
actually and he's like, oh, what?
Excuse me.
We're far from Aurora.
Someone didn't do their homework.
Someone didn't do their homework for sure.
You act like we have something to hide.
No, I know like some who said we played well.
I don't want to do shared chat.
I know like, I mean, we played well.
He's right.
Like, I know like some chats don't get like, you know, it's
hard to moderate.
genuinely it's fine too when the shared chat i mean i know
like you know people are flaming much except like other
people's like you know the team's teammates i don't want it
to help like she's gonna go through there but like just
trust the comms and call out someone's diving yeah if i even
if i didn't alt right away it's just because i was stunned i
would have still got it off so yeah i know i should have i
should just trust it though yeah just trust it's not ranked
when you're not you're not playing with some random goblins
we fight together we die together that's kind of poetic what
was i gonna say uh yeah if things don't work out i didn't
want like our lower our lower rank players to feel
discouraged seeing the church like seeing some of the
chatters for them on the stake who are like just you know
just being toxic towards our the code is bad if you fuck up
because that's why i didn't want to share chats because i
know that i know that some you know they're because it's so
hard to moderate and i know some chatters might be talking
our teammates or you should talking me and that's why i
don't want to do share chat because i don't want to
discourage because like you know i've had people should talk
me in other people's chats during these tournaments and you
know obviously it's like it doesn't feel great and i feel
like it wouldn't you know i feel like for the newer players
it's gonna like discourage them so much that's why i didn't
want to do a share chat It wasn't my fault.
I played perfectly.
He told me to want their vibes to like go down.
I didn't want to play him.
Like I won't be surprised if like I've already got shit
talked like from other people's chats and stuff.
But like it always happens.
Every tournament always they want someone.
The chatters just some chatters just want someone to blame
because they're like my streamer.
My streamer can't be dude.
You know wrong.
You know it's like it's obviously this person.
Like or like all your team sucks.
Shit like that.
you know we
do have mods they're just wait actually yeah we have mods on
right now so it's okay they're just they don't talk a lot
because they're silent they talk when they need to talk
where is there
mod check yeah uh i don't know i think it might be a vtuber
thing um but i it's just like i like i like the mantis pick
last game i think it was good yeah i think the mantis in the
group i just i just think like it was a bit hard to live
against the ditty baby i didn't think we had trouble with
living against ditty like we genuinely were almost first
point of hell i know what went wrong like it was really
close i think it was just one fight we fucked up and the
ditty killed one person but until then like it i think it is
hard to live against the ditty but i think the mantis
provide a lot of value i agree yeah
we were kind of uh yeah we were doing so much second point
was a mess i agree yeah it's a point which is a lot of um
staggers and stuff yeah they just kind of pushed into us uh
just like when you guys die especially you all just just
stay in spawn for a bit unless the fight like just show okay
and uh just show and just take a breather but i should just
take a breather it's very take five seconds and like see
what's happening give them a little bit of push and running
around okay okay um
all right we're just waiting because our game is going to be
streamed next and because it's like uh oh i think like
usually youtuber mods are usually like behind the scenes
silent because they're like um it's more so like they don't
want to clutter clutter up the chat because you know like
the badges and everything So, you know, they give their
input when they have to give their, like when they won't,
like, when the time is right type deal.
And it's more so like, it's so, you know, there's no
hierarchy type deal being like, oh, you're just paying more
attention to the mods.
You're just talking about, you're always just interacting
with the mod, you know, stuff like that.
And so, yeah, instead I keep the mods in the basement.
where the sound teams are if the sound team's not if the
sound team needs rest I target the mods if the abuse goblin
my abuse goblins are you playing the fucking fishing video
the abuse goblin mods because like you have to do it like 60
times to get all the loot and I'm like that's why they're
silent just give me the loot
yeah yeah you know in other people's chat like mods are at
the top of the food chain in my chat mods are at the very
bottom you know how they're like oh the mods bully the
streamer i bully the mine it's the other way around
don't add sharko think of the bitties thank you thank you
have the stuff have my alert like alert stuff i can see it
now but chef uh creepy and here i thank you for the twitch
prime they can thank i'm sorry i haven't been reading the
subs or anything um um just because uh like i said not my
setup so i'm i don't know this stuff is like all over the
place for me don't
worry they know they they know what they got signed up for
some might not but what they say you think it's the you
think being a mod in my channel is the good life it's not
that's why they're in the basement
oh lobby's up
what is it let's get into the lobby oh no not competitive
imagine if I did anybody out of the innit oh nope all right
oh I'm the first one in the lobby I never utter you a docker
bird sorry that's toxic you know that honest yeah so that's
how toxic you know what I'm reject your friend request too
fire i can only have one friend for each finger on my hands
and you're the 11th sorry you have 11 fingers in one hand no
she's the 11th so i there's no room oh my gosh okay i'm
gonna go do the interview day needs to fucking move to his
team he can stop for me he can stop for me i'll play for
them throw a little bit
they have no power they're only here to moderate as they
should
congratulations yay I got rewarded for abusing my mods let's
go I don't know where that I don't know where that came from
Yippee!
I'm rewarded for my bad behavior.
Yay!
See you guys, never punished.
Good boy point, bad boy points.
We're like...
I got my bad boy points.
Being toxic never gets punished.
Why you think Rivals is such a popular game.
I will say I think Rivals is like almost two league levels
of toxicity.
But I legitimately think that it's getting there only
because Rivals has boys chat.
I think, I think, yeah, I think Ravel is getting, getting
there just because they have the benefits of being voice
chat.
I don't even think, like, voice chat, I feel like voice chat
bands should last longer.
Voice chat band and text band, it does not last as long as
you think.
It's, like, a little slap on the wrist because, um, I know,
like, in Overwatch, if you get too many reports or bands,
can actually get your account banned for a shit like that
but like in rivals it's like a slap on the wrist type deal
um and it's more so like you know you can get as many voice
chat bans as you want like it'll be like it doesn't affect
your account yeah like rank bans we're throwing is also
super short too i think i know like overwatch is like one
spectrum from one like because like Super strict.
I wish it was a middle ground a watch is super strict and
then rivals is super lax when it comes to it I think the
only Like even when trading yeah, even in when trading in
rivals the bands are not Like not hot that harsh type deal.
Oh, yay
Yay Thank you.
Thank you.
I know I dropped i'm dropping real shit right now uh necros
if we get you in the lobby um as soon as the interview's
done we're gonna be going into the game i don't even know i
can get gifted money okay sure that was possible i don't
even i even realized i get i
don't know that was possible how am i getting giving is that
new i
don't know i can get gifted money this was I've never seen
that screen before in my life.
But I do think there should be a middle ground.
Yeah, the story is US-based.
That's why our pings are a bit goofy.
Oh, that makes more sense.
Our team is very European.
Yeah, it's such a big disadvantage.
Even if we might be, you know, if you have, like, let's say,
like, better players for me, you just having them on ping is
such a big disadvantage.
That's why I wish we at least used, like, balanced latency.
how they never do that there's an option in the game it's
like a popular yeah i saw i saw frogger playing on 200p
during yeah it's like not really fair i think it's worse for
him too because it's in north virginia it's gonna be even
worse oh geez
you only have profile code to send that must be new hey guys
i'm dokey bird there's only one dokey bird I it's popular
vote and if like majority of the players are on NA they
wouldn't want balance latency so like there's that's the
issue if majority of players are in NA like why would you
why would you nerf yourself for like the other team you
always want to play to your advantage you know
yeah i just i do think because like i don't play rivalous
rank as much anymore um just because um just because of how
toxic the game has become um not just like not even just
like players themselves they're saying hi to you in the chat
wait who is
Hello, Tuchon.
Hi, Tuchon.
Oh, no, I...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I think, like, it's not just in rank in general, but
also, like, I've noticed, like, creators are also getting
more and more toxic.
And, like, I've actually had to block some players on
Twitter just because of how toxic they were, like, towards
people in-game.
And it was, like, not, like, toxic like it was really really
bad and like like one of them was like very directed towards
me and it was like a pro player and I was just like I I'm
blocking like I've never blocked a professional player
before on Twitter but I have like in rivals I've blocked um
like two rival players on Twitter because of like like one
content creator and one pro player because of how like it
was not haha funny talk it was like they want you to like
legitimately like their toxicity was so bad to the point
where it was like like their intentions was to make you cry
and like on your team too on my own team it was like their
intentions was to my chad is asking if dokey is with inside
the net ease headquarters i well my is my friend's set up so
i guess they are they're like they're they're literally next
to the server it's going south we just ask her to turn up
the servers can you sabotage please yeah let me just go find
your servers real quick and just unplug the unplug this the
data center thank you thank you yeah so like i've it had
gotten to that point and that's why i haven't played rivals
as much because i felt like people were just so negative it
was just so toxic and like like negative so I had quit
didn't haven't played as much rivals as I used I still love
the game that's the thing I was gonna make a tweet I love
the game if I could I would play this game non-stop like
like I always play this game whenever I'm like stressed out
or like like off work or off stream like I always play this
game off stream not every day obviously especially with the
how recent how toxic the community has been and a player
base has been lately so but it like but still love the game
i still love playing it if i could but it's just a commute
like what's holding it back is literally the player base
slash community because it's just it's like it's just so i
think you're just literally gonna be just you know punching
the tanks or biting the tanks main and just try to play your
life and not die really like that's the most important part
like save your cooldowns for when you're taking heavy damage
like specifically the shield is kind of your lifeline on
that character and everything it's everything it's just uh i
mean for things kind of like just punching and yeah the
shift and well not really the shift is just punching people
every time you punch someone it's 150 health like you're
just really difficult to take down as long as he's active on
someone punching every punch to think about like i don't
know he's probably throwing like almost two punches a second
and every single punch he throws is 150 health right so as
long as you're active like you're very difficult to take
down even if you're under
i i know sometimes i've retreated from situations where i
should have pushed i have a hard time telling the difference
because i'm always one cc away from like immediate i mean
it's very hard these are things that just come with like
time that's what makes me sad about it's a very game sense
heavy role so like you just you just can't really develop
that within specifically like because you know i wish i
could just play the game without they're more accurate more
damage to you and like of course used to playing against oh
my gosh okay so i had an instant one of my friends they
because i told them i was just like the communities like yes
it's like it's getting really toxic especially directed
towards me recently i don't know only because i like
recently just started playing a little bit more lately but
like still not that much thank you i appreciate the calls my
friends didn't believe me and then they're like you know how
you can have like impersonation names so you can like with
like uh russian characters you can have oh sorry yeah that's
good stay there oh they're calming just yeah yeah just just
trying to listen to our calls like when we're like when i'm
calling that i'm shooting at someone's low like you should
probably let them finish in general just kind of look i
can't turn the turn it down because everything is linked up
to one sound system so if i turn it down i'm worried i'll
don't know and they might be talking about something
important trying to minimize mistakes like that yeah don't
hesitate to tell me so i can't i can't lower discord or i
can't lower it's all them if you notice i'm they're like
he's coaching so we'll let them coach on their last legs
thank you i appreciate you walking me through those steps
appreciate it okay so what's i gonna say fuck i already
forgot i need to pee please don't start i need to pee um oh
yeah so i um i knew because like i've had moments where
people i need to pee i had i there's like people who like
just because I'm because it's me um and so like they would
if we lose they automatically go be like oh it's jokie
bird's fault oh she's so boosted blah blah blah and like
they'll just shift the blame to me because like you know
like content creator blah blah stuff like that and and like
how I don't play the game as often and then I told my
friends about it and then they didn't believe me so they did
like an impersonation name of me played two games they
changed after by the way they named changed after my friend
my one of my friends and they're a pro player by the way
this is a pro player um and they they did like one one game
with a like with a fake dokeybird account like two games
with fake dokeybird account they lost and then the team
instantly blamed dokeybird and then even though like he had
like um he had like like
and everything on support on support and dps and they blamed
me quote-unquote me with on the impersonation account just
because it was jokie bird and i was like bro i told you bro
i told you first band spidey 100 i'm binding spidey i will
yes she said just don't give them like Thanos triple
support, I think.
And then he was like so angry.
He was like, I was fucking them.
He was like, bro, I was fucking carrying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I agree.
Yeah.
And then they're like, I should have avoided you when I saw
you in that game.
And I was just like, that's not even me.
Like,
I was like, bro, that count wasn't even me.
It was a fake, actual fake dokey for it to go.
Elsa's a great band.
I think Elsa, Mag.
Yeah.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, they protect Rocket first, right?
Because they have all the rocket player.
Mag, Elsa.
Angela.
I don't think I care about Angela too much.
I think, no, no, no.
We don't.
Especially with the triple tank.
No, no.
Mag, Elsa.
Yes, Mag Elsa is a mixed band.
Yeah, the real fake dokey.
Yeah, so that's why it's just like, it's crazy.
That's why I haven't.
playing rivals as much i love this game um no the stream
mode doesn't do much it just hides your name for like like
the first minute or if the first minute and then like uh uh
and then and it reveals your name if i could i would want
stream remote like entirety of the game what's our last just
so i don't have to like fucking deal with that last man can
be mantis can be bucky i like the bucky bad dude uh mantis
mantis is also a good band if they're gonna play triple yeah
it was actually not dokeybird is that crazy the one time it
actually was not dokey bird and i still got blamed by
association or Bucky.
Actually, not a secret.
Coco, thank you for Twitch, Brad.
I know, it's crazy.
It was actually not Doki Bird for the first time.
Also, like, very good against the Triple Support.
Gambit Band, fire.
Love to see it.
I think we just run our little Chungus comp here.
Legendary, thank you for tier one, so thank you.
Thank you.
Ooh, lock in.
We run them down.
Alright.
What's the point am I playing in?
You're playing Cloak.
Alright.
You're on coat.
Yeah, we're just playing our thing here.
We're just running it down.
Elsa, lock it in.
I want to see it happen.
I'm kind of thinking about it.
Yeah, do it, do it, do it, do it, do it.
It's not like she's too hard to play.
No, I believe.
If I can play it, you can play it.
What, I don't know, it was some one above all play.
Like eternity slash one above all play.
I have a DPS player.
I don't know.
I didn't pay attention to who it was because it happened to
my friend, not me.
I just thought it was fucking...
crazy i don't know what day place i got flayed by a by
dissociation even though my friend who was on the
impersonation account uh was literally carrying the game to
the game because they were a pro player and they were just
playing support i'm i think he's a dps player but he might
force some triple support here they don't actually have a
crazy front line i thought he was uh i thought he was
thinking yeah i thought new king was thinking maybe yeah if
they have a dive character i'm just gonna put display on
this trap okay with this trap that i'm gonna put down oh my
god oh okay oh now we know they're penny guys yeah they got
their black hat okay that's okay guys right side we have
things i'm back already all right i'm back you can walk
right side or left either one we just have to full command
okay okay i'm just walking man here they're just giving us
space Yeah, I was gonna say, what do you have to say?
Yeah, yeah.
There's, um...
Yeah.
They're confessing me.
I'm going left side.
Just keep farming support.
Okay, I can... I'm blind, 3, 2, 1.
Line.
Give me a left and left.
Nice, good, good, good, good, good.
They're super low.
Keep pushing in.
Put the hood.
Hold it, hold it, hold it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Do we go for Penny?
She's up, she's up.
Dead, by the way.
I'm finding him there.
Coming back a bit.
I have bubble.
Yeah, I think I can.
Playing in bubble.
Do you have ult soon?
Come back, guys.
Come back.
I'm 70.
I have all.
Should I send it?
Go for it.
Yes, yes, yes.
Do we win this out?
We win this out?
We win this out.
I want A black light Black hat Blinded Black hat Blinded One
one one one She's one Nice Nice I have 93 I'm gonna put a
truck Get the mines Get the mines Mines Mines Chill Chill
Chill We don't have We don't have Chill I have You got mines
He's getting rest He's getting rest They're talking They're
pushing They're pushing They're pushing They have mantis So
I want to look In mantis Okay Oh big or big Big or big Big
i'm gonna break break break blinded blinded blinded i'm on
penny penny penny one penny left side penny left side guys
oh okay oh no no what is happening maybe okay guys i guess i
guess i get sleepy and i misclicked you might need coffee
olive you might need some coffee i can clear comes still
comes what's the plan it's okay just take space just farm a
penny's gonna try to play
Oh, they're all pennies.
Yeah, I'm letting Rocket heal.
I'm letting Rocket heal.
Okay, that's okay.
I'll heal.
They were on HUD.
I'm at 66.
Put this on me.
I'm contesting him.
It's fine.
I'm good.
I'm coming back.
I'm on card.
And just farm Rocket.
Come from the other side.
Okay, let you farm.
I'm pushing forward.
We have Rocket Alt here.
I'm hanging.
Should I play aggressive?
I got you.
Yes, send it.
Send it.
I'm gonna die.
It's fine.
I'm getting hurt.
Okay, nice.
I'm pushing up.
Play with me.
Am I saving up for anyone here?
I've got it.
Yeah, I'm on the floor.
Hide.
I think I'm just gonna go...
I might be dead.
Yep.
I got one, but I'm dead.
He can res.
Watch out, they're taking seriously aggressively here.
Yeah, it's fine.
Don't worry.
They have turret, turret over there?
Yeah, shoot, shoot, shoot.
They have Adam Rose.
They have Togo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm walking up here.
Just walk up with me.
Yeah, I'm sure.
Yeah, I'm with him.
Quick, quick, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Thanks.
We can't break it.
We need to live.
Just hide.
Yeah, we can just put it on.
That's fine.
You getting rest?
Adam, left side.
No, I'm not going to rest.
Oh, sorry.
Come back, Cox.
I'm trying to keep odds up.
I have a bolt here.
A big one.
We good, we good, we good, we good, good.
We're trying to keep you up.
Catch you.
We almost have rocket ult again.
We just play for that, okay?
I play for that.
Okay, I won't use it here.
Yeah.
All right, I'll just let you heal.
I'll let you heal.
I do have a bolt here.
I'm going to push up, okay?
I'm going to push up here.
Let's go three, two, one, stand it, stand it.
Rocket up, rocket up.
Shoot the ultron, shoot the ultron.
Nice, he's out.
Live, live, live.
I got hit, I got hit, I got hit.
I'm ulti is.
Good, I like it, I like it.
Push in, push in.
The atom has res, by the way.
I blinded, I blinded.
Shoot the rocket thing.
I'm blinding again?
I'm ulting this.
I blind, I blind again.
I have bubble.
They're probably gonna hold the atom round.
Yeah, nice, nice.
I'm on Emma.
Oh, yeah.
Emma low, Emma low.
Emma one.
Oh, I'm trying to...
Adam's behind us, by the way.
That's flank, that's flank.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's one, he's one, he's one.
Yeah, you had to play back there.
She went back up.
Come back, come back.
Oh.
back no it's fine they used to love support us i'm i have
blinds for it
three two one blind he's gone he's gone oh i'm blind i
blinded full blind
Okay.
They have punish your point.
He's on fire.
He's still on fire.
Kill statue.
Three on card.
I'll let you heal.
Mine portal.
Mine portal maybe?
No, no.
No portal.
I need to heal.
Yeah, yeah.
He needs to heal.
Oh, on card three on card, three on card.
Yeah.
We farm our oats here, okay?
We need to play.
We need to farm them out.
80?
Yeah.
Oh, I have to use that.
I have to use that for her.
Yeah, I'm good.
Three or Is it kind of six Use it, use it, use it Nice I use
it, I use it Hood 1 Hood 1 I'm stunned I'm using it here
Ready Yes, yes, yes Go Go Kill them, kill them, kill them
Kill the hood Big, big, big Big, big, big Big, big Oh Hit
the hood I'm I'm shooting I'm shooting I'm blinded doors
Rocket Oh Rocket Rockettles, rockettles, rockettles.
I'm out of base.
Portald, yes or no?
We need portald, yes, yes, yes.
His last fight.
The last to save point.
Portalding, portalding?
Yeah.
Just a triple comp there.
Just annoying.
So miss portals.
Once again, I think this map is really hard to push.
I think we can definitely easily follow this.
Okay.
Question, what happened at the start were there like 29
mines in one invisible spot or no they just put mines in the
spawn door and we just walked out and they got exploded
that's fine it wasn't even invisible they were just sitting
there we didn't expect them to fight fanny that's it sure no
don't worry
three else in a row yeah is this difficult because they have
the punny and i mean we had three tanks really have i think
it's because we had three tanks so yeah so the punishment in
the farm is Do you want to try 2-2-2?
We can.
I can play Bucky or Pony.
But Triple H and Diffin is going to be better now.
No, just do it.
Just take it.
Okay.
Sounds good.
They might be early.
Adam likes a plank.
They just tell, if you see him, just mark him for us.
Yeah.
I'm going to scout.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
See?
We've seen him come.
Yeah.
Come back, come back a bit.
Just play it short.
Good.
Go ahead.
Go ahead, bubble down.
In the corner.
Hood, hood, hood, hood.
He's pushing out.
I'm landing.
3, 2, 1.
blinded okay low low low low low oh it's good push it push
it push it you get res you guys just I have blind here where
there's one I don't know where's the left side I wonder
where's the wall wait wait I don't see main stay main stay
main I'm on Adam Adam still behind I'm okay I'm okay I'm
putting bubble out I'll hold the right side halfway his
main.
Emma!
I don't know where I don't run it anymore.
No res, no res.
They're going.
We almost have ult.
Just live, live, live, live.
Come back, Oz.
Come back.
Oh, that's it.
Back up a little back up.
We have to get that.
Rocket very soon.
Help us, help us, help us.
Hoping back, I'm going back.
Yeah, I think I'm dying playing.
Can you TP?
My amp might be...
Kill him, kill him, kill him, kill him.
Yeah, Oz, can you TP?
Yep.
I cannot.
86, 86.
On it, on it, on it, on it, on it.
Hey, man.
You can get touch, we have TP coming.
Yeah, TP in five.
94, 94.
We have a defensive wall.
I'm 99.
I just got it.
Ignore it?
Ignore it or?
Yeah, just go back, go back.
Yeah, just ignore it.
I have far spawn.
Yeah, it's okay.
Do I go to far spawn?
Oh, shit.
Yeah, it's just come out.
Fuck, dude.
I think I'm just going with it.
Don't worry.
No, it's okay.
I'll die and switch.
I'm sorry.
Oh, you're good.
You can make it out safely too.
I have cloak here.
I think they'll have mantis though.
I'm gonna go top.
Yeah, they have height.
Yeah, it's fine.
We just need to win one fight here.
I'm gonna contest up.
Returning with proper hero.
I'm just trying to keep.
I put the bubble in front.
It's coming here.
We're good.
Adam and the Amlar are pushing me higher in here.
Can we go in?
Can we go in the close?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I died, I died, I died, I died.
Mantis one Mantis no.
You have that and Wardlock on the right side.
Mantis is still low.
Mantis is all...
Low low low.
Okay, can you live?
I'm alive.
I'm alive here.
I have my oath here.
A rocket's coming back.
Break, break, break, break, break, break, break, break,
break.
Or it's or it's...
Judge, jury, executioner!
Do we have res for that?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
camp guy that camp guy ready in the best spot hood hood bar
hood's one we almost have rockered up and i'll let him take
damage for you i'll let you heal that hey bondage we have to
give it better oh my oh my oh my give it a little bit okay
i'm good oh thank you thank you okay we have to walk i have
touch touch touch touch i'm gonna need help i'm trying to
yeah i got kicked out of it it's just stuff against that
comp i know i can do there Yeah, triple support is gonna
strong.
Yeah.
I'm sure Batman does probably.
Or even then, they could have played Ultron with Adam.
Should we have played triple support against that?
We just don't have damage if we play triple support.
I guess we can go triple support and like, put Olive on DPS.
Yeah.
I guess that could be the only thing we can do.
all right what does the don't worry the coach would type it
out what we could have done it's just it's just hard because
we don't have the mag open there and their comb has so much
damage i'm not quite sure what we even play there maybe we
could have tried dive or something but even then i just
didn't know i could build my ult faster on during that first
point i literally never stopped healing i let a huge guy no
it's not your fault yeah it's under fault it's just um we
got picked off there we we wasted the i don't somebody we
got picked off we had no rest for when that got picked off
and then they they just got their funny old super fast and
like funny with it's kind of good against rockado because
you can just kind of yeah yeah i mean i guess we could have
maybe tried banning more supports but even then it's just a
hard comp i mean the puncher was farming off of like know
thing and group so it was very easy for them to get all out
yeah well our coach can figure it out for us if we fight
them again coach shoes yeah i think we do need to swap up
strats here but though we need to try something else yeah i
agree we should try two two we can i think we we can i think
uh that or like triple sport we should try
oh it's not Necros muted?
I think Necros is mad.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he's just mad, guys.
I don't be surprised.
But it's okay.
Isn't he always, though?
the life hey if you have to play rivals every single day for
months for months on end you know you can get mad ever so
often it's just the way
they're strong people who stream like competitive games
every single day like night day in and night out they're so
strong they're very strong individuals i will say know how
they do it like doesn't matter if it's rivals rivals
overwatch apex um like i think we we definitely should try
all if like any competitive game day in day they are very
like they are allowed to be mad they're allowed to be but
not fucking toxic as hell though because i will like I said
I have blocked at least two players maybe three I don't know
I just know I blocked every time I see one of theirs I'd
have to see that person in my game I'd be like I like just I
even though they're really good player I don't care if they
fire me I avoid them only because they're so mean I I would
avoid even if like this even the person is like super I mean
I'm too fair I feel like they would have already avoided me
but like I just I like because like if their during the game
like i will block you like what the fuck that's up like like
fine if it's a tournament or if it's like a like a like a
pro tournament whatever like you have justified to be bit
mad but i'm like bro you play how many rank games you in
your life like
you there's you have no like risk involved here you have
nothing to lose okay guys we have another game lock in yeah
all right this is where we lock in right guys we're already
logged in listen first game first game Thanos second no
first game with lucky second game Thanos third game uh
triple supportive users okay four games to be fair lock it
in boys they're all here already by the way the aura the
aura area of booger I'm making the bands invite me okay you
can make the bands dude you have fun with that one did they
add a new update where people can send you money now I keep
getting sent money you can share with me it's fine no I keep
getting people sending me a hundred the teas and I it's like
weird I've never had that oh wait I got one yeah i thought i
thought maybe they were just being like i thought it was a
tournament organizers no i don't i don't i don't know i keep
throwing money sent a hundred latis like every couple of
every couple of minutes why somebody sending me a hundred
letters i don't know booger maybe be a better captain or
something i have wow i am trying my best not a hundred
latice fest though apparently okay buddy you're doing great
booger if i had a hundred latice i would send it to you you
do have a hundred latice though you do no i already spent it
i already his lap is not latice i already spent it's just my
canadian accent all right i'm trying to invite necros he's
got to get out of that sorry sorry sorry yeah yeah i i love
that
well i actually need to okay so i i this is the this is the
turnaround okay we have dropped three games we win four
after this okay all or nothing lock in okay okay yes sir was
that okay okay okay i guess i just want this to be over with
i guess just like no no no no no no no yahoo yahoo but wow
do people tell you you sound like yoshi or no luigi luigi
what does luigi say oh there's ghosts in my benches
you should you should voice act as what random eastern
european goon in a movie hell yeah hell yeah yo arts
arts arts you unmuted and muted again or uh i i can't hear
him i'm so sorry guys uh i think my toggle was like breaking
and keeping me silent don't worry don't worry about it don't
worry feeling man broger loves you tell him to tell him to
ruin him destroy his spirits bathroom we're I'm our welcome
back okay oh thank you for the Twitch Prime thank you thank
you I really appreciate it guys I'm having fun lock in I'm
so locked in everybody's locked in it's me you are locked in
are you exciting in your voice you're like are we locked in
guys yeah we are locked in are you locked in huge i feel
like you're asking that yourself i think just trying to help
guys i i'm locked i'm locked why are you so hesitant why so
yeah like lock and throw away the key guys yeah you are you
like you're asking yourself that question if you were and
get me get me an mvp play
Yes.
I'm locked.
Let them all up.
Wanted to be all of them.
Mm-hmm.
These guys are dead.
I'm following our coach here.
I'm following the, I'm following the, the, um, the list.
The list that's in your head, right?
What?
The list that's in your head.
Do you think you want to be?
You came up yourself.
No.
Shoot.
I ain't gonna laugh.
you're not you're not gonna take credit i'm laughing no
because if i take credit we lose then i like that is kind of
ugly if i don't take credit we lose i can blame you
also oh my god free thank you for the 10 gift itself thank
you thank you thank you yeah yeah yeah yeah oh the cat oh we
save mag this okay which heroes will get my cosmic favor
today i
feel like i feel like not gonna lie this is all been best of
ones but it feels like i played like 10 games already i feel
like okay i don't know i feel like it feels like i played 10
plus games already yeah i like that line i'm like this is
only my fourth game like and we protect mag oh my god it's
only my fourth game um i'm banning mag here and then we
protect what is our second protect neck i think he's muted
he's muted unmute brother unmute three two one zero maybe
he's in the bathroom break me let me think let me think i'm
waiting i'm waiting i mean we probably want to get a hero
for odds right either dino or thing it's okay i can play i
can play either they're not gonna ban both are they uh yeah
they can't they can't ban both you're right you're so right
odds yeah i'll be okay i'll be okay i'll do my best protect
rocket protect rocket we protect rocket all costs i think
rocket protect i i am protecting rocket i think it's okay
sure yeah i they can't ban odds they can't ban anyone else
they can't ban you
do we ban another support yeah whoa what do we even have
left uh no they plant but they ban cloak we banned their
cloak ah uh you have luna available in this we have luna in
this and rocket yeah and rocket
oh they're
you want to try the venom dive here uh or no because you
don't have cat available
a bunny cloak did he do something i mean i don't know and
their team is gonna be weak to dive that's my point oh we
know a lot of magic a lot of magic oh we could we're good
yeah that could be pretty magic with the hood i'm i'm down
to try it yeah and then venom uh we put olive on venom oh no
actually i go mag uh what are we gonna do here uh i kind of
want the mag here i think mag is good um maybe i dive with
you neck uh you go king i'll go thing yeah i'll try to dive
with you neck uh unless you want to play something else do
you feel good on the magic here what do you feel it's gonna
work yeah yeah i think i can do magic i mean is is there a
thing i might have to swap to bucky but like let's just see
what do you want me on uh luna uh snowflake neck or i think
luna is gonna be good just put resource into your neck all
right That's Luna's skin.
Yeah, just play, just follow Olive, guys.
I'm going to take an angle.
Just follow Olive.
Odyssey, play with Olive.
Yes, sir.
Does this team play dive or no?
No.
Okay.
So they're front back.
Well, doesn't Frogger play Iron Face?
I don't know.
I think he's playing Support.
Yeah, he's playing Support Face.
He does.
Watch out with trickery and mines and super spell that we
don't expect.
No, they can't place mines.
Oh, it's a munition.
It's a munition, yeah.
to the mission area just play with play with um olive i'm
gonna take an angle okay yeah i'm gonna walk them i'm
following olive line leader i think they're just walking
main yeah they're just all they're there no they're here
they're here they're here they're here they're here some of
them are main i am gonna can you guys walk up with me here
yeah i can walk i can walk i can walk
Big walled already.
There was one.
More bottom left.
Oh, we got him.
I'm clapping.
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Nice.
Snack.
I'm with you.
Don't die.
I'm healing myself.
Nice.
Do I push with you guys or stay with, stay with the
supports?
Just stay, just stay with the supports.
Okay.
Watch out for us.
And hello.
Let's keep doing this.
You guys can play there.
I'm going to play this top left and I'll come back to main
when they start.
okay yes madam they're on wolf now i stay with support or or
support olive uh you you stay with your supports okay i'll
be okay i'm i'm back there they're all walking yeah two
people left i got them i'm clapping i'm clapping this
I'm clapping for one, for low.
Nice.
Hello, hello?
Hello, hello.
Very good.
I keep doing this.
I want to play...
When you dive, I'll start clapping in them.
I'm going to poke them as they're coming in.
They're going to take that TP over there.
They're triple now.
That's fine.
Don't take that comp suck, right?
Can we kill the Ultron now?
What do you think?
Or the hell?
Hell is main.
No, I can't really kill the Ultron.
I need to sprawl.
to kill like hella or jeff or indus ideally okay jeff is one
66 i'm gonna go into this room though am i am i am i'm i'm
walking i'm clapping i'm clapping i'm clapping it she's low
she's low she's low dino's half i'm shooting the ultron huge
huge i'm on i'm on frozen uh looking dynamically half dino
half dino low left side dino still low nice job guys you're
the ping late ping yeah they are i have i vote for this if
we need i don't think we need i don't think we need we don't
yeah they've already they use portal too so guys
yay uh i'm imagining we can actually look to go aggro with
magic holton hood maybe Should we use Rocket first or Luna
first?
Let's do this.
Let's do this instead.
Let me use mine and I'll probably cancel it when they
support out.
And I'll just force support it without.
And that's a good start.
I think I can just one shot.
They have triple.
They have Ultron.
Rocket, Rocket, and my ult.
And maybe I can just one shot them.
I think that's going to work.
Let's try that.
Listen, guys, at least we're going to clip farm.
You mean you're going to clip farm.
You got the POV.
You got a card for net or what?
I'm going out of this tournament a winner, no matter what.
You're going to get that million views on TikTok.
That's what I'm saying, though.
Can you get it?
I get it.
Come point.
Okay, so...
I'm just walking my way.
I'm walking my way.
Yeah, I'm walking man.
Yeah.
Just rock out.
Bougar ult.
I'm going to go straight for him.
Are you ready to rock it out already?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They do one now.
Nice.
Good farm.
I just got screwed over.
That's awesome.
Shark, shark, shark.
I'm not sure.
He was.
It's technically a shark.
It was a big ass shark.
Stick with support here, me?
Yes, yes, yes.
Staying.
Just stay singing.
I'll let you heal.
Let's go back.
Can we catch them early here?
Yeah, I'm ready.
If you dive, I'll have clap ready for it.
I'm going here.
Let's go here.
Nice.
I'm out.
Out, out, out.
We cannot help him.
If he dies, he dies, bro.
We accept this shit.
That's on him.
I mean, you guys could take damage and then he'll get heals.
Help all of us.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
If I have to, I'll try and force it out.
Come back, back, back, back, back.
Full ass, full ass.
Just let me heal a little bit so...
Oh, okay, no, it's okay.
Yeah, we can heal.
Yeah, you can heal.
No, no, it's fine.
You heal now.
You need your ult.
Okay.
I placed a shield there.
I got one.
Break walls, break walls, break walls.
I'm eating.
I can't... I can't...
Get out.
Okay.
Oh, I...
You're out.
My bad.
I need heals though for this.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
They were shielded.
I'm leaving.
I shielded you.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I froze someone.
I'm actually going to look to play.
I'm rolling.
I'm with you.
I'm in.
Nice.
I'll let you heal.
Wait, wait.
By the portal?
I'll let you heal.
20% 20 seconds.
They might portal.
They're on Strange.
Bro, I'm in.
They are on Strange.
Yeah, I think I'm back, back, back, back.
I can keep you back.
Yeah, it's just that's just- Yeah, they're portal, portal,
portal, portal, portal, portal, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, all good, okay.
Play with it.
Help her.
Uh, uh, don't, don't blow up.
Nice.
Uh, we didn't die once this game.
I got the- Don't die, don't die, don't die.
I got a Phoenix.
Good job.
Oh my goodness.
Yay.
New- We did it!
Matt, new magic team up is broken.
Yeah, he deserves 100 lattes after that.
It's so much pressure.
100 lattes.
Yeah, he deserves that 100 lattes after that, guys.
Thank you.
Bo-ger.
Who said that?
Oh, it was you.
Oh, it was you?
Fucked up.
Wait, why?
uh no nothing nothing why why lock in lock in i'm just a
stupid mag one trick again god damn it my stupid mag one
trick chunga's life it always comes back to it's okay mag's
meta though he's meta this is the perfect time to be a mag i
know we just need a different comp if mag isn't open that's
it like i like you on group but he's weak i think we could
guess if mag isn't open I think triple tank without mag is
so difficult.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
If you want to play like strange or something.
We can try that.
I'm down.
Oh, true.
Yeah, you did say triple tank.
Probably not the best.
I just think we just need more damage or triple support even
like we might like maybe we whip it out.
Triple support.
I know.
Oh, we stay in this lobby by the way.
We don't.
Yeah.
We stay in this lobby for the rest of the day.
Anything anything I could have done different guys.
I mean, we had two of them.
No, I think I think you did good that you stick with the.
mitigation e little leaps useful at all am i timing them
well or are they a bit redundant do i kind of save them for
bad trouble better like any comments on if you bug at all
all listen when it's a stump like this i i can't tell you
anything it's just impossible but like annually i'm sorry
it's like you were perfect man that's good that's good you
played your role that's all that matters i mean i mean you
listened when we said just play with a demon like that was
good because like yeah it just lowers the chance of you
making a mistake and it's no of course of course no you made
super easy for me this time around amazing and honestly i
don't know what the hell necros is cooking up behind enemy
lines but i do not share the recipe dude whatever you're
doing down there yeah yeah that magic team i felt really
good i think we should run magic is she feels good on thing
yeah it's probably my best though yeah we can i'm down who
left oh necros
it might be again yeah i need my practice range you got
practice range right here you have a practice you're right
you're right you're right so stupid uh we have punch kid
bunny steam to play ship steam um i like the support band
line that's pretty good yeah shout out to our coach he was
the one that got us that win if anybody he deserves a
hundred lattice guys our coach was like ban all the supports
how much money is a hundred ladders i don't know but one
dollar it's like i got sent like at least 400 so one jesus i
don't know i think it must be a new patch put it put it in a
fun seven for your kids got my fault four dollar runies my
lattice fund i i think for the rest of the team so i'm
pretty sure we just keep banning supports or the other teams
just all support players or when they have a lot of support
players or like do you guys think their less experienced
player by giving them by forcing them into shark or yeah
yeah it was just like forcing because shark is weak
everybody puts their worst players on rocket and like rocket
just gets infant but not you huge not you not we're not
talking about you no i mean i acknowledge i acknowledge
rocket is strong and also that a weaker person should play
the rocket i was even This is why you're not sent a hundred
lad.
This is why.
It's okay.
I was telling chat yesterday, I think I'm going to be on
Rocket Jail, but I must accept it.
Yeah.
Rocket is just infinite value.
He's just high value with the res and the whole.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
I like that.
It's okay, Boker.
I won't remember that later.
I won't cry myself to sleep and be like, I'm just so weak as
fucking chit on the team.
fuck my stupid fucking support guys taking a 30 seconds
break to get some more caffeine like if this goes on for a
few hours i'm already starting to yawn like a motherfucker
oh my god how old is odds like 45 i think really he sounds
like a young a young whipper snapper really
guys all like mid 20s how old are you how old are you why
are you saying that i'm almost 29 i turned 29 in september
oh you're gonna be a hag soon yeah i'm looking forward to
hag maxing like oh i went did you go to bingo i was i did i
did bingo on the cruise you know how they cost like they
cost like 30 plus dollars per bingo sheet that shit is like
yeah that shit is just pieces of paper i don't understand
it's because the jackpot's too big right bro it was like it
was like okay the first game was like 800 and the second was
a thousand dollars but then if you multiple people win it
they have to split the prize so like yeah so i was just like
one one in the first game six people won bingo so they it
just pays off the bingo sheet because some people buy like
years to the bingo so there was one that was like a hundred
plus dollars but you get 32 bingo sheets but like 30 of them
are on a digital tablet so like whenever they call a number
the tablet would be like ding ding ding for bingo stuff and
i was just like do you really need 32 sheets like like what
the fuck i don't know the the oldies yearn for the bingo
sheets
like twenty dollars it's just what yeah it's just a pen that
it's just a circular pen that you just stamp it but
apparently it's not like like they won't consider it bingo
if it's not stamped by the bingo marker it's wow yeah bro
bingo goes hard you should like it it's crazy yeah i do want
to go on my first cruise you look low-key inspiring me oh
it's relaxing it's so like i feel i want to i'm in the
bahamas still it's really nice thanks so much on supporting
us there in spirit guys flanking from the bahamas they will
see incoming you was asking how old you are oh how old i am
yeah how old are you i'm 30 i'm 30 i'm 33 but i yeah i'm 33
but i always think i'm one year older younger really i
thought you were younger yeah she thought you were young
young man no yeah i have a i'm in the i'm in the twilight of
my life guys no i i can feel the downhill like steep down no
i'll let you guys know what it's like next tournament we
play residence home i know you've been doing dead by
daylight content um the game came out in 2016 but i up like
a year and a half later or two years later oh so since
you're like oh g-o-g no no no there's people that have been
there longer i've just like i've just had such consistent
love from that community and i've been so consistently like
you know i don't know absorbed by it um it's only been
recently that that i've i've i've loosened my grip a little
bit and and tried a few other things a little bit more on
the side well why have you been is just like starting to get
stale or no no i think as of as of a couple of years ago
like i i've been stretching myself a little bit thin i like
to help newer players and i keep up a little website that i
try to update so people can check it's kind of like imagine
if you go on on rivals info.com and it just tells you okay
this character not good for beginners this character not the
best this one solid pick and it's looking like it will be
for the next season too like stuff like that and i do enjoy
that a lot and I'm doing that a bit more and more but I'm a
bit less I'm taking the game a bit less seriously just
because there's so many things outside of your control
sometimes you know and I feel like when the game is doing
great I ride the wave but when the game is not doing great
or there's controversy or people aren't happy like I feel
like it got to me a little bit so I'm trying to distance
myself a little bit if that makes sense like keep a
healthier approach the dead by daylight drama stuff yeah
I've seen some of that oh yeah it's honestly it's been
nothing burger after nothing burger recently what was the
most stupid drop wait is it okay to ask that or people are
gonna start i'm actually what was the most messed up drama
yes or stupid the most stupid one you think oh my god fad
the flames or is your chat gonna start arguing about it's
like no it's not stupid i mean it can be anything from like
the community being in a broar about things that the devs
haven't announced that got leaked that didn't end up
happening you know so there's been there's been petitions
for the debbs to not do something that was leaked that then
turned out to never be in the plan anyway uh yeah the the
most recent what is the most recent big controversy um okay
so they are releasing a new character yeah that was kind of
community voted imagine that instead of like their own
original vision they kind of went like a poll and it's like
okay how do you want this character to be okay range okay
how do you want this character to be?
Okay, a tank.
Okay, you know, like, we all build it together.
And this character is very, very, very difficult to play.
Like, it's probably the hardest character to play in the
game.
So now the current big debate is like, is it a good thing
that it's difficult?
Or are we going to make this inaccessible to all of the
community or to a big part of the community?
And yeah, I'm not going to lie.
Like, seeing some of the takes on it, like, it makes me a
bit upset.
It makes me a bit upset that some people are very black and
white and the thing about you had to satisfy everybody you
know they yeah like someone's gonna have something wrong
with it yeah and the DVD community it's like two sub
communities right because there are people that play both
sides but most people will play one side only or one side
primarily so they you also have two people pointing at each
other and pretending that their issues are the important
ones and on the other side has a super easy but they don't
want to switch you know what i mean it's like it's like if i
play support and i say oh the ps is so easy you guys have it
so easy this season i'll switch to the ps no you know like i
see that's interesting i've never played dead by day i've
always seen i've always watched it from afar i like all the
memes from it how people are like always like yeah i like
this if there's ever a new licensed character that you're
like oh i like like for example they're bringing terrifier
this year i don't know if you're familiar with those movies
if there's ever a character you want to try it out and you
need some help you let me know yeah i like it all like i
know they did a resident evil crossover they did fanaf and
everything oh my god that was huge man that's huge that was
like last like a year and a half ago yeah oh yeah nicholas
cage isn't dead by daylight that one that one got lit by the
way i i wake up one day and i see a video on twitter i'm
like dude this this fake is
guy why is he in here I'm sad he wasn't a killer though I
mean it would be an honor to be killed by Nicholas Cage in
game in game of course it doesn't tell you who gives you
lattice you just receive it yeah that's what I'm saying you
got lattice too everyone's got lattice except for Bougar but
everyone's got Latter you all have you all have zero hours
in DVD you're all completely green like I was on rivals
three weeks I have zero hours I've never played it.
Oh, no, I have a few hundred.
I had a face.
That's nice.
I like it.
I watch Tensin play DVD sometime.
Oh, Tensin, truly Tensin?
Yeah.
I met them in real life a million years ago.
They are super nice.
Oh, really?
Yeah, she's so nice.
I love her.
That's wonderful.
Well, if any of you need a helping hand getting into the
game, they'll be intimidated.
I would love to.
Yeah.
I think I would have a heart attack.
What's my character?
No, what's the easiest character?
to play as a beginning.
Okay, so if you play Suburber, which is the role that has
four people, they're all skins of each other.
Like they don't, it doesn't really matter.
You pick one, you get slightly different abilities to begin
with, but Suburber is all the same and it doesn't really
matter and you can, it's very, very simple.
If you don't buy any DLCs or pick up any packs, you start
with five different killers that all do different things,
but you have a few really good ones for beginners as well.
So you could play one of the easy killers that is just a
little bit stealthy.
And since there is a MMR system that pairs you with other
people of your similar experience, you're probably gonna
destroy them, even if you just do the bare minimum.
Then later the game becomes a little harder.
There's no ranked mode in this game.
Like it doesn't really separate pools.
So it is a bit chaotic sometimes.
If you do a bit too well, the game will still go because
that's because there's like hidden MMR types.
Yeah, exactly.
But one thing that they often do nowadays is that they have
like multiple game modes.
They do like stupid little summer stuff.
And those are very casual and super easy to get into.
oh please i didn't mean to interrupt go ahead what nobody
said anything no i i was just saying yeah no then do finish
your long yeah that's cool i don't mind trying i never tried
it before i just see it's like i always see the people like
like always like competitive tag in the way because you're
trying to tag the survivors The funniest things is that,
like, especially if you play Survivor, like, no other game
plays like this.
Like, you got people like Shroud that play this game and
they play it for 20 minutes for a little streamer
tournament.
And they quit it on the spot, say they don't want to play
the game.
Oh, wait, they quit on the streamer tournament on the spot?
No, they played it.
Yeah, there was a big streamer tournament organized by, I
think, like, a big sponsor, right?
And one of the games, it was kind of like a multiple game
gauntlet.
and the game has become a little bit better for beginners
nowadays but especially back then it doesn't tell you how to
unlock fps back then you had to go into the game files to
unlock the fps it doesn't tell you how to change there were
no gamma filters like the game was so inaccessible edit the
files yourself and everything yeah yeah yeah so for a person
that's used to like serious games with like a million
settings for everything he like he and other people get
pissed off and they don't understand what's going on and
yeah like luckily there are like for example in the now like
tutorials and stuff that is a bit yeah because i know
there's like hidden because i know something because i've
seen like the discourse about on twitter there's like hidden
rules too for dead by daylight where like you know the
survivors would be mad if you killed them too fast or some
shit yeah it's a it's a whole thing it's a whole thing and i
mean i was i'm supposed to know that like i'm a killer i'm
supposed to kill right i mean honestly you just need to go
some common courtesy rules make sense for example yeah that
by daylight there's no timer on screen if one side decides
to hide they can take so like they can literally just tell
you forever if they want you if they do it effectively there
are there are some strategies on both sides that can hold
the other person hostage for oh millions of years so that
like doing that i mean it's not nice right like there's
nothing like there's nothing preventing you from doing it
but you shouldn't do it Yeah, I get that.
Yeah, because then you're just like, you're holding in
hostage.
It's like, you're not allowed to leave this game.
Like, I get that.
But sadly, sadly, the the made up rules and stuff, it just
comes from people that play one side and have zero empathy
for the other.
Like, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
That would be like, if I played healer in this game and I'm
like, why am I, why is the venom coming to me, man?
I would never do that.
If I played venom, I would never do that.
Yeah, it's like, how dare you dive us in.
they ready oh okay oh they have oh 15 i didn't realize we're
on a 15 minute break when did that break started guys i need
to piss all right i'm gonna go piss thank you thank you i
love i love that this is an airport dude and we're like
announcing departures like oh my gosh
that's interesting i mean for a game that's been out for
like 10 years i assume like there's just so much built into
it is it like is it easy to get in to is like begin like
because i know like like there's games like rainbow six
siege where it's like super hard to like no no like the the
biggest asset of the game is that at almost any level it's
fun it's the game is genuinely fun and it's so chaotic and
if you if you know how to laugh at yourself a little bit and
especially if you play with friends i think the game is fun
and you know when you begin you're like oh my god i got i
got pulled from my neck around the corner by a killer that
doesn't make any noise and that's stealthy, you know, and
it's, if you laugh about it, you will have a great time.
The worst thing that you could do, I think, is, I don't
know, play it by yourself.
Whenever there's something tilting or frustrating happens,
refuse to take any kind of like minute to like look into
what exactly killed you or what exactly annoyed you.
And then basically end up isolated.
And obviously like in any multiplayer game, you're going to
have a game.
where you're learning something, the other side, whether
it's the survivor or the killers, they stomp you, and then
they are horrible sports about it, right?
Yeah, some people have that happen and they try to take it
out on the next video, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
And it starts a cycle.
Yeah, it starts the cycle.
It's like, I got bullied, so I'm going to fuck with you and
I'm going to hold you hostage for 60 minutes now, right?
Well, the best thing you can do with this game is generally
to play with friends.
If you play a bit of killer, stream it to your buddies or
stream it to your audience.
or or do little you can do custom games as well with five
people yeah it's fun it's fun yeah i mean i feel like games
are always more fun when you're playing with people you know
yeah or that yeah in dvd in dvd in particular yeah i think
we're all here yes just been chilling sir i've been learning
about dead by daylight poker have you played dead by
daylight before nope never you should try it odds with t my
it's you coach odds coach you if i if i ever get 20 hours
with him i will make him a beast dude i would make it i'm
dialing in i'm gonna ruin the lobby of every player which
one killer will you pick boker uh kaneki from tokyo oh my
god that's so funny oh i didn't realize tokyo cool was in it
that there's no no way to make someone like this is like you
wicker on the other side as like oh yeah i'm gonna start the
game i'm gonna play kaneki like like what's up with kaneki
in in dead by daylight like what's Okay, so when he came
out, right, and initially he was a little buggy on the
testing branch, right, but when he released, he had a killer
that basically had the powers of like two killers combining
to one, and it was unreasonably good.
He had great mobility.
He basically puts you in an injured state that you cannot
begin to heal from.
So imagine that in rival's terms, I do hop, you know, 50%
damage to a tank and I apply a debuff that unless they
disengage and run back and I let them go, they can never
heal.
Which basically stops a lot of things that you could do
against them.
It stops them on the tracks.
And if you do need to heal, it's slower.
And if you don't, well, it counterplays a lot.
On top of being very, very, very, very, very fast, his first
injury is immediate.
Almost every other killer in the game.
has to work a little bit to injure you.
Some of them it's easier, some of them it's harder.
But you have resources, right?
You can drop pallets and do things that delay the killer.
And I mean, if you're quite lucky, you can just delay,
delay, delay.
And if the first damage comes really, really low, really,
really slow, like the killer will be stolen, right?
This killer just, if he sees you, he injures you.
I see.
So he's got mobility, he injures you almost immediately.
He will not let you heal as quickly as other characters as
well.
And on top of that, he also has an ability that allows him
to ignore a certain obstacle on release especially right
right now not so much so yeah people would put him on they
would put a certain amount of like certain abilities so they
made him more accurate I don't know I honestly don't know
but they just made him play like every Kaneki you played
against had the same had the same abilities equipped they
did the exact same thing they also had like a built-in
equipable add-on which is like a team up, I guess, in this
game, that if you equip it, you make the counterplay even
harder.
And it was just very unreasonable.
Compared to other killers, he was way, way better than the
average and way easier than almost every killer in the game.
And for that reason, after he came out, for the next, I want
to say six months at least, he was the most popular
character by a long shot.
You could play against him five times in a row and he would
feel like you're playing the same match five times in a row.
But yeah, if Bower wants to play it, dude, I'm gonna make
him a beast.
I'm down.
Yeah, it's gonna be you, Boger.
I mean, he was also really fun because you can zoom around
the map, right?
Oh, yeah, that's the worst part.
The worst part is that you can't even be mad at the people
playing it.
Because he is a really skill-expressive character at higher
levels.
And he's very fun.
So, yeah, that sucks.
I used to play a lot of Dead by Daylight, but I played
Ghostface.
Yeah, and I had so much fun in the beginning.
I was like, main in Ghostface.
And then I got to the higher brackets and I was like, this
game fucking sucks.
Yeah, that is the lived experience of hundreds of thousands
of people.
Yeah, the moment the SVM is, Ghost is right now bottom three
worst killers in the game.
Yeah, yeah.
He's so fun.
He's so cool.
Man, I just liked playing Oni.
I love Oni so much.
Oni is great.
Guys, I'm sorry to ruin your parade here, but are we ready?
We're ready.
We're so dead.
Yeah, I'm dead.
Are, oh yeah, okay.
Okay, I was looking who was doing bad.
fans yeah are you are booger don't worry i am making sure
i'm scared i'm terrified okay terrified which is scary
actually i'm gonna use the bathroom real quick that's all
right that's like 20 years what do they play what did uh
support they have three support players so i am just bad not
i am planning on banning their support basically that's my
strat save mag if available save thing if they ban mag uh
there might ban cat First, we shall see.
I'm banning Mantis first.
It's either Mantis or Rotoron.
I think I'd rather ban Mantis.
I'm not going to lie.
I think mantis.
Don't we also want to take Mag off of them more?
We can.
But we can.
But I think...
Yeah, we can.
They put...
It's fine.
I'd rather ban Nix supports.
I think I banned Rocket feed.
Guys, is it bad?
My skin started scratching my nose and...
my skin started peeling off because i got a sunburned on my
face a little is that should i start peeling or let it
naturally peel i'm protecting mag i've no i don't remember i
haven't been sunburned a third band can be ultron and that
shuts down all sports oh it's too late i scratched off a bit
of skin already i'm down the band see look i asked this
after i peeled my skin a little oh yeah i'll abandon them i
don't really care too much why even i well so i can stop now
we played i'll stop now i say okay we love repeal there's
like a long one i'm protecting all right i'm done i'm
protecting they want to do ultram if they're banning
spider-man we should see we should see i can do tingo dino
do what's best for the team man like i think i think
probably okay no i've been putting it low and uh i think
we've been putting it low i'm not gonna lie i've been that's
why i've been you see me looking now it's just i was molting
if they protect ultron if they protect ultron i knew it i
knew toky was a lizard person i fucking knew it then he
couldn't ban you don't i mean yeah yeah all content creators
for lizard people all along yeah we can ban ultron here if
you want to or i banned something else like are you scared
of team captain something
want to ban i maybe i want to ban a wolf because we're gonna
be doing triple tank but no yeah we are triple tank right we
want to yeah i'm down against him captain i'm down three two
just yes yeah yeah okay because i feel like if it starts
going wrong for them he might go wolf not that he plays it a
lot but what do we what do we play uh go cloak cloak all
right cloak and dagger we are hope and okay docky beard 300
decibel blinding a name all right all right say it's so loud
i wish you never say it again just put me at 200 just put me
at 200 bucky by the way but i still have magic go magic i
their backlings weak honestly dude it works really work
they're backlings really weak i mean we could do mantis luna
uh yeah they won't play dive so we can try that honestly i'm
kind of okay but um i like the cloak a lot though i like the
blinding blinding man energy is a breeze blinding to put
money don't waste it will be coming in 30 seconds stay
strong oh odds just stay with all the uh olive yes yeah
olive i'm like a block pound let me let me let me get your
scent he's down loading he's down loading and when their
tanks get close if you would uh you get 100 lattice just
remember that 100 lattice is on yeah 100 lattice 100 lattice
i'm probably not not going to cross this bridge right here
just poking for damage yeah they're on electron that's fine
they have thor maybe yeah they're top left is that way up
yeah yes it is yeah i want to be i want to be another there
guys i cannot get to you no it's my bad it's okay we have to
give up this corner now we have to get with this corner okay
we do we're gonna look for grab on me soon yeah thor above i
can do it are we are we going for the back everyone throw
everyone blind blinded blinded blinded blinded throw one
throw one throw one and i hope you're not i i'm keeping you
up throw again throw again difficult corner difficult corner
for me shielding i'm trying to get to you i'm trying to get
to you i oh i'm so sorry let's try i was left clicking so
hard i'm a neutron i'm out i'm out i don't have a nice kill
nice kill Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor, Tor.
I have a bubble in there.
Can you blind him?
I can't see him.
Oh, behind us!
I'm blinded.
I'm dead.
I'm dying here.
Can we regroup and like TP?
I'll die here.
Yeah, that's fine.
I have all in 20.
Can I chase us here?
They can't chase us.
Nice cap.
They're stalling.
I'm stalling.
I'm just poking for damage.
We can just push up.
One of you has the TP.
Yeah, no, we don't.
We can touch.
Oh, we don't.
Okay, my brother.
No, so close.
I'm last coming in now.
Don't die.
I have a bubble.
I have a bubble here.
Oh, I got bursted.
That's my fault.
90, 90, 90.
Oh, we can't touch that.
We are left side.
Thor is on me.
This is his side.
He's down.
Are we letting them kill us?
I don't think we make this.
Yeah.
I'm going to go Elsa, I think.
You think Elsa?
Yeah.
What about Wolf?
I don't think Wolf will go DPO.
Do you guys want me to change approach or?
You can try dinosaur maybe.
What do you think?
Dinosaur would be fine here.
I love here.
Yeah, just grab the door.
Just grab the door.
Grab the door, got it.
Yeah, just grab the door.
I mean, you're MVP.
You're locked in.
I will try.
If we get closer, I can start blinding.
Yeah, we kind of need to blow up the door here.
I'm pushing up.
I'll turn it up.
Nice.
Oh.
Widow.
I don't know.
If you want me a cloak, I'll call for it.
I am not gonna lie, I don't know how to navigate this space.
I stand behind all these bugs!
Fine, it's fine, come back, come back.
No, you're good.
But we can call for that cloak out here for me?
Uh, they have maggos.
Okay, they have maggos.
We just need to bubble here.
Yeah, I have a bubble.
Yeah, we're done.
We're the only one.
I'll monitor you.
I have the bubble.
Do you have bubble?
I'll cloak all this to get bubble.
I have 14.
I'm going in.
Okay.
Let's你在 widow.
RT, right side.
Right side, right side.
It's fine.
You're just gonna do- I'm oğlum.
It's okay.
Yeah, bubble.
Ja bubble.
I have been in three.
Go under.
Oh, I think that was trying to.
Yeah, they're just keeping, um.
We can't.
Guys, it's okay if I go like the thing, I'm not feeling it.
Yeah, go for it.
Go for it.
That's okay.
Listen, listen.
We need to touch here.
We need to touch.
Yeah, if you can touch it'll be good.
Jio?
You touch with Blen.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Oh, that works.
Interesting.
side oh wow i died through that so you're good oh my god
she's dying yeah they're just kind of blowing us up oh yeah
oh i'll die here i just do smoke pool i don't know let's
just smoke we'll walk in with uh maybe i need to die here
dying with blind it was just a little bit tough possible
um can we stay cloak uh you can mark yeah i'll do man i'll
try to mark or olive can mark What corner are we trying to
hold on to?
The very last one?
No, no.
I need Kareviki.
I'm getting hard.
Yeah, I'm making good.
I'm gonna push up for Karev's right side.
I'm walking this way.
You guys walking up.
I'm walking up.
Yeah, I'm walking up here.
I need else.
Trying to keep you up.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
She's looking lower.
She's low.
Can you get her?
We'll turn one, we'll turn one.
I need you guys to watch that be...
He double, he double, double, double, double.
Yeah, play with her.
We're dead full and it's like...
I'm trying to keep her up.
I slept cloak, I slept cloak.
What the fuck just happened?
There's a thwart, thwart, thwart, thwart.
Any help here?
Oh, he got pushed me back.
He pushed me back.
Beholds the god of thunder!
I think I can help you there.
Yeah, I'm close to all.
I'm 10.
I can hang in here, but I'm not gonna die I got one I'm
coming around the corner where you do something about this
Uh You can't even see Madzou Did you play with Madzou
Machi??
There's a mag I'm ulti Yeah push it push it push it push it
push it Probably gonna go dps plus or smoke guys midway I
think they're good Dork here behind us On me, on me, on me.
Yeah.
On me, door, door, door.
I'm looking.
He's one, he's one.
Oh, he's half, he's half, he's up.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
No, it's not, it's not you.
That was it.
Come back, come back, come back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We only have mantis.
You only have mantis.
I'm gonna need help out.
All right, we have support.
Go back, go back, go back.
Go back.
Should I go for the back?
Come back, come back.
Out, out, out, out, out.
Out, out, out, out, out, come back, come back.
Play together, play together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to let you heal.
I'm pushing in, pushing in.
Help him, help him, help him, help him.
No, I can bubble.
I'm trying.
We almost have Luna would play for that.
Yeah, I'm trying to.
Yeah, Widow keeps... I'm holding!
Otherwise, it's over, right?
No, just stay behind.
You can keep saying.
You almost have Luna would.
She got hit, she got hit.
I got hit.
Sorry.
Trying to keep you up.
Yeah, I'm on a touch plan.
It's okay.
I just think we should do this comp, but like, uh, this
rubble from the start.
Yeah, I'm down with that.
I live to fight another day.
The score is 0, 2, 3.
0, 2, 3.
Are we definitely going to focus on Thor more, maybe?
Because he hasn't...
I think he's well-being.
No, he's just doing a lot.
I think we can write this.
I'm getting uh I don't know what to do against both widow
and ultron poke so yeah we just could go daredevil to mark
the widow but like I'm gonna get marked by thor and then I
don't know what I'm gonna do I think it's like possible uh
yeah I'm marking the widow but I can't mark both of them and
would also I can just take angles that it's okay yeah um I
we can run this we can try this this looks um surrounding
their tour and tour is like a pretty big deal here it's kind
of like the widow angle and the tour and the mag it's just
too much do i need to be shifting him or grounding him yeah
yeah you can ground him he can't leave should i should i be
looking to do that or prioritize no no you don't you don't
need shifts or anything else you want to find this where are
we sure oh you want me i can also play ultron too it's
better um we can i can go mag
Yeah, do that.
You good with like Punisher?
Yeah, Punisher is good.
Punisher is so good.
I mean, they have, I guess...
What about Wolf?
I can wall it.
I can wall, but it's still a DPS.
Wolf is cool.
I can wall, but still the DPS wall is cool.
Oh, I'd rather play.
Door is top right.
Door top right.
Going on our back.
Door is on.
He's still beyond.
They're just giving us room.
Yeah.
No sleep from my end.
Thor up?
Thor up here?
He's... Oh, he's just playing by himself.
It's fine.
You already got him off.
As long as you're occupying him, we're back here.
You can stay with us here.
Yeah, we'll do, we'll do.
All right, Thor is here now.
Any help?
Thank you, sir.
Yeah, yeah, I'm walking up.
Oh, cloak, cloak, cloak, cloak.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
It's fine.
Thor is behind us.
He's asleep.
I'm behind it, back up.
I'm trying to do it.
Widow's still on high behind us.
Widow left, yeah.
Widow 1, Widow 1.
Widow 1, Widow, you're the one he should be here.
Very good.
Nice.
That wouldn't blow me.
He's asleep.
Yeah, he's also frozen.
Where are you seeing?
He's behind us.
I see him.
He's half, he's half, he's one.
He's one, one, one.
I can't do it.
Oh, still here, still here.
Yeah.
here i'll be honest let's just stay on i can use it
aggressively you want it yeah go for it okay three two one
go ahead look now we have ultron out here i might get hit by
that perfect precision live live live live live live i'm
trying to oh hi this doesn't oh i'm just stuck uh he's a bit
isolated he's bubbled and oh live live live live live i have
my own they used to invest in these widow yeah we're gonna
walk with support for now yeah i'm okay with that yeah we
have three funny old two and set the camera uh throw right
side try not to leave me if you can i'm a little should i
luna i'm gonna luna oh no no i'm oh sorry oh i'm supporting
it's fine it's fine push up push up his damage boosted um
hey throw behind us one point uh widow two widow two people
three people behind us and also I'll try yeah I
know what if what do you feel like going here I know what's
maybe go triple tank again I can do it we can do it and we
got two waltz from me and Bougar yeah I'm so I think you
know You mean damage here?
Do you want me to time mine with yours in any way?
No, just land your roof.
I slept someone?
Push it back a bit, push it back a bit?
Here I'm alting it.
I'm pushing in.
Oh, my god.
Can you live?
I'm trying to kite out, but I need help though.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
Yeah, I got pulled back here.
Yo,
please stop.
We kill him.
Please.
You can't have zero deaths.
Give him one.
Yes.
Give him one death.
Maybe two.
Yeah.
I'm trying to reach him.
Michael.
Oh, I might get hit by that actually.
Yeah, there's a widow to a far right.
We go right side.
Little flank.
No supports, no supports, no supports.
Yeah, Trey supports.
Okay, I got him.
I'm on HP.
I think I'm coming off with...
Yeah, I'm chilling.
You were behind still?
Yeah, she's behind.
I'm on HP.
I'm going to die.
Oh, they're just all taking angles like crazy.
We're the one, we're the one.
Literally one.
I gave you damage for Snakes.
Can you stay upon him?
Live, live.
You stay upon Alex.
You have to stay upon Alex.
Yeah, we're on fine.
I want the old from.
I'll give you damage.
Uh, do I want to...
Bottle leg?
Oh.
Porto, Porto, Porto!
We have to stay.
Oh, they're coming from the back of it!
They're dead, they're dead.
I'm just waiting.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Nice.
Are you damage boost?
Can you shoot him?
I'm shooting.
He's lower, we can just play other side.
Yeah.
I'm on the Ultron.
Widow flanking again.
Widow flanking behind us.
Okay.
Get ready.
Okay, nice.
He's low behind.
I'm on the cloak.
Uh, Pamela Exchange!
Pamela Exchange!
Nice.
Pretty good.
Oh, a third point, third point.
He's grounded.
Nice, good job.
I will.
It's just really annoying the way they play.
Good stuff.
We can do it.
We can push through.
Yeah, you're the MVP right now.
I'm just trying to damage boost me.
I'm going to be off on this.
Yeah, I'm damaged.
Like jump on their backline.
Who needs me to have their back?
No, you're doing great.
Who needs me?
Who do I latch onto if anyone?
Oh, no, you're good.
I'm on cart.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to hold Hyatt, so...
How many characters are possible?
I don't know how to play this next section.
If you guys tell me where to position myself, I'll do my
best.
Oh, okay.
Good.
You can stay low right there.
I'm just slam Thor whenever he comes.
We're just gonna hold, maybe.
I showed you, Duke.
Yeah, he does level.
We don't main.
I'm coming.
Oh, wait.
That's unfortunate.
That's one lucky.
That's unbelievable.
That's brutal.
Yeah, there's nothing you can do there.
We'll do it.
Okay, no, we're good.
We're good.
Stay.
god of thunder looking clear what a function oh i died
through that what do i want to do that is all right they use
they use three ultra that oh we have no supports there wait
cloak hit cloak hit i'm so sorry no it's okay maybe we
killed our no that's interesting you damage
yeah i have my old here we got about a minute maybe i'll do
a tron You want me to use aggressively or defensively?
Oh, we can go aggro, we can take it.
I'll be honest.
Pull up, pull up.
Pull up over there, main.
I'm gonna confess there for me.
Come in with Magneto and we push him off or?
I slept him.
Nice spawn in the back then.
Thor is hard looking for me.
He's hard looking.
You guys are chilling.
Mag, it's just Mag on the cart.
Oh, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
Yeah, you're fine, you're fine.
Oh, I'm not dead.
Thank you.
I'm not dead.
All right.
Man's silk?
I need it.
Yeah.
I'm hitting Ultron after this.
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak, Cloak.
Relo, Relo, Relo, Relo.
No, no, don't come near, don't come near.
Don't, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just, we have to split up there.
Two on me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got pulled.
I'm the only one on point, guys.
I'm the only one on point.
Yeah, it's okay.
Yeah, you need to wait.
We need to regroup.
Yeah.
We have anything here.
All the castle.
Yeah, I have a little, but I don't get a touch point.
You're going to have to walk up something, though.
I'll walk.
I fly.
Oh, uh, third left side.
Yeah, yeah.
You mark him.
Hold up.
I tried.
Two went up.
Looking ultram with this.
We have to push for it.
You have to push for it.
Yeah, yeah.
I got him.
I want a mag.
Yeah, mag low.
Mag low.
Yeah, Tori's behind.
I'm still alive.
Watch out, Widow.
Watch out Widow down the street.
Yeah, I'm gonna try to contest here.
Okay.
We have Thor right side top.
Yeah.
I got all any priority for it.
I just landed on somebody.
Just like before if he pushes in.
Do your best, I believe.
I will try, I will try, I will try.
I will try.
I'm all in the map, bro.
He moves me.
I'm gonna be back.
Oh, I got hit by the widow.
We have Lunal soon, though.
No.
Get a TP coming back.
I can stall a little bit.
Max, a bit low.
Max, a bit low if we can somehow push him.
I'm looking.
I have bubble.
I'm going to throw bubble in the center.
I'm playing.
He's going to book me.
Should I portal?
No.
We already have.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
We don't want to have Lunal.
I'm off.
Oh, oh, my God.
Oh, I'm off.
it's okay they're just off-handling demons all of them it's
kind of difficult too much i'll be honest it was kind of
difficult it was like six angles that's real yeah it was
like the widow horn angle and the ultron taking angle and
then just the or taking an angle this town felt cursed man
it was like the neighborhood was against us yeah people were
opening the windows and and drenching us with like a bucket
of water dude Yeah.
Is that the last game?
No, we have two more.
We have two more, Nick.
We have two more.
Oh, it's one.
Seems to have him played, but.
What could we have done for that?
That was so hard to play against.
I mean, I didn't think we should have banned the war.
I mean, I think the bandit war with the Ultron.
No, no, we should have protected Bucky.
I think that was the thing we should have done.
I think so.
I think Bucky was really good there.
Yeah, the Bucky, we just don't have.
Cause I couldn't peel.
yeah also don't play widow which is kind of like like
widow's kind of the counter to widow
yeah it was just so many people to look at I was just like I
don't know where I was just gonna I don't know where to go
it's just like I'm here I felt bad for you she was getting
hard bullied there yeah I was like I'm sorry I'm like I'm
standing away from you I'm still healing you.
I'm still peeling for you.
But I don't want to be next to you, man.
I don't know.
I was just like, I don't want to be next to you.
But I'm still peeling her.
I still got the peels.
Okay.
I think if I stood next year, I'd have died.
That's why I stopped.
I realized standing.
I realized if I stood next year, I would have 100% just
died.
where we do what's put me on hella five healers oh yeah you
want to play hella against the celestial players I got you
we can do it no no no no no no no no no be fire yeah genius
neck to neck to neck against yeah against their DPS yeah
they're cool never heard of them um yeah quite honestly i
think necros was disgusting on magic i think we should just
stick with that it worked for us we can't it was it's just
no okay but here's this here's the thing right i have a very
shallow understanding of the game you should not take
anything outside seriously yeah i mean i know it works
really well that one game but the reason why we couldn't run
at this game is because uh their backline was pocketed by
the ultron and ultron's a flyer the magic doesn't really
have good tools to deal with you're gonna struggle right
yeah exactly like i can't really gym right
you know i've learned that like whenever like i realized
when we play together we both died together so that's why i
started playing i don't play like super far from her but i
started playing like just a little bit further from her so
at least like we can because when they're diving us at least
they're like we don't have a little player they're not
focusing on both of us and chipping us down it's so annoying
i realized like during the first two games i would position
next like during scrims i position next to her and we would
just die like both of us just die realized like every time
we've lived we could every time we've lived from dad i was
like a little bit away from her yeah i mean that's the only
issue is the issue is also like i just because i'd rather
i'd rather one of us lives i'd rather one of us lives than
having both of us dead yeah it's a shame because did he hard
connor's widow i can just shut down every flank like she
cannot take angles like she was playing every time she goes
off angle she would just explode to me yeah unfortunate yeah
it's a go we have a 20 minute break so it's 20 minutes 20
minutes of quick play 20 minutes of quick play or we play
let's boot up a different game while we wait dbd let's we
have dead by daylight let's do a custom you can ruin your
day really quickly in 20 minutes that's that's like two or
three quick games that we We'll call on you forever.
But how long is the break?
20 minutes.
Yeah.
That's enough for your token.
One match.
Yeah, right?
I'll boot that shit up.
I mean, it's either that or I'm just swinging around the
practice range waiting.
Bung, thank you for the Twitch prize.
Thank you, thank you.
I want to boot up a quick play.
Fuck it.
I don't think I can pull up a rank match.
Imagine if I could.
Sorry, guys.
I'm in the rank game.
It's currently 6 to 6 right now.
Give me like 20 more minutes.
Pick your hero.
I don't know what to play.
Maybe.
I'll play more Cloak.
Oh, their stream game just started.
It's going to be a while.
Okay, guys.
We have a crazy line here.
Okay, we have a crazy line.
Okay.
there we can qualify okay we need to win against punch kids
team and they need to lose against their other team and then
we can qualify we need three we have we'll have three wins
that's good so that's good we can do it then we can qualify
we're not that different parker we're around the same so we
need to beat them so badly that they will be lose the next
one too so yeah we need i don't know if we're playing
against them right now but they need to lose against us and
they need to who are they playing against after us so who's
the next team they're running yeah uh i don't know actually
i need to check this was uh let me see where's the bracket
there's a new world door to come okay i found this
uh just see who like they haven't played yet no i know where
i can see oh okay i can see it they haven't played Daysteen.
So I think Daysteen can definitely win against them.
Well, it depends.
How good are is Punch Kid's team, though?
Punch Kid's team.
I mean, Punch Kid's team is, I mean, had really good score,
but they played against the weaker teams towards the
beginning, and now they're going to play against the other
teams now.
So they played against Gale's team lost.
They played like us too we played against the good team what
we played against the all the good teams too yeah we played
against the good teams previously we played against the
worst team so it's the beginning uh they lost to the new
team they lost to punch kids team i know punch kid gail's
team now they're gonna play against day's team and
everybody's running the same band line which is um ban
spider-man first and i think zeal just kind of doesn't know
what to do so both times they just kind of banned the spidey
and And then they...
I'm just looking at the ban lines from the other teams that
have been winning against them.
Banning Elsa, banning Spidey.
Let's see.
Banning Thing, because Punch Kid plays Thing.
They saved the mag after that's bad.
They kind of just ban out the DPS a little bit here.
Do they run 2-2-2 or triple?
I think they try to run triple sometimes with Zio on
support, but I think it's working too much.
But they do run triple sometimes.
I think they definitely do win a ball.
Alright.
Wait, who are the next two teams we're playing against?
It's Punch Kit and who?
It's Punch Kit and it's...
It's Bunny Steam who haven't won a game.
Okay, so if we win against those two, we can qualify.
Yeah, if we win against those two and Punch Kit loses all of
their games...
Wait, so Punch Kit wins the tiebreaker?
No, so if we win against Punch Kit and we're going to be
tied, if they don't win...
there are two games and there are going to be three wins and
we have three wins and we tie to them and we've won against
them which needs to happen to have three wins i see uh then
we we win the headbed so yeah yeah i see yeah who whose team
they win against uh punch kid uh they won against ships team
they won against the oh so the team we just lost against the
team we just lost against actually this was their first win
oh what did they what did the bottom of the barrel what did
the other teams do differently we are below the bottom of
the barrel no no bunny's team is the very last team we're
okay but what did they do differently that we couldn't
replicate uh i don't know I don't know.
I think we kind of end the fight there.
I think it's just the door, maybe.
It's genuinely just because they're calm, just hard
counters, whatever we can.
But unfortunately, it's just like Neck can't play Dedeon
Ping, and we don't have a strong kick to counter play.
So we can't deal with the Ultron.
We can't deal with, like, the flankers.
We can't do, like, big damage.
It's just really tough.
If we're desperate, is it worth trying to play Dedeon Ping?
Or do we know for sure it doesn't fucking work?
try t2-2 maybe if against the triple yeah we just uh yeah
for sure for sure we didn't have we tried t2 against them or
no uh we tried for a little bit but it didn't work out we
tried uh if we had bucky open it would have been easier
against ship's team now's your chance to pull yourself hard
don't waste it
30 seconds before you attack get ready maybe it's because
they ran did they ran ultron before or was that like maybe
maybe the other teams kind of banned out like mantis and
ultron and everything else yeah i was gonna say maybe they
banned out mantis ultron or just banned out altron instead
of mantis because our biggest issue was ultron because we
couldn't or not biggest but like one of the issues yeah he
the ultron was a big issue i already have a mantis in an
ultron at that point yum that's fine Yeah, got it?
Every spell cast has its price.
I'm just going to follow the, I mean, I see.
We also dive there, play dive against the triple.
I think, um, I think against Bunch Kids team, uh, banning
Spidey first could be good.
And then just banning out their supports really good.
They're going to save Mag.
I'm just looking at the spreadsheets prepared.
I think that's pretty good
Bunny seam What
about bunny seam?
Look at bunny seam I mean, I'm just following the draft
here.
I think against Aspen's and maybe we just led the Mantis
crew and just found the or not Aspen's ship's seam, just
found the Eotron And the tour was also really annoying
whatever focus on the future against bunny steam they they
kind of they're kind of just relying on fraggy and they kind
of want to play triple support I think they have like three
support players yeah so I think I think three support
players yeah so I think I'm just gonna follow the band line
here like band the rocket band it will come on it's kind of
forces Anita on on Jeff band the Luna be or we can ban Elsa
too we'll see definitely trying to protect mag every time we
can I think also against Thor and stuff is just hard to play
mag fuck this Thor character piece of shit we should nerf
him that is guang guang nerve this fucking character
immediately every time you say that they end up buffing them
I don't think that's how it works anymore just be like say
like how Yeah, how fun he is.
I love Thor.
He's so fun.
He's the best character that they've ever made.
In fact, I think there's not enough buffs for Thor.
I don't even know how you can practice Cloak.
I swear, every time I play Cloak, I just...
I don't even know how you can practice.
practice her.
I feel like maybe more three more blinds, but it's just like
how long of a break do we have left guys?
We have no idea.
They said they'll tell us when when to come in.
We're standing over here.
Oh, our Jeff ulted when?
How in the fuck did he hook?
Where the fuck are they going?
I'm in quick play right now, guys, because we have 20
minutes to kill, and I was just like, let me practice in
Cloak, even though there's, like, nothing to really...
I feel like Cloak is just literally, like, rocket, there's
nothing much to actually practice, other than just...
blinds I guess blind timing and cooldown management oh no
should you see it again there you go all right nope the
double cloak oh get ready for the jubilee hook too oh shit
oh mild it's gone first
No, it's a one time, it's a one day tournament, which is a
lot.
I realize it's been 10, 11, 12, 1.
I've been on for five, what is it, for five hours now.
I've been playing for five hours now.
What's your favorite Tapa?
Croquettes are really nice.
Croquettes are really fucking nice.
Yeah, they almost never mess them up, dude.
Especially if they're like homemade, they are really nice.
I had coffee earlier.
100 croquettes.
Bro, the shark, I...
This is why Jeff's not meta.
Unless it's triple, I guess.
I guess I could play.
Poor villain.
I don't play.
I already had caffeine it's just the downtime is a lot I'm
not a fan of the downtime I feel like there's uh oh I keep
forgetting the ice block I don't oh wait no I've been using
the hood team up fuck okay team up's always messes my head
sometimes I think if it was split in two days, I would
prefer that because there's eight teams if it was like six
teams Then yeah, it makes sense to have it be a one day like
what like even then two days is ideal But if it was like one
why doesn't DVD?
It was like sports like this I mean I'm asking myself as
well.
There have been relatively big tournaments But there is not
a comparison like net ease behind DVD the way there is
behind this game that funds it and keeps it alive.
But yeah, it's just like.
And ultimately, DVD is just a really hard game to balance.
I was going to say, fuck, I risk for that.
But you'd be surprised.
Like the DVD part threw me off.
What if I forgot what I was going to say?
Well, it's what are you thinking?
Quite honestly, dude.
You remember earlier I told people that I was old?
Anytime I host a tournament, I'm going to I'm going to age
10 years.
Guys, what was I talking about before the DVD stuff came up?
It's so stressful.
There's so many things I can't go.
I know I usually host tournaments for rivals and Overwatch.
I host one for Overwatch, but I usually do rival
tournaments, but I'm saying DVD tournaments.
Is it?
What?
I'm going to be honest, man.
I feel like I'm going to do it.
I've never posted my own tournament one day.
I'm going to do it and that will be the last thing I do on
DVD.
Like it's going to piss me off.
Yeah, I'm just saying.
Oh, dude.
Yeah, it's like it's an eight.
I would love to see you play the game for me.
I'm not a fan of the downtime, but this is like Ash's first
time hosting.
So obviously she's gonna, yeah, she's gonna be winning.
Because the thing about PvP competitive that you need to
understand is that they are about, it's all about learning.
For both sides, so the game doesn't break.
Like if you don't ban one particular strategy or one
particular item or one particular subset of perks, or one
particular map, it's too much downtime, I'm fucking on
board.
It's almost like if we did a rivals tournament and we ban
every hero except three healers, three tanks and three DPS.
Yeah.
But like how does a pro tournament look like you just like
do bans um what what is it like yeah how would the pro how
would the tournament look like like do you oh good side go
through the killer and then survivor no okay so basically
let's say team a you know they take turns to make the game
fair since it's uh asymmetrical they take turns so team a
killer plays against team b survivors and then team b
survivors uh sorry team B killer plays against team A
survivors and if the killer on one round gets four kills for
example and the killer on the other round well Wow okay so
sometimes you play around the tournament and it's like okay
my my survivors escaped oh my god our swords are really so
like if I get even one kill but sometimes the opposite
sometimes it's like my survivors died super early so I just
watch me get fucked up there Yeah, there's like a win
condition.
Why did he just watch me?
Can you guys join the lobby we're ready?
Oh shit
All right, goodbye quick play I might face that's the risk.
I'm willing to take It's all right.
I don't do it.
I don't do that often so it's okay all right they'll just
think i rage quit because i was like my team's dog i'm gonna
leave this quick play match now they're just like oh i
didn't know
poro thank you for the raid okay thank you i'm just
following a little spreadsheet here little bands and secrets
we're in the tournament right now right uh no pressure this
team has lost every game damn yeah so far and listen we want
to like even out the playing field right just give him doing
some choices again maybe maybe maybe it's a bit nice maybe
it's a bit nice to say guys but i generally think that
despite losing the previous round we played that really well
like we don't need to reinvent the wheel we probably just we
can do similar Yeah, last time I mean, we just fucked up
this route.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's fine.
No, you didn't fuck it up.
You didn't fuck it up.
It's okay.
Yeah, true.
That's true.
I didn't fuck it up.
Sometimes the other team has come prepared, and if we ban A,
they do B, and if we ban B, they do C, and they're good at
all three of them.
Yo, Neck, join.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Oh, no.
Intergalactic Empire of Wakanda.
yeah i should remember what this map is chat but you're our
ass and then leave the quick play game uh it's uh it's uh i
know how to explain this to you no it's okay it's okay it's
it's the one that has a little capture point and then you
have to push it and the ending of it is like a bit call and
the start is like an open it's like an open street sort of
yeah yeah like i'm gonna look it up exactly so i know what
i'm all right oh necro's time to boot up rivals get off yeah
yeah yeah i'm coming up i'm sure i'm a game though i'm a
game i'm a game you need to yeah i got you right yeah uh
simple map i think i you can do okay i i'm plus it's plus
i've seen i've been coached on shoe on this one so i
understand the corners and and choke points a bit better
towards the end maybe towards the end of the track maybe not
so much but oh is this map gonna be dom convoy which one you
can see convergence it's convoy where is it i don't see it
oh on the right side sorry i was looking at everywhere but
the right so silly um someone should tell you switch the
switch the captain thing to subuni right uh no no no no okay
i appreciate craiggy is the correct one yeah Okay, okay,
okay.
He's the main guy.
Brainiac, the mastermind.
I'm just following the line here.
We're just kind of banning triple support.
And then we're banning...
We can ban Elsa.
They might protect Elsa.
If they protect Elsa, we can ban Luna or...
Honestly, Emma or Groot are also good bans.
I know about Mag, but we'll see.
I think Emma, they feel more comfortable in the ammo.
Every time you kill Sweet Anita, say sorry in the chat,
okay?
She's very nice.
I really like her.
That could come across as very toxic.
That's true.
Yeah, that's true, okay.
Just say a little player.
You're giving, like, a counter.
Like, they'll count all the sorrys so they'll know how many
times you died.
That's pretty fucked up.
I'm going to start doing that.
We're just waiting on...
the R's we're just waiting for the games to start the games
to start downtime downtime is too much Craigie up on the
Jeff because it's best of one and I feel like that's an
insta-loss by the way if I see a Jeff it's like it's best of
one like to improve it in front of a bull i play sometimes
our best one is a lot faster this one feels very slow for a
best of one i you know guys you know what i mean this feels
i feel like i i feel like i've already played the entire
tournament like yeah too much downtime i'll give that it's
okay to pull up the stream on screen right i'd like to watch
it a bit yeah too much downtime yeah this feels like a best
of three type i feel like i'm playing best of threes i think
it was fast fast six seven today all right go six seven six
seven we're not arring it where's the eyes by the way it's a
universal meme or like make all games Dom make all of them
cop anyone can like it because I think it doesn't hurt
anybody I think it's unfair that some you know that's
because some teams are better that's one of the better
reasons I guess I don't know I think like Dom if you are can
we host like an EU tournament in domination yeah make the NA
players come to Make them come to EU.
Make the NA players come to EU.
I'm saying, bro.
Why do we always have to play on a hundred plus ping, okay?
Yeah, we have played, maybe we're playing so many of these
tournaments and they've always been on an A.
Wait, can you not?
There's not been one EU 30.
I'll not make the next tournament, make it EU.
Make it, why can't you, you're literally European.
Why couldn't you force the last Boagr bash on EU ping?
I'll be fine.
I'm kind of considering it.
Yeah, why didn't you?
why do you do it for your people i'm gonna i'm gonna do a
smaller tournament with a smaller price pool and invite all
dna creators and make them play exactly that's awesome and
it's gonna be so it's just to humble people yeah potato
wanted balance latency so badly and then i lost i know i
know but then it would be unwatchable it would be like the
world cup everybody would be on 200 plus ping it was so
unwatchable it was like people were just teleporting next
booger bash we get eu ping only next booger bash true yeah
you're literally you're the organizer is literally european
he has the power true i'm gonna host it like um like what
and it hosted at like four in the morning for that day no no
it has to be something more bearable for them maybe maybe 1
a.m yeah maybe one yeah 1 a.m tournament for n a 1 a.m
tournament club guys where we have
like n a has so many tournaments just give you a bone like
just one tournament out of the 20 exactly equal rights over
here is fucked up bro i mean we're almost 30 with necros bro
we're it's necros go to 6am bro i mean the team that won
first place is a european team so imagine yeah imagine
imagine EU deserves the rights.
Whoever wins MRI gets to decide the ping for the next
tournament.
Oh my god.
MRI will decide Boulder Bash region.
It's fire.
It's cinematic.
Clearly, N.A.
just can't win on fair rules.
That's why we have.
One of my favorite experiences back in the day was...
It's always an EU team that's first.
One of my favorite experiences back in the day was playing
Overwatch, and I was playing this creator tournament.
and the enemy team was playing on pink, right?
They were playing on pink and they were like American.
Some of them were playing on pink because I don't remember.
I think majority were EU or something.
And they were like, yeah, unplayable on pink.
Can you swap?
We swapped the regions.
We were playing on 120 pink.
Still one.
Like, just like lock in, bro.
EU players are dialed in, used to pink, smarter, faster,
more handsome, better at Spider-Man.
lucky zeal does whoa no yonek listen come listen we need to
make sure zeal doesn't qualify like if we don't qualify
whatever but if he doesn't qualify that's fire i i'm you
still upset at him for what did he do the place from the
spider-man thing you guys played yes no i'm not upset at him
i'm not upset at him because i knew he wouldn't be able to
carry anyways
no it was forced on me because i picked the different
spider-man and then he then he got into a drama with his
teammate and they and they separated them and they were like
yo but we take zeo i was like okay bro i guess i'll take zeo
i saw a video on that i saw his tweet yeah i guess i'll take
zeo bro oh my god what what happened what was the one so
streamers were picking their Spider-Man players and one of
the streamers picked Zio even though they hate each other
and basically told him that he's gonna throw his games and
they got into an argument.
I mean, it wasn't his fault, I agree.
But it was just funny.
And then they took your Spider-Man.
Who was your Spider-Man before they took him away?
It was this guy that works at Nasa and wants to fly to
space.
I shit you not.
He has a wife and his wife is pregnant and he went to the
tournament his family oh did they win did he win with the
new team no no they lost every game oh oh that's a bummer oh
that's so he would have made it fire with you he was so
stupid but he told me everything he's like i'm i'm i'm
grinding at nasa i'm trying to like study up go to space i
want to go to the iss or like uh uh or like whatever is next
because they're you know uh decommissioning it and um He
said his wife is pregnant and they're gonna have a child
soon and he works at Nasa And he used to be a voice actor
and like an aspiring voice actor and he shared everything
about his life And then he lost every game and you know, and
then I got pulled into a call and they were like listen We
need to give you zeal man.
I was like, yo, what the fuck?
It's like it's like shooting a puppy Yeah, it's like I just
learned about this guy's life and everything you like know
his life story Yeah, and I was like sorry, bro.
You're not you're not playing with me yeah and say bye it
was fucked we are yeah we are that's crazy so sad that
sounds like the coolest person ever yep yeah it was chill
and he was taken yeah yeah it was fucked up yeah yeah you're
also in the lobby bro you could have gotten in by tanasa if
you kept him he said he would write me write my name down on
a piece of rock in space wow that's so romantic that wow
well not anymore because you like you you lost him oh true
yeah he probably wrote like his wife's name yeah now he's
yeah i think he chooses what yeah who needs wives no he
shout out his wife nah okay i'm following the draft line
here do you want to ban ultron or mantis I think Ultron may
be better for you now.
I'm protecting Mike.
Neck.
What does this team like to play?
It's triple, right?
So I'm basically looking at the draft sheet.
It's like ban supports.
They have an Emma player.
Craggie likes playing Elsa.
So maybe we want to ban Elsa too.
Elsa needs to go.
Sure.
We can ban Mantis or...
Never mind.
I'll ban Mag, I guess.
I don't know if...
play me like i'll be honest they're a new funny i i think
ultron is a really good man against them okay we can do
ultron i think ultron is good just to not pocket him and i
think mantis is a good ban or luna here and then final ban
we can ban whatever they don't protect um banning mantis we
can also ban luna uh for kaiji so he doesn't flank around
but yeah Whatever you choose, you know, you know, your
teammates.
Don't forget.
You need to protect Bucky.
They're batting like all of my ears.
I'll protect everything for me.
I'll batting the Bucky.
Emma is also a good man.
OK.
Cloak.
What do you feel like here?
Honestly, I would say Mag or Emma.
I mean, I guess Tony's more comfortable now.
I guess sure.
Yeah, we could go on.
i think okay yes okay i'm banning him and then yeah and then
protect me bucky here so i could fucking play something and
i don't have to play like magic intel so that's going to be
not very fun for me okay they're
probably banning uh a tank venom fire uh everybody gets to
play whatever they want to play basically yep uh all of them
run me in i was gonna play bucky anyways Is it a thing
angle, a dynamo angle?
Yeah, just go thing.
Want me to stay on cloak?
Yeah, I think it's good.
We just need to, so all of craggy or Kaiji is probably gonna
flank.
I'm not gonna lie.
I can check here on defense or we're attacking right now.
Okay, so I think we're expecting Jeff on the other side.
Yeah, so If I use my shift, I'm unable to be grabbed.
Am I remembering that right?
Yes, correct.
So when they go for the Jeffy, you can shift and that's
going to deny basically here we need to deny flank make sure
nobody's flanking and I think we just go down main and farm
roads look for hooks, farm roads and look for terror cave
honestly they're going to be playing some crazy tanks here
and what they're going to play just terror cave right there
just close them
I'm right here behind you i'm logging in on you all right
here you're probably gonna want to play more fronts uh i'll
play more front yeah probably don't have divers all you need
to do is capture the mission area got it oh i hear someone
fire yeah they're playing yeah they're playing uh this guy
don't use on the mag fishing out i'm like three two one
you're gonna go blind Yeah.
Getting space here.
I'm down.
Yeah.
I'm good.
I'm trapped, but I'm good.
All right.
I'm going to look for blind.
Three, two, one.
Blinded.
Shielding.
Kill Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike.
Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike,
Mike, Mike, Mike, Mike, you kill him.
You kill him.
There it is.
Nice.
Oh, we got this.
I'm on point.
I'm good.
I'm just pushing you a bit.
Blocking POs and kill her.
Oh, I'll push up.
You stay on card.
Yeah, I'm on card, I'm...
Give me a three to one, Doki if you're gonna...
Yeah, I'll do it.
Look for it here.
Yeah, go for it.
Go for it.
Three, two, one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't push.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Call the corner.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice.
He's one, he's one.
He's one.
Come back here if you can.
No, that's just nice.
Push, push!
I vote, I vote!
Keep going, keep going.
Don't, don't, don't, yeah.
Just follow the neck.
Again.
Oh, wow.
Okay, I vote here.
Get him, get him.
Yeah, I got him, I got him.
Okay, do you.
Just stay on card.
Can you push free on card?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got the card.
Yeah.
I am the card.
I can ult this, so we need to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can go, by the way.
Watch out for my goal.
We can battle you.
Just go for it.
Go for it.
Yeah, go for it.
I'm pushing really hard.
I'm grabbed.
I think that he's okay.
Oh, you're so...
They used two spoils there.
Nice.
You win this.
Guys, on point, be careful.
I have my ult.
I'm on card.
Wait, wait, wait.
They're all low.
Hood one.
Oh, just let me build all here.
Yep, you're staying card.
Yep.
Did it is he counting me on cart?
There's a jab.
I want to get to TP.
Do they?
Okay.
Use Jeff already.
Yeah.
You can push up.
I'll stay on cart.
You push up.
Let's try to one shot.
Oh, yeah.
I'm with you.
Me for hook.
I'm flurring bubble.
Can you hold this?
You hold this with this.
I got mine as well if you need me to.
Hello?
He's on cart.
Yeah, he's just trying to... He didn't get it.
He didn't get the cart.
Is that a portal?
No.
I'm pushing him.
I'm coming over here too.
I'll give you a bubble if you need it.
I'm on you, buddy.
All right.
I might be.
Shoot it.
Is that it?
Yeah, I'm gonna hold a corner closer.
Yes, yes, yeah, I'll be I'll be on Bouncer duty on the
corner Bouncer duty Yeah, I'm putting bubble in this bubble
on the corner.
Yep I don't want to I kind of want to hold this turn.
Go go Go Go go go.
I'm surprised Luna behind.
Luna behind us Yeah, yeah, yeah, coming.
Oh, no, no, no, no, No, no, no one.
Oh, Oh She's my bobbled I don't have played so I'm gonna I'm
far
It's watching magma It's still winnable it's still winnable
It's winnable it's winnable Yeah Cloak one, Cloak one, Cloak
one Maglo, my glow I have all soon Cloak one, Cloak one Nice
Change, change, change Luna?
I'm sure, okay Yeah I've noticed a lot of stomp we're
getting stomped in this turn guys i mangled to donita twice
and then it didn't feel good obviously i'll dm her i'll dm
her and i'll be like yo yeah she loved every time you yeah
in vc olive was like i got her olive was like i'm putting
this on on her i felt so guilty just think we'll qualify
just think about the qualification don't mind think about
that what is plus seven hundred dollars mean uh it's uh it's
the pricing for three of them oh like kaiji is completely
basically complained that they're last plays but they're
getting 700 yeah it's easier whatever the he wants
yeah kaiji was playing mystery heroes no yeah i saw like
five different characters it's just like like hit scan this
like Okay, their team doesn't have a crazy front line.
They have a really good head scan, and they don't have a
crazy second DPS.
That's the problem.
Like, I mean, they have- What's the vibe in this offense?
What are we- Just play this corner.
They just don't have a crazy second DPS player and like
having two good DPS players, like make or break for a lot of
teams.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them.
It's taking me, we- What am I trying to just said, explode
her again?
Three teams.
I'm gonna do it again.
Just I'm just gonna flank.
I have a dog strange.
Olive you may be I'll go contest you guys they have but they
have a thing I believe I'll stay Yeah, you stay in the
front.
I'll confess to Luna.
Yeah, you go.
You go Oh, be careful here.
Okay, she's main now.
I forced it.
I think think one thing one thing one I can do another.
Oh I got you.
I'm okay.
Yeah, thank you.
Sorry.
I panicked Yeah I'm landing
I have no funny are we pressing the advantage here yeah yeah
I mean I think the enemy team would praise the surrender
button if they could wait has that been all their games
we've been humble today for a while we know what it's like
we know what it's like no I know I'm just saying I think
they're a little bit tilted right now and they still have
one more game they still have one more game to play.
Where are they playing next?
Oh no, they have a whole other game.
I'll help, help.
Yeah.
I did as much shields as I could.
Come back.
Yeah, help our town.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go back.
It's fine.
The OO came with us with Levardize.
He came low.
I'm going to have ult too.
92.
Munai top.
Munai's gonna hold.
Oh, yeah, he's dead lands.
Alright.
I'll let him.
Yeah, I'll let you.
That's good.
Can we kill the Luna?
Yeah, you can if you want to.
There's a...
Oh, nice.
Nice cracking on the fucking thing, bro.
We want Stony to have a good time.
94.
Yeah, they just don't have a second tank player, I think, as
usual.
Yeah, because you took all the tank players.
He always plays tank in the turn.
What do you mean?
Well, I don't know.
I'm coping here, man.
I was lucky.
Trying to make it better for them.
I don't know, bro.
Yeah, go for it.
Go for it.
Oh.
No.
Sorry.
Yeah.
He's looking for it.
Yeah, yeah.
Beautiful.
I'm coming in with all from behind.
Oh, my God.
It was definitely clobbering.
It was definitely clobbering times.
I will try.
Try TP?
Yeah, I should TP.
I've lost track of him, sorry.
I'm getting...
You got that?
Yeah, it is.
I swear we clutch this.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Spawn.
That's so sad.
That's a regroup angle right here.
That is a regroup angle.
Support slow, support slow and out of zone!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah, lock in here.
Um...
I had lots in.
There you still have votes.
There's someone above us.
Oh.
Oh, no, it's...
It's KG.
Okay, just a flank another time.
You need something, okay?
He needs a kill.
Yeah.
we want to hold yeah we need to push up yeah go forward go
forward go forward they all they kill my res yeah go forward
go forward all right i'm doing it you're okay it's fine yeah
go go go to the supports watch out jayfold what do they eat
their team their supports are low nice yeah whoa Oh.
Hanging low.
He's retreating.
Yeah, one in spree.
Luna behind.
Luna, Toto, Toto, Toto, Toto, Toto, Toto.
All right.
Luna's still behind.
You get her?
Oh, nice.
Now we got her.
We got her.
Um, they have, they only use a jet fault.
So they'll have the other two support ults.
Yeah, they have support.
Anything I should say my ult for?
Anything I should look up for?
Um, you can just like ult one there.
I'll be honest.
Let's see.
Try to do.
We'll do.
Think, think, think, think, think, think.
Think, think, think, think.
Okay.
I'm going for it in a second.
I blinded.
Nice.
Shooters, shooters.
Everyone's shooting.
I blinded Hood.
Oh, I need to look.
I bolt.
No need.
You're fine.
We're so healthy right now.
Okay.
Wait, Doki, listen, next slide, we're going to rocket it.
I want you to call your tarot kit.
We're going to try to one-shot somebody.
Oh, okay, okay.
I got Tim Luna.
Yeah, that was a crazy play, by the way.
Kill a thing.
Go, Craigie.
Very unkind to call him the thing.
Oh, my bad, bro.
My bad.
You got me all this toxic Tim?
Yeah, listen.
I want to, we're going to clip for him, okay?
When they come down Yeah, I'm ready for my tarot Okay, get
ready Rock it out, rock it out All right, dare I got I did
two tarot Oh, that's a lot That's okay That was low damage
Oh, they Kill them here with you Wait, what the Oh, my Don't
worry, I got you I got you I killed I didn't heal you at
all, I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
Dude, that guy just ran straight for me.
He just ignored me.
Yeah, he ignored me.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'll tease the win over the disrespect.
Look, KG hits that plus one, man.
That plus 700.
You're fine, you're so healthy.
Look, here, you can't lose to Kim, Fogar.
You can't die to him.
Strange low, right side.
I literally gave you your own little.
That was fire.
Thank you, thank you.
What's left?
Think, think, think, point, think, point, right side.
Very nice.
Let's go off, guys.
Gee, cheese.
One,
three, two, one.
look at that now we just need one more one more uh yeah one
more and then we gotta put we get to play rivals for at
least three more hours or one more hour depending on what
maybe we just ended early guys yeah well it's single wait
there's potential we might face what was it is that a gale
or whoever's second place uh we're facing uh we're facing
kit first we need to focus on the first thing focus on
winning against punch kit it looks like they're losing their
game right now so who are they oh nice okay they're playing
against uh daste okay
right i cannot put him towards how difficult this is that
like if you if you think like if anyone watching think this
is like oh it's so easy but god there's so many layers to i
mean just keep in mind you're playing one of the easiest
heroes in this game and it's this hard it's crazy like hero
shooters are really really hard they're very difficult games
oh no no yeah i know like i needed to understand there's a
chance i a boger might have not been this corner to pick me
as he was and then i would have been the team with five
people from the united states that all wake up at 5 a.m my
time then i could practice with them even less and i know
them even less so all things considered i am so fortunate
i'm so grateful i mean i'm happy to have somebody you
actually
Yeah, it's good.
I'm happy with the team.
Like, I wish we couldn't, like, we could drop somebody else
but Necro's, but it's fine.
I'll get what I have.
What?
You picked him first.
You called him your husband.
I'm joking.
I didn't hear the interview.
I was glazing you in the interview.
I was like, because they was, because they was trash
talking.
It was like, you kids trash talking, Neck, but he's playing
on Bing and without him, you guys wouldn't play Spider-Man
in the first place.
you didn't hear the interview real real real i was like you
guys keep trash talking him but he's playing on ping at like
1 a.m his time and he's the reason you guys are playing
spider i know you guys i know that two years ago you used to
watch all of his guides and he's like no no that's not true
that's not true no yes it's true bro i'm going bathroom we
are the grandfathers of strange and spider-man we have
pioneered yeah all the future strangers and spider-man
can we actually still qualify somehow yeah so the line here
is if uh ship's team doesn't win two games and they don't
have three wins because if they have three wins they win the
head-to-head and we win our next game and uh this will mean
that we qualify because we beat uh punch kit's team in a
head-to-head and uh we all have the same score where's the
the sheet for that We're like the oh, this is the challenge.
The challenge.
I'm learning a lot today.
Is it top four teams?
Top four teams.
Oh.
Okay.
Hey, no matter what, we're not last.
No, we're doing okay.
I'll be.
i mean i'll be honest like i mean i think we're doing pretty
well i would think it's very good optimist like always yeah
i bet they did lose a single game i mean he had a like he
had a really good draft i mean they just i'll be honest okay
because the people before him through i don't fucking know i
actually got so annoyed because nobody picked jitward and
jitward just went on gail's team and it's perfect it's like
they have one of the better kids kind of players and one of
the uh he's a really good dive player he's in the mri like
yeah who i know but who was in front of gail for picks oh oh
bunny picked fraggy which is not a bad pick uh but like it's
just i feel like jetward brings a lot to the team because
he's a strong shot caller and he's really good at coaching
his team you know you gotta unite you know he was a coach
before he played the midnight yeah so so bunny panu picked
kingsman which okay like whatever they have good synergy And
I think somebody else was being for them as well.
Oh, yeah.
Punch Kid picked Moxie.
It's just people picking their friends.
And then, yeah.
Yeah, but like, I mean, that's fine.
But like, it just kind of, it just kind of makes down those
teams when you just pick friends.
Because like Jitward going to Gale is like, having two
really strong DPS players.
It's like, fuck me.
I mean, it's not even Jitward.
It's the fact that they also have like two more eternity
level players.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, all the best teams.
i'm wondering all the best teams have like two really strong
dps like day's team have day and kingsman uh jitward uh gale
um who else is on the top i know who's in kingsman's team um
kingsman just has a solid team not gonna lie i know i think
there's necro's count necro's conscious too honestly he's
he's good to say no neck is good like that that's the issue
is neck is good but yeah but ping ping is fucking up one of
his yeah it's really the thing it's but like they have two
necros they have two twice the necros like we have one and
one of the necros plays hits can and it's like oh neck you
heard that you're not even unique dude one above all more
like one above all right like nah also neck neck would have
way more picks if he wasn't a ping that's the thing like
it's just the love yeah what are you from neck yeah sirbian
yeah no it's just like next booger bash gotta be on youtube
better be europe yeah yeah you gotta do it mri was won by
european team you gotta represent that's true that's true
and they that those darn north americans really have to get
what was the coach what was the coach of that team that won
the team that won uh that's our coach that's our coach
that's right that's right you guys start start believing
guys start believing shadows to shoot you know it's so funny
i have people in my child going like oh this coach is so bad
that's not what he's talking about bro that's always sad
it's so funny really the coach i mean he only coached the
team that literally won the fucking highest tier of
competitive play he probably has forgotten more about this
game than you've ever known but that's true tough tough line
tough line okay i'm back
man there's no humility on some people some people just type
dumb i like they're always right some some guy and bronze
like in plaids like i have uh 50 hours in this game what the
all right i want to check how the stream is done i'm like
disassociating guys i did not think this tournament will go
so what's on the big screen right now we're still in the
best of ones i don't know we're still in the best of ones
it's the best of one it's the best of one is does kj just
sell snowflake and flink as luna yeah i mean back in the day
it used to but now now it doesn't damage boost you anymore
so oh it doesn't the self snowflake oh it just heals
yourself do that oh i was wondering why he just skated
towards yeah i mean the idea there was like they just need
to get killed like they don't have a choice i think well you
know like after he killed you he was finally positive in his
kd so he wanted a positive kd so that's it wasn't it felt
personal but it wasn't i see
watching the closest closest match i've i've seen in a while
which one isn't it's uh i'm watching crunch but it's a dot
punch kids team right now they're playing against um they're
playing against oh wait it's close it's really close yeah oh
no i mean they kind of are clutching up here uh the other
team has way more time on attack though oh it's overtime
yeah yeah oh they might actually so if i understand this
correctly the other team barely barely got to well like they
were they were a bit shy of capturing it yeah no no it just
it gets capped it just capped it so if punch kit fully caps
this then they qual or like if they if they win this
It's all up to them to lock in.
Well, the other team to lock in.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we're just preying on Jay free winning this,
basically.
If Jay loses this, we're quick.
We're just playing for vibes after that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're just quick.
If they lose, we're quick.
Because no matter what, we'd be fifth place.
Yeah.
So we just need to...
We are basically praying.
You want J3 to win.
What's the map that we're playing after this?
I have no idea.
Don't go live.
Me neither.
I think if it's like Dom, then it might be.
It's going to go by so fast.
Yeah, guys.
Basically, if the team we're facing next wins this, wins
this, they qual, basically, because it's like top 14.
teams qualify and then technically i'll be free i'll you
know technically if they if they don't qualify if they
qualify i'll be free i'll do stuff fantastic yeah you too
yeah they don't cap this yeah they don't cap and there's no
way they count there they could tie and then we have have to
wait for another map oh or would we don't say that i i don't
think i don't think draws happen draws happen so rarely does
yeah i have no idea what happens when there's i'm you know
how like every turn is like what your feedback i think like
for a best of one tournament there's so much downtime for it
like yeah yeah they do also have a spot for draws listed on
the score thing so i think they would just mark it as a draw
you're just i didn't even i feel like i've already finished
the tournament i mean it could happen after this game but i
well yeah usually when i make the limits i try to get
everything as fast as possible yeah i mean it's it's the
first tournament too so you'll need to prove it it's okay
definitely that was that's my feedback i feel like the
downtime is just a little too much for me yeah um oh so you
don't know what's happening in the background yeah that's
true oh my god I'm just we're just waiting I might need more
water I mean actually I have water here JK I'm not wanting
you I could end the next game I can end next game that guys
and then we'll be free or we keep going and then we'll be
free the team after next game need to finish this game
quickly bro because like it's 1 a.m now bro it's on sleep
time come on bro it's the eu debuff right here yeah i have
like another tournament tomorrow after this what for apex
yeah oh Oh my god, Doki Apex are legendary.
Wait, are you in it, Yuge?
No, no, I'm just a fan.
Oh, I know you're goaded.
I know you used to play Apex.
Yeah, I haven't played in a while.
I'm kind of washed.
I mean, they classified me as the plat player.
So I was like, sweet.
Oh, I get to have two pros on my team.
I was like, fuck yeah, let's go.
Very good.
Yes, I will be watching.
Oh, no.
It's my day off tomorrow.
oh they capped all right punch kit time all right we kind of
need to lock in here if we win this we qualify i mean if you
win this we qualify oh my god lock the in guys yeah let me
see let me see just to make sure i can see how the other
teams are doing they should be because no no one else can
have three wins i mean if shib wins their next game they
qualify i know who they're playing oh oh yeah oh they won
ship is playing all ship is playing against bunny steam oh
okay well bunny no bunny claws right listen listen play the
game play the game whatever happens whatever happens i'm not
gonna lie oh they won again whatever happens happens what
did they play against that they one uh oh they played they
played against abby i believe craig can win craig can
fucking carry yo wait let me dm craig j and craig yo guys
lock in you need to win this
yo that's a little unlucky hey hey no matter what no matter
what punch kit doesn't qualify either so doesn't he i think
does he did he beat shib's team or lost against shib's team
actually a good question yeah i don't know how oh no wait
we're gonna be it's gonna be a tie so i'm not sure i'm not
sure how it's gonna i don't know he has he just gotta oh
wait no punch kit has lost against shib's team if we beat
punch kid we would be punch kid's team like how would that
work then then what's the law can't just win this game
because that's an actual it's like rock paper scissors
listen listen listen if we win this they don't qualify
probably so most likely yeah yeah most okay lock in but also
like it's rock paper scissors because then we beat punch kid
punch kid beats shiv and shiv beats us so like how the fuck
do they forget about it do this
no more thoughts it's time to lock in why is moxie he's
literally inside the building right now he's literally
inside the building ignite grand finals here guys yeah more
pressure uh just a random rank well run random quick play
queue Can I leave him in game?
Nothing heals the soul like a bit of gardening.
Wait, is Yel actually Diamond 1 right now?
What the fuck?
Yeah, I got into a...
I got into a ranked game with him, like, the other day.
Oh!
Wow.
How did he get down here?
Yeah, I asked him if he was on an off account, and he said
yes.
And then it was not his altar count.
To be fair, he does have a lot of people that throws his
games.
Yeah, I'm also...
I think matchmaking has been pretty rough this season,
though.
I think...
I don't think it's just this season.
Well, it's been extra bad right now, for sure.
Horrific.
How can you get worse?
It's actually crazy.
I can't match but you get worse than what it is.
Record breaking.
We need a full reset guys.
Wipe it up.
Wipe the slate again.
I think Kaiji's team is gonna lock and I promised him a raid
if they, if they get to play that and get us qualified.
I think he's gonna lock it up.
I'll raid him too.
I'll raid him as well.
We all raid him.
If he wins The lock in yo neck you have to pull out the
spidey one one one one zero.
Are we actually gonna Let's uh, uh, spidey through?
Uh, I mean, I'm just following what our issue says and then
we flame him if uh, if it's wrong.
Yeah, if we lose it's because I'm trusting another coach
with my life again I don't fucking care what happens happens
wait our coach clocked out he has to go to bed yeah he's
sleeping i mean what he came from la so he's oh so his jet
lag as hell yeah they just finished their their land oh my
god i just saw a penny mine thrown across the map that blew
the fuck the ears of uh we're not playing everything uh yeah
they got uh penny mine lineups
you ever play valorant no no but i imagine it's like so much
like a flag lineup it's like the brimstone molly lineup fuck
that game i can never do what are you calling it tactical
shooters yeah i cannot do tactical nothing tactical about
those shooters man i i'm just i get so bored and i feel like
i can't see anything i was just running around on neon just
like sprinting and like i feel like yeah it's like if you
play hero shooters or like battle royale's neon's like the
character you play yeah i was just like running around the
neon that i kept getting slurred every game for picking her
but like i didn't care i was like this is the only way i can
have fun yeah the stand on the corner for five minutes
hoping someone's lurking that is so boring i've never heard
as many slurs as me playing ballerine for a month it was
actually crazy it was every game it was rigid it was legit
insane i pick neon i'm getting slurred for picking neon
first in silo king he was like bro we're in gold so like
she's relaxed chill yeah are you playing for your life in
gold lobbies like have you ever played with your life on the
line and the line yeah gold of all ulo yeah but then you
think how long have they been stuck in gold you know
actually true i think uh their team yes sir two minutes oh
wait is necros on here he's ducking and then he he's warming
up his spidey or some shit he's definitely locked in that's
for sure i saw you the bear booger that was nice does anyone
know what way what's the map we're playing on?
I'm in practice room.
It's Hydra, Charter, is based.
It's Dom.
I think we played it together.
Oh, it's Dom time.
Yeah, we did.
It was our first game.
Do you guys have, like, your shooter games that make you the
most happy when you win or do well in?
Well, it's rivals, but...
Yeah.
But I feel like rivals is sort of held back by the player
man i think rivals is a very fun game i could literally play
dvd be considered a shooter if you're a hunter yeah you can
you can play you can play one of the characters that has to
aim and throw projectiles yeah you can go you can go crazy
on it yeah maybe five six seven projectile oh is your hit
scan six seven six seven
it's apex like the level of adrenaline i felt in that game
like was unmatched i mean yeah you want marvellous close
second yeah i really enjoyed pubg when it came out in like
2018 2017 oh my god dude that game felt so good to win him
for the first year or so moxy is actually on the server what
the yeah he's literally he's playing in the building right
now he keeps winning these tournaments man i mean you can
stop it rig is the next boker bash against him who's 20
what?
Moxie we're just saying what is because he has 9 ping hey
wait if you do a European do the European boker bash and
invite Moxie he's not getting 9 ping after that no no I'm
inviting to feel 1% of our pain I'm inviting all the dice
players I'm inviting Kingsman Yeah, yeah, all the die
players suck on things.
Oh, we're starting.
Oh, my God.
We're starting.
Lock in.
Yeah.
Invite all the die.
Let them know how the youth guys feel.
Wait, who's their tank line?
I'm banning whatever is in the district, by the way.
It's mag first.
Yeah.
And then also invite all the European die players and then
let them know how.
Oh, yeah.
Yep.
Yeah.
Let us be gods.
Journey.
I'm banning mag first.
first we're letting the zeal spidey out whatever happens
happens zeal the diamond one spidey fucking all right listen
you're laughing now but what if he locks in bro bro right if
he locks in he could lock in he might pull you guys off yeah
he's gonna fuck me and and you up guys you guys better be
locked in or you're getting clip farmed oh i'm locked oh i'm
sorry i'm gonna let you die first i would rather not be okay
i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let you that wait they protected
spotty man yeah i'm just banning whatever the our coach told
us what if they banned your spider-man necros whatever thing
might first and um what if he doesn't respect the 1v1
are all of marva our little player is larpers zero is a
fucking larper zeal's whole thing is just rage baiting
oh they're gonna bun spider-man now uh the dinosaur protects
i think and so the bucky i don't like i don't know nick i
you can play magic maybe or spidey i'm you're dialed bro we
need protect the dino for us we don't have a choice really
i'll just play spot that's fine yeah just do the spotty 1v1
get some clips clips out of it all right all right all right
i'll get it i'll get it yo you know he's gonna clip you he
gets one kill off of you you could be in him like eight
times yeah but then you can make your own all spider-man is
not gonna die to a diamond one yeah then you can make your
own counter montage of all the times you killed him what did
we ban last by the way Ultron, I also, Wolverine.
Whatever necklace struggles with the most.
Oh yeah, but I mean, Moxie can play also, right?
I mean, Ban Elsa or we can ban Lily's support or Ultron
fast.
Elsa, she's the Elsa.
Anything else.
Okay.
I don't want to play against the catch.
All right.
Good luck.
Have fun.
Luna Raccoon, maybe?
Yeah.
You want to be Luna or Raccoon?
I know.
I'll show you.
Oh, Cloak is banned.
I'm sorry.
right be like i mean i'll entertain this for a bit but i
think it's gonna be a lot harder for me to play spider-man
if because they have uh you're probably gonna have the dps
you can just not entertain this you can just play about the
game yeah no no no no just go back here we went you can you
can cleanse the spider okay yeah have you ever played the
ash clash with your uh spider-man eagle yeah yeah we should
all just like not even go in the set let the 1v1 in the
center and we'll attack after the Spider-Man does.
1v1 per player.
Because you're like an arena.
Just play Necrus.
Yeah, yeah, I haven't played.
This is the map where you can get pulled off.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean, Oz can't get pulled off, so it's fine.
My ass is too fat.
Support just play inside, it's fine.
You won't get pulled off.
If I shield you up, does that prevent the pull up?
Yeah, shields you prevent the pull up.
We're right next to you.
I'll do that in a page, I guess.
Who am I sticking through with anybody?
Am I sticking with support?
Me, me, me.
Just play with Olive.
Olive, got it.
Oh, he's coming.
Oh, they're 1v1ing right now.
They're 1v1ing.
Get out.
He's got the, he's got the VADM team up.
I would have killed him.
We see the VADM team up.
He's looking for pulls right now.
I want to speed, I'm good.
I want the tanks here.
I'm chilling a bit.
The Spider-Man's are all having their own little fight.
There he is.
Hook, hook, hook, hook.
Biting thing?
Oh, good, good, grab, good.
Oh, no.
You have res, you have res.
Thanks.
I'm in my, my, my, my, my, in the corner.
No, mine.
I got you.
Biting thing again?
I'm on the thing.
Okay, I'm on 81.
We need to get this point.
I'm at 81 for all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I need help here.
Do I need to?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, I'm on the move.
Go back, go back, go back, go back.
You can come back to me.
Yeah, come back.
Oh, I got pulled.
in the fight i got one yeah but we're down support we're
down support yeah it's fine i'm a little bit behind you guys
uh now right behind you for uh for somebody i feel like
myself again
coming back not down good but he's one he's one oh i don't
think i need i use it i froze him too i froze him too i
don't don't don't okay Be careful, careful.
Yeah, yeah.
3, 2, 1.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm...
Bucket left low, bucket left low, bucket left low.
Bucket left low dead.
Break, break that, or we can.
I...
We need help here.
We need help.
Right above you, low.
You have no supports, no supports, no supports, no supports.
Just rocket.
Wolf back.
We have no supports.
We have no support.
We're coming back now.
Kill him.
Kill him!
Coming soon.
We have Res.
Spidey trying to pull someone.
Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf Wolf.
Wolf Wolf Wolf one!
Wolf 1!
I'm growing.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Emma low.
Emma one.
Okay.
Watch out for both.
Think of the left side.
Nice fucking hook.
Nice grab.
Overhook.
I don't know who that was.
Yeah.
He's one run the corner.
Did you chase him?
Just chase him.
He can't run anywhere.
Okay, I'm coming.
He's on top there.
He's lowest.
We'll top left.
Uh, lower, lower, lower, lower, lower.
Oh, he got out.
That's okay.
I got him.
Nice.
We have, um, Dino.
They're working top right.
I think.
Yeah.
I hear someone to my right.
Res.
You guys play save.
They're going to top right, top right, top right.
Oh, it's too late.
No, we can't.
Yeah, we can.
Yeah, I'm playing.
You can use your ult whenever they drop, by the way.
Mlight on my Wolf is really low.
Wolf is really low.
Wove, Wove, maybe?
I need reload.
Oh, I'm dying, I'm dying, I'm dying.
I'm trying to kill.
I'm alone.
Got him.
Oh yeah.
Lost control.
I'm sorry, I'm fucking, oh my god.
You're alive, you're alive.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm good.
I'm not good.
Nice, cool again.
I'm with you.
I'm with you all in five.
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
I have a- I have a- Yeah, go for the rocket.
Oh my god.
I- Go for it.
Go, go, go, go, go for it.
Go, go, go for it.
Think low, think low, think low.
Spider-Man low, too.
Spider-Man.
I am ready to put on a show.
I'm grabbing him.
Oh I got it.
I could save you.
Oh nice.
Nice nice fire fire.
We have the better out.
Oh, she flung me.
Oh, I'm grabbed.
I'm coming in coming.
I'm coming.
I'm gonna help.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Wolf is one.
I lost wolf.
Yeah, he almost killed him.
He's... he might have got HP.
Wolf Wolf, you're walking up to point now.
He definitely.
Why are they coming?
Gazzled.
I don't have res.
I don't have res for 20.
Oh, I'm being overwhelmed here.
Oh my god.
I got deleted.
You might have to TP if you can.
I don't have.
I don't have cleanse.
You might need a TP.
I do TP.
Yeah, yeah.
Nobody has time.
No, no time.
I tried.
No, no, no, no, no, no time.
I mean, to be honest, like, that is the probably best fight
in my map in the game.
I don't know if he was getting, I mean, he was kind of
pulling you guys off a little bit.
It was me.
I like, I can't react to it there.
I can't hear him.
I mean, he can't pull you on this map.
He can't pull you on this map since forever.
Yeah, no, this one.
He also did, like, tie me up, Kinky, a few times.
Like, I did keep my momentum a bit, but...
We honestly didn't do bad.
We didn't do bad.
If we sort out some kinks, I think, I think we'll win the
next two.
Should I put my...
Should I put the flake on the Dino, or should I just flake?
It's really mad.
Flake, uh...
I hate this one.
Bucky, I know.
Bucky, yeah, I was gonna say.
I don't know who to really flake you.
yeah just like yeah just play play for that play for a
necros or dino yeah just put it no no don't don't put it in
the diamond just put it in that okay the battle starts in
five four three two one
all right we don't have any support though i don't think
they do either they have spidey probably no wolf is behind
there oh okay with luna they'll come together play together
play together uh top top left i hear spidey behind us just
looking for it they're they're still on top this is kind of
bugged for them i think they're wrong oh it's bad they split
us they split us oh never mind she i forgot she has to see
yeah okay it's fine we didn't have a new we should have
mirrored there yeah it's That's fine, we just didn't have
any woods anyways.
Yeah.
Let's get out of here.
I'm trying to get him out.
I'm clapping this.
Am I a bit low in the back actually?
Am I here?
Am I killer?
Kill it, kill it, kill it.
Nice.
We win this.
Push, push, push, push.
Push this.
They're going.
They're all one, they're all one, one, one, one.
Spider-Man behind me.
Spider-Man behind.
I froze him.
Nice, nice.
Keep him alive.
Keep out alive.
I put flake on him too.
Beautiful.
Nice.
Kill the supports.
Luna.
Maxia's will vault soon.
I don't think we need any.
Yeah, careful.
No, we win this one.
Nice.
Spider-Man, right above, right above, right above.
I'm aiming at him right now.
He's 1 HP by the way.
That's fine.
That's really good for us by the way.
That's a perfect fight.
Good stuff.
I'm going to try and like you.
Nice.
Good stuff.
Very supported.
You need to build alt here.
I need a farm.
Oh.
I'm confused.
Just going to be here.
I still with the team, but I don't know what I'm doing.
Uh, kidnapping thing?
Okay, never mind, I can't.
It's fine, it's fine.
Huge, huge, huge.
No more else, no more.
No more, no more.
I'm at 83.
Yeah, I'm like, you know.
Yeah.
Don't take too much damage.
You're gonna have...
Yeah.
Just farm your roads, guys.
Just farm the support.
Don't get pulled by the spidey.
That's what they're looking for.
if anything happens.
Spidey, Spidey, Spidey, Spidey, Spidey.
I grabbed him!
Shielding!
Okay, chill.
Back, back, back, back, back, back, back, back, back, back,
back, back, back, back, go back, go back, go back, go back,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, 96, 96.
I need...
Come back and rocket.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rocket, yeah, yeah, rocket, rocket, rocket, right.
Think, think, think, think, think, think, think, think,
think, think, think.
They do.
I'm trying to fire me as much as fast as I can You okay in
the back?
I'm clapping, hoping.
I hit something I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I
got it!
Oh my god, beautiful.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
Oh, something.
Three, two, one!
Oh, I'm getting...
I couldn't do anything after that.
Guys, I need to push back.
I died here, my friend.
You just died, just died, just died.
Spider-Man in the back
Just regroup Did they spy you all they did it's by the day
you single they have ammo Yeah, we need to they might be
looking for a fight right now.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah on the left side nice good
stuff.
Nice beautiful Yeah, I think on the left side let my Emma
thing left side I'll try to I'll try to pull one of them.
I'll try to pull one of them.
I'm good.
Don't worry.
Oh, never mind Okay, Mike, wait, can we all shoot?
I got one, I got one, I got one.
One of them low, one of them low, one of them low.
Rocket, rocket low.
Spider-Man low, Spider-Man one!
I can't shoot, I can't shoot, I can't, I can't, I can't, I
can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't,
I can't, I can't, I can't, I'm sorry.
No, you guys, you're good, you're good, you're good, we're
keeping you.
We're keeping up.
I'm clapping on this.
I'm clapping this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my way, my way, my way, my way, my way, my way, my way,
my, my, my, my, my, my, my, uh, thing low, thing low.
Never mind.
Thing, thing, thing, one, thing one.
One, one, nice.
Spice, fight.
I'm on right side or...
Rocket one.
Rockets one up top.
I don't know if you can get him.
No, we can.
Resonate.
They're keeping, they're keeping, by the way.
They're keeping.
I hear him behind.
Hi.
Right side, right side, right side, right side.
Rocket down.
Yeah, grab.
I froze something.
I don't know why I froze.
I'm grabbing thing.
Grabbing thing.
He's going to shift back in panic.
He's there.
Oh, no.
He has the gamma team up.
I got him.
Nice.
Stop, guys.
We're going to have, they're going to have their DPS salts
now.
It's fine because our old economy for us.
supports is better our support is better i'm gonna like keep
us alive maybe we just need farmers for this yeah i'll try
and let you farm yours and then okay they're gonna have both
their dps uh for that fight magneto can soak them up or not
really well not really no but we have maglet for rockettles
maybe i don't know whatever all of the sides just don't fat
finger it no she's good she's died anyone in particular
should be focusing on or helping no you're doing great
you're doing great anything anything scary about spiderman
in this map that you need to be aware of it's really hard to
hit the ball it's not not too crazy just farm rock it all
just farm rock it all we can even take it slow and just wait
maybe they're gonna end and throw like just go if they use
something before we have rock at all to stable yeah it's
okay just take some damage they're taking right yeah come
right to come right to come right to come on look at him
close him out close him out uh i'm behind by the way am i
right side we have to walk you're gonna this point right now
one point 84.
i'll grab uh and get that big thing oh nice Nice, nice,
nice, nice.
Whoop whoop whoop whoop.
One HP.
Rocket...
Rocket, 3, 3, 3 Rocketrich.
My null.
Yeah, alt this, alt this.
Oh.
Oh yeah, he only got alt.
Yeah, I didn't have it.
That's my bad.
I'm pulling a shield on top of us if I can.
Oh my god.
The other guy, get out of him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just dead.
Oh, they're harassing me again.
Yeah, it's okay.
Okay, okay.
I think I died here.
They stay in this wall.
We had nothing.
And they used the Rocket.
So that's- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is really good.
Try old first.
If we need it.
I'm a couple seconds behind.
Listen, listen, listen.
We just go in with Rocket Loads.
Okay.
Before the Spider-Man can go in and out, okay?
We just don't know.
Okay.
I have a map for it.
You can try to stun it.
Oh, it's up to you.
Can we push up and Rocket Loads?
Just send it.
Send it.
Send it fast.
Nice play with this.
Kill the tanks fast.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a Spider-Man.
I got it.
Yeah, I got it.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Four, three, two, one backing it, out now.
I'm okay.
Help your Rock.
Live, live, live.
I'm helping him.
He's very good.
We win this.
Wolf one.
No pass.
Think, think, think, think, think, think, think.
Buddy wants to fight him.
Push up.
Okay.
Okay, come in.
No grab.
I have Spider-Man on me.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Can you look for me?
Look for me?
It's fine, it's fine.
We trade the backlands.
Emma about to be off of her mode?
They have no supports, no supports, no worlds, no worlds.
Oh my god.
We have rockets soon.
They did, they did, they did.
They used it when I Lunad.
What's next?
Mine's ready.
Okay.
Here we need to farm Rocketode and we can play for that.
They're probably going to have rocket at again.
Yeah, they should.
Yeah, they will.
They use Spidey.
They're looking for a pull right now.
By the way, I think he's setting up.
Yeah, he is.
He's one.
I almost have all.
Yeah, yeah, just farming.
They're farming those two.
I'm going to pressure them.
I'm not scared.
We're close.
I'm going to kidnap Bindy.
Bind, Bind, bind, bind.
I'm using my, I'm using mine.
No, go, go, go.
It's good, it's good, it's good.
Oh, I'm dead.
I died, I died, I died.
Luna alone left.
I watch out Emma on the right side.
Yeah.
So it supports bunkers under here.
Can't get up and think, he's really low.
Any help when he dies?
I'm far, I'm far.
You can maybe win this.
I'm trying to.
Oh, Spider-Man, Spider-Man is half.
Rocket, rocket down.
Rocket down.
Luna far left alone.
I'm sorry, I got you.
Oh, you can.
It's winnable.
A rocket's here.
He has alt too.
I have a lot.
We're good.
I already TP'd.
It's okay.
You won't come in.
They're behind you guys.
They're wolves.
We just don't have TP for the fight.
Last fight.
Just remember that.
That's fine.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
Just don't get grabbed.
Don't get grabbed, like.
I want heals though.
They're spawning back though.
We need to go back.
You can touch fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Touching, touching, touching.
Yeah, watch out, man.
They're gonna TP, I think.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Right side, Emma.
Right side, baby, top.
Spidey's looking for a dive right now.
Come to me, come to you.
You should come to me.
Above us, above us.
Okay, now you come back, go back, go back here.
We'll close.
Rocket, rocket, rocket, throw it, throw it, throw it, throw
it, throw it, throw it, throw it.
Can we look?
Emma's down, Emma's down.
Good shot, good shot, good shot.
Luna, Luna.
I could.
Oh, I died.
Yeah, it's okay.
I got raised though.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I can't Go for me.
Give me reset.
I'm trying to.
I got you.
I gave you a reset.
Yeah, I know TPM.
I'm not putting it.
I'm gonna help you.
Okay, we have one more shot at this even if we lose this,
right?
Yeah, I'm a composer.
I got I got you as long as I could.
I have all here.
We have one last fight.
I have all.
By the way, they're all multi's 85s.
They're gonna have global students.
Just wait for me.
Make sure I don't get picked off.
Yeah, yeah, we're all together.
He's 85, he doesn't have it yet.
He's not gonna...
I hear...
I'm trying to help you.
Emma's right side, Emma's right side.
You can ult with you guys.
We need to live.
Nice big, beautiful.
We need to go for him, we need to go for him.
I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking, I'm walking.
Three, two, one.
I get you out of here.
I don't have res.
I can hold Quinn for a second.
I need help here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wolf no passive.
He's still on him.
Reson 3.
I give it to you.
Should I kill myself at the spawn to spawn there?
I need help.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good thing, thing.
Good thing.
He's one spider-man one Yeah, spider-man's still low Yeah,
we have to kill rock at all I'm on rock y'all They're poorly
They're okay, okay They need to be Uh Spider-man behind the
spider-man behind Uh, Emma left side I'm on the thing on the
point I'm gonna kidnap that Kidnap him I need help, I need
help I'm dead I'm coming back, coming back I'm with you.
I'm with you.
Any help?
I couldn't.
I quit.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, so close.
I'm sorry.
No, I live as long as I could there too.
No, that's not your fault.
Go faster.
I lived as long as I could there too.
Ah, that was close.
Just around, run.
GG's.
Oh, I got Spider-Man low too to run.
there too no i was really close it was really close game
guys that was a really close game i i actually played really
well there i'll be honest it's good that's really good yeah
it was fun it was really good i enjoyed myself a lot no it
was good listen listen if it makes you feel better ship won
his game anyway so oh so he none of us they didn't qualify
either yeah no no no no no uh i think we played pretty well
with things considered just the spider-man just going on us
but listen you can always blame shoe for the bands in suke
that's true that's true no like i froze him i froze the
spider-man in the middle of the point but we didn't we
didn't kill him i was so sad yeah it was a little bit hectic
there at the end it was a little bit hectic.
I could have showed up a bit earlier.
I thought we were like, one second away.
No, it's your fault.
It's not your fault, though.
It's like, you did.
I was thinking.
It's fine.
An unfortunate slip up.
It's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate, but you really did you did really good on
the dinosaur.
Like, it's not your fault at all.
I think it was, like, really hectic there at the end.
That's probably not should have died, but it's fine.
It's okay.
Yeah, I just got comboed.
I'm sorry.
No, I was i was trying to help and shoot guys i was trying
but it was fried i'm not gonna lie it's just the last fight
was just way too hectic i mean i i do wonder like we could
have won last fight last fight was winnable but yeah it was
a little bit tough there um i know i think we played pretty
well things considered there were some storms um there were
some wins from us but i think all things considered pretty
well played guys thank you guys i'm not gonna lie the one
day and a half to practice is has been so rough on me yeah
we had a day and a half you all been wonderful dude we had a
day and a half yeah we had a day not even honestly not even
yeah it's fine so like it's on thing and it's late at night
you guys did great thank you so much uh you can rest now and
you know odds you're free from rivals you you don't have to
you don't have to stay away in the past thank you thank you
what's the uninstall button hold up uh it's going back to
thank you so much for entertaining me uh and honestly being
with me every step of the way especially those last matches
man i don't feel bad at all like we all did so good last
match was good last match we're good for sure yeah it was
close yeah it's a close game my absolute pleasure guys i'm
gonna probably look to wind down a little bit much yeah are
any of you are any of you streaming for a while afterwards
i'm i'm i'm streaming for a little bit longer i'm gone i'm
gone i'm gonna go sleep yeah it's been a long time yeah yeah
yeah ggs take care guys take care love you team bye bye bye
i love you wait punch get qualified how does that work how
do they rock because they won they have four wins because
they've got four wins if they if they lost if they lost
against us then oh i thought i thought shib had four wins
for some reason no no no no no no go all right ggs all right
i'm freed oh my god oh i think if i got that kill on
spider-man we could have won that but i don't think it was
just on me though it was not my mostly because that freeze
if we all turn around and shot him he would have died so it
wasn't on me to fully kill him yeah
yeah i like used every i used every you till I had to like I
feel like I survived so like longer than I should have went
during that game so I'm I'm oh happy with myself especially
when I fucking wasn't even practicing Luna yeah
I think I did well on that last game it wasn't really uh
like I had like good ults and good frees my hands started
shaking though on the last game because I hate it when that
happens because uh yeah I didn't do well not last not last
as long as it's not last that's all that matters yeah I like
he I got dove so many times I've lived majority of the times
I got dove too so I felt like um like I did the best I could
I think we just I think it was everyone was like uh fighting
their own demons yeah um everyone was like fighting their
own demons i well the thing is that is that like you have to
be aware like a lot of players are not used to play against
i'm not used to playing against dive i'm still like a front
to back player i hate playing against dive um and it for
newer players it's very hard for newer players to play
against dive so that's why that's why i stopped standing you
can tell I told you guys, I stopped standing next to her and
I was telling her like, I'm not going to stand next to you
anymore.
Just because like it's very, I'd rather one of us lives
rather than both of us die.
Because it's very hard to have to, especially against good
dive players, it's very hard for like someone who is not,
who's not used to that type of dive.
Like coordination slash dive to like keep each other up.
And that's why like whenever I stopped standing next to her,
like we survived longer because one of us still lives and
I'm able to like heal her from afar.
Not like too far, but like in a position where we can both
survive.
Like as a chance for both of us to survive.
And the vibes were good.
The vibes were good.
That's why I learned I was just like because, you know, to
correct to play correctly, we have to be next to each other
like to correctly play against dive and also move forward
because like she was not used to doing front back like
moving forward, moving back and stuff.
Um, so I had to like, uh, like hold her hand, be like, come
with me, come with me, move front, move front, don't move
back and just, because like I got yelled at for playing back
too in rank, so it's like something you have to be able to
learn through playing in the higher elo, which is why I
don't blame her, like where dive was like, really hard on
her.
That's why I was like, are you sure you don't want Ben
Spider-Man?
Because it's on us, like, you know, it's on us.
We, us supports are the one that has to deal with the dive
and like, you know, yeah it's just a knowledge gap in in a
way but like you know like i i that's why like i try to play
in a way that helps us um that just helps us uh survive just
a little longer and stuff um um but yeah um i don't know i
had fun i know um i know like maybe like i know other teams
might know, I have had fun, but my team, I like my team's
energy, I like my team's mood and everything,
and, and I think, you know, I wasn't, I wasn't supposed to
be on Luna duty as well, so the fact that, like, I had to,
like, remember how to play Luna, well, not remember, but,
like, I was not, you know, I was literally gone for, like, a
week and a half, like, I haven't played and i had to play
rivals starting yesterday like you know so i was like i have
not touched luna for so long because uh because huge was the
one that's supposed to be on luna duty so i was just like oh
i'm on luna all right i'm on luna now i yeah and not on my
actual i'm not gonna lie i have more frames on this setup
guys i i have more frames on this setup though
yeah so it could be a it could yeah no I've had 200 plus
frames when I play on my own setup I get 100 plus frames
even though like even though tech like if I just brought my
microphone if I just brought my microphone and my go XLR
we'd be perfect it'd be Gucci
if only if only I had if only I had my mic if only I brought
my microphone set up then we'd be so Gucci um I think I was
able to I don't know I think person was able to do a lot
despite um coming in with only being able to play for two
days and I had a lot of fun I had a lot of fun just like
chatting and stuff there's no bad vibes or anything and we
were not last place and that's the best part Lord of Shadow
playing with the twitch branding thank you we were last
place guys now should i play one game of rank and get yelled
at and feel like shit after that do i um do i do i do one
game and then feel like absolute garbage after the fun funny
fun time
you could do two that's true I could do too.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's ruin the funny fun time with one rank game.
Wait, so... Okay, let's see.
Um, wait, actually, I don't know if my friend needs their
setup.
Let me message.
Dude.
I've been, like, hogging their setup, so I don't know if
they need their setup.
I message them.
That's the doom queue goes oh yeah i should they deleted the
i don't know how this works is it are we still screen oh
we're still sharing chat everybody's still together
let's see i'm
just double checking
But yeah, honestly, I think my critique for this, I think,
honestly, I think if they did the draft in a way where,
like, they separate the categories with the players and
stuff, like, what kind of player and stuff that you have to
draft, like, ranking in roles, and also, I'm so tired, it's,
it's so tired.
best of one is a lot it was so it feels like it felt so long
you know the best of ones felt like they were not best of
ones that's how i felt the best of ones did not feel like
best of one too much downtime Too much downtime.
Let's see.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
We got.
Oh, we got not last.
Not last.
Let's see.
Okay, so I don't have to give back the...
Alright, let's queue a game.
Let's do a game.
I hope they do a...
EU tournament.
I feel like they deserve one.
I always feel bad.
Those Europeans have to play with one game.
One game.
One game of getting yelled at to remind.
Guys, I need this to remind me not to play rivals for a
while.
Guys, I'm doing this to cleanse the good spirits, you know?
Anyways, like I needed to cleanse the good spirits are
people mad who knows I know a lot of people were yeah
counteract the good vibes yeah I had yeah after the the good
vibes with team let me go get yelled at for for an entire
game straight uh
it's hard to make a good tournament i know like i know like
um there's definitely a lot of unbalance i i feel bad for
the team that got last place that did not seem that must
have not been fun that i know as someone that has dealt with
something like that that is a miserable experience and like
you know at least I feel bad for the non-rival players too
that get like their ass beat like that.
It's not fun at all.
Absolutely miserable to have to go through stuff like that.
Technically I would have counted as the non-rivalous player
because like I said I was literally on vacation.
I was literally on...
It's alright, it's already
It's just I feel like pre-assigned teams maybe pre-assigned
teams or
Draft draft is hard because it's like players are like oh
either I get my friend I either get my friend or I get like,
you know You don't know what the captain's gonna pick are
they gonna pick their friend or are they gonna pick like
someone who they think it's good and you know that would
leave off and then you have to make sure all the captains i
feel like all the captains should be the same role um and
because then it's going to be so because that's what
happened with i think two bunnies team same role same rank i
think all the captains are same role same rank then it would
make more sense it'll be much more balanced because like the
thing is the issue with two bunnies team is that she's a
tank player i don't know what her elo is but she's not a dps
player and she's obviously you know not gonna be not the
same rank as gail or something um so from that you know um
she's already at a major disadvantage because for gail all
he needs he could just pick a really good really good dps
player to match with him like a one above all dps player and
then which is i did not i which is surprising that uh
because there was like a current ignite player i didn't
realize like oh i don't know what goes well with all tried
um you think we can heal enough i mean i guess i'll go invis
for the double yeah
yeah i know what it's like to be in a bad vibes team so i'm
glad uh so i try to make like you know try i i was trying
and also i want to be sure the, you know, I want to make
sure the newer players, the, you know, the newer players and
the non-rivals players, because I'm also a non-rivals
player, I'll make sure they're having a good time and
they're not feeling miserable or like they're not, you know,
sad about the mistakes they make because we all make
mistakes, like I made mistakes.
I made mistakes during some of the games and I'll make sure
they don't dwell on it too much and everything and I want
them to have a good We didn't qualify.
We didn't go top four.
But, hey, we're not last.
We're not last.
And I don't want to make sure they feel okay about that.
Like, I don't want them to just be, like, sad and depressed
about a tournament.
For someone who, you know, for them to don't play the game
as much, too.
Especially don't play the game.
You know?
I'm just making sure.
Yeah.
Because, like, even if we lose, at least, like, we...
Alright, so...
Alright.
I'll go over there and help them.
I'll make sure they're okay.
They're okay.
Whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Sorry about that.
I'm dead.
Oh, whoa.
Maybe a little bit too much.
Oh, no, that was the, that was a good idea.
I lost the momentum now.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
I got pooped everywhere.
um i'm with albert lily and fun fun i don't know both
controller players um i asked mac left his team to be on my
team i felt so bad he was like i'm already on a team but
i'll join yours and i was like okay are you sure he's like
yeah i don't know who these people are i felt i felt i felt
bad for that because he literally left his team just to play
with me I was like are you sure a real yeah it is a real one
he is oh they're not portaling oh wait I mean that's fine I
mean that's fine too yeah
he came in with zero experience he literally uh and he got
target ben too he's playing against like really really good
players so it's like and you have huge who has to play
against dive and like obviously like she's never she doesn't
play against like really good dive you know like playing
Playing against dive in any elo fucking sucks.
Oh my god.
I hope there we go.
Like playing against dive in any like against like one above
all players is never a good time you know?
So it's like she has to go through a lot of shit.
Show me the world!
Okay.
Where is it?
All right.
Let's hope she lit.
Oh, he's on me.
He's going to show him the world again.
What?
Oh, I mean.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This guy's been alive for so long.
Yeah, like a diamond player playing against a one above all
dive.
Like, it's, yeah.
Like, I understand.
Like I can't fucking do shit like I get yelled at play when
I'm playing in style because I don't have experience Playing
is look at like I I'm literally playing front to back.
That's my bread and buddy front to back is like easy mode
Like I
get to play front and back
Oh All right
Like look how easy this game is in front to back.
No.
Bye.
Oh my god!
I thought he used it!
I legit thought he used his all.
That's why I peaked it again.
I was like, Zovir, right?
I was like, the old Zovir, right?
I would not have peaked it, but I knew it was still going
on.
I don't know when to use this.
Where's Yelting?
There ya.
Oh my god.
Wait, where's Matt?
Oh.
there you go oh my god let's hope he lives please live no
I'm trying to try to get to you I really did
Jesus Christ I can't do shit about that oh my god he made
his guy that guy might need healing
What the fuck?
How did I get hit there?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, I'm trying to heal.
I really am.
The main mistake.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
I don't know, I guess I could go...
I only went Invis just because of the team up.
The team up is so good.
Alright, let's see.
Rocket.
Well, we're going Rocket.
I could go Luna.
Maybe Luna would be better heals.
Oh, wait, Rocket.
Mantis?
Perhaps?
Is that enough heals?
I don't know.
I don't know if it's enough heals.
I might not be.
I don't know.
I don't really want to play Luna.
Like, Luna's not as fun as she used to be.
But if it doesn't work, I'll go Luna.
Just because Luna might give us more heals with my claps.
Where is she?
Where is her?
Oh shit.
Where's our torch though?
Oh there he is.
Is that it?
Oh.
Yeah I'll go.
Yeah I'm swapping.
all right I'll swap the Luna I just thought breaking winter
soldier for deals and then I can't jump because it's in the
way like let's see who block who broke it I would like to
give oh shit oh
Alright.
I don't think I can heal any more than that.
Oh wait, there's a portal.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, we have a magic now?
When did that happen?
Please, let me give you a snowflake.
Oh.
She blocked it.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
No, I stood by trying to stand next to our strange.
I don't know what else I can hide from it.
Oh, fuck.
I stood next to him.
It's not my fault.
It broke.
I stood next to him.
Alright, triple support.
If all else fails.
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah, I turned.
I forgot how VCs.
I can't hear him because voice chat is super low right now.
What do we do?
Alright.
healed.
Wait, we rocketed?
Oh, we rocketed that.
A forfeit GG.
I told you guys, I had to cleanse the good vibes with a rank
game.
I felt too good about myself, you know?
You know, when you feel too good about yourself?
Alright.
Can't have that.
Exactly.
I was just like, this game was too...
This tournament was too fun.
It's time to feel like shit.
I had too much of a good time.
It's gonna be me, isn't it?
Not me.
I'm trying.
I try.
I try to keep you up.
Exactly.
Oh, he's done.
He's done with this game.
oh
okay sure I mean I guess I I guess well
okay I I guess I guess oh my god there was nothing to do
Rock it all for, I guess.
Yeah, my steak was too thick and my lobster was too buttery.
Let me like just fucking throw my lobster away.
Fuck it.
That guy does not want to play the game anymore for sure.
Whoops.
who has it oh my god why would you peek we don't have
anybody there
we're this poor guy
this poor guy doesn't want to play anymore he's just like
please forfeit it
oh my
You're feeling brave I
I forgot a VC turned down
It's okay It's okay despite losing that game Despite losing
that game It's not on me How are you feeling it?
Surprisingly not depressed Is that crazy?
surprise me i should keep going till i do get depressed guys
i maybe i should keep going until i feel the depression
hitting it oh yeah 19 i did not want to talk to anybody oh
guys all right i have someone that's gonna log in to play
all right do you have rivals Download it.
You promise.
I never promised anything.
There's never been more over.
Who's this?
I don't know who this person is on my...
Guys, also I found...
Apparently there's a...
Let's see.
Oh yeah, the tracker shit's crazy.
crazy now it's like apparently like everyone high elo uses
trackers now for like uh oh what's this
all right i noticed i said one more not one last game i'm
waiting to see if they if they they want to play i'm going
offline hides you from the tracker does it and i know that
is that why people go invisible these days yeah but what's
the fun and i guess i don't know doesn't really matter like
they can't really target bad me i'm just chilling i'm not
one trick i'm just bad like it's just they just like when it
doesn't whatever they do like i'm not whatever like it
doesn't hide doesn't hide the fact that like when the
tracker like like you just see my history like whatever like
go offline you still get to see my history
you go offline your game history is still there so it's not
like what you're gonna hide from like I don't know what I'm
playing next yeah all right let's see all right we'll do we
have to wait how many okay how many
will it take all right let me change the stream title guys
let's see because i'm not in a tournament anymore i don't
want people um
like oh you made it and i was like no just playing rink
playing rink now to get rid of the good vibes
i felt too good about myself it's time it's time to fucking
be depressed and find another person block on Twitter.
I feel way too good about myself.
I can't be too positive playing this game.
Maybe that's why I'm not.
Maybe that's why I'm no longer in the test plate, like the
test previews.
I still like the game.
I do think I criticize, I do criticize this game a lot, but
only because, I feel like if you like a game, like you like
something, you criticize something a lot, better you know
you want the game to be better and i do say i do criticize
the game a lot but it's not the gameplay i don't criticize
the gameplay i criticize the toxicity i love the game loop i
love the game loop i just think i just think it's just the
community slash player base of the game i felt i feel like
like like a like voice chat bands text bands are just like a
slap on the wrist um and and it's like it's like uh even
like wind trading wind trading and stuff is like not uh um
wind trading is not very harsh punishment um getting boosted
by cheaters isn't a harsh punishment there's so many people
that are boosted by aimbotters to high Elo and they get away
with it because they're not the aimbotter.
They'll just keep queuing with the aimbotter.
Like the aimbotter would just have their accounts banned
over and over again.
I don't know if you can, I guess hardware ban is like not,
is not, is very easy to spoof pass it.
And yeah.
No, I think like, okay, Overwatch has an issue where it's
really, really strict their punishments.
Um, but you can't say anything.
You can't say anything.
You can't do anything.
Um, even in pro play, uh, in pro play, if you do anything,
you get suspended from pro play.
Um, because it's like very, very harsh.
Um, if they find out you boosted even once, I won't be
surprised if there's boost, if there's like half of, not
half, but like, I won't be surprised if a handful of rival
pros are boosting on the side.
Um, but in Overwatch, if they find out that you're boosting,
or if you were a booster, you get like suspended from the
from um from the uh league basic not overwatchly but you get
suspended from basically like professional play um so it's
more so like rivals i will not be surprised if have because
you know boosting makes a lot of money um like i know people
who've boosted before and like for money and i've asked you
know i'm curious so i'm like how much do you make you know
i've actually been asked to like help a friend uh and i was
like no i don't want i'm not gonna like i was just like bro
like i have more to lose like yeah i was like bro i have
more to lose like i'm not gonna i'm literally a content
creator bro like
like what the bro i'm not risking my fucking content for
like 200 bro i'm not i'm not wasting so much more doing
content creation like for $200 for yeah
yeah and then it's like uh and it's like you can get away I
feel like you in rival is it's less harsh in rival like I
feel like uh um oh thank you thank you you Ashlyn thank you
oh yeah we were talking oh you might be I I think like we
were talking about like what ways to improve the tournament
because I know it's your first time hosting and we're
talking about it and there's always ways to improve
definitely a downtime um the downtime is is a lot for like
best of one um it was a little like faster I'm tired I mean
I'm playing rank but like waiting in between matches was
very tiring especially best I think it was just all
domination it's your first tournament like my first
tournament was fucking ass this is all right like i was like
i felt like after three games i was like telling my chat
after three games i felt like i just played the entire
tournament i was like there's six there's five more games
after this i was just like oh my god i do not feel like i
just i felt like i finished this tournament after the third
one like mine um okay ash do not watch necrosis stream
that's my feet i i do not watch necrosis stream i'm just
saying for your i for your mental for your mental
because he's passionate you know he's very he's a very
passionate guy And obviously, you know, he always wants like
to things to like improve and go, you know, improve.
And, you know, obviously we all — he's a very competitive
guy, too.
You know, he's a very competitive guy.
He wants to place higher and everything.
And everything.
So I get it.
You know, I won't be — like, you know, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'm pretty sure I got hit, too.
I got hit in the Crossfire as well, you know.
I'm trying to check in to see when Okay Two games maybe
three Alright let's lose Celestia 1 Guys Let's lose Celestia
1 Alright if like maybe I think like one that They were
talking about it and That's cool It's cool I've done lots of
these tournaments I'm just happy I'm not last Like honestly
like It's always like as long as I'm not last blazes I'm
cool I mean even if I'm last I'm also cool like it's fine
it's fine as long as I just want as long as the team isn't
passive aggressive or assholes like I'm cool with anything
like uh oh yeah Gomez wanted to play but he said play two
more games yeah and I think I think I did my part you know I
think I did my part I oh for I think the gifting of stuff to
Ashland.
I think I, you know, I did my part.
I think I played well individual wise.
Individually, I played well.
So I know it's like not like, you know, oh, I made my team
lost, you know, like, you know, I think everyone, everyone,
you know, made, made little mistakes on and off too.
So, um, yeah, definitely, I think I remember, I don't know
if Ashland's still here, but one of the things that they
were all talking about, was they wanted maybe the captains
to have the same role and the same E-Lo because I think like
basically the teams that placed lower were captains who were
I think like all the like majority of the good teams I mean
like Gail's team was good deep two good really really good
DPS players on the same team I think all the captains were
just same role same E-Lo it would go a little better for
balancing wise
I feel bad for Two Bunny's team Only because it's like I
know like KG and Two Bunny are married Right?
Husband and wife I felt bad Husband and wife losing together
You know?
You know It's supposed to be a romantic thing You know how
like You know Oh we're on the same team together You know
we're We're husband and wife on the same team And then they
lose together And then you You know That's shitty.
That's a shitty feeling.
That makes it even.
I don't think they were having a good time, guys.
I don't think they were.
I don't think they were having good time.
Like, KG seems really, really, seems really, really mad in
chat.
Like, through thick and thin.
I don't know.
They seemed really mad in chat, though.
if their mayor survives this it was meant to be exactly if
their mayor survives this random me sorry random right I
should practice apex later random rivals tournament then it
was meant to be don't ban DD they have a duty in spider-man
player that's okay I'm gonna ban spider-man and I
think it did well for someone who haven't um who doesn't
play this game 24 7 you know i was very surprised boga
picked me i think because he wanted me to have a fun time i
was very surprised showed at boga for picking me i didn't
not expect him to to pick me i thought i'd be like the
second pick support you know and i was i think this setup is
a lot this pc wise gaming wise this setup is better than my
pc like i legit have 200 frames that's why i want to keep
going because i don't think i've had it i don't think i've
got to experience 200 plus frames in rivals maybe i'll even
you know maybe i'll stream ape you fuck it maybe i'll stream
apex here too i'll stay an extra day i was like oh my god
200 plus frames on apex oh my god while i'm streaming oh my
my god maybe um i won't be surprised if like maybe like he
wanted me to have a better like you know i hope i helped him
with helping him with boosting up the vibes no it's a one pc
set up i'm technically i'm i've i've held their setup
hostage for a while
hostage for a while and they were like um when can I use the
I was like I'm guys I was like bro I'm this is my job bro
it's not my fault it's literally my job
oh my god what
the fuck is going on are you gonna what is going on I don't
even know
all right are they fighting better oh my god oh he was right
he was above me oh my god he was above me all along I was
like what was that
What the fuck was that?
He just appeared out of nowhere like a fucking ghost.
Oh my.
Oh, fuck it.
Oh, I thought that would hit that.
Not gonna lie.
Can one stone cart, please?
Can one person stone cart?
It's been way too slowly.
Alright.
Fuck yeah, I'll stay on cart.
You know what?
I'll be cart, bitch.
Alright.
It's fine.
Hope you keep them up without...
Oh, maybe if...
I'm on cart.
I'm a cart bitch right now.
I'm a cart bitch.
Oh, that's not who I want.
There?
Okay, I had.
Oh my...
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Never mind, I'm no longer fine with that.
Oh my god, maybe?
Oh my god.
Oh no, we've lost her!
We've lost her!
momentum that's the worst part no
let me share I'm okay with that sit and spawn I'm okay with
that did they get him
ah don't worry I'm trying to farm leaves right now
oh shit oh shit it's me it's me i'm up here i tried i used
every leaf possible no no no we i lose every leaf possible
there's nothing to heal you are missing your shots on this
you sound like a dumb bitch please stop talking help me get
back please let me know You're an ugly bitch, kill yourself.
Oh, so when I ask you, I ask you to see you, we're muted
off.
God, I've got it.
Oh, my God.
You sound like a pedophile.
Don't speak to me.
Oh, my God.
A real original bear.
Well played.
See, this is why I queue rivals rank.
This is why I queue rivals rank, guys.
This is why I do it.
Oh, can we double?
I'm done.
Good double, good shit.
You guys are talented.
This is why I play rival.
If we double all, my emphasis is still dead.
No, you are trash at the game.
You just died when we double ulted Are you returning?
This is what we play rivals for.
At least they blame the Invis and not me.
They picked one support and it wasn't me.
That's Marble Rivals, baby.
That's Marble Rivals.
You know what?
Now you guys...
No!
If you go...
By going Cloak, you're only making...
Proving him right!
You're only proving him right if you go Cloak!
Oh, that's a lot of...
That's a lot of shots.
Welcome to Marvel Rivals.
That's what I'm talking about, baby.
Come back, kill him!
Oh my god, kill him, please!
Okay.
Whoa.
as long as it's not me but it might be me soon though oh my
god what the fuck please please oh my god I'm alive I'm
fucking oh he has all up though
that man definitely has all
okay all right i don't know
oh my god slog is not me i'm freaking i'm fine with that
don't worry they'll shoot me next guys do not worry they'll
shoot me next
wow i wonder what party they're having on the other team
what kind of party is going on on the other team i wonder
well one season it is cod lobby it's just it always has been
And both teams get the...
Oh, maybe the other team would surrender.
Who would surrender first?
The team you got, Lavi.
The issue is which team will surrender first?
I've never met such a miserable person in my life.
I'm glad I love my life.
He's fine, right?
No, they're so fine.
All right.
There's that guy over there.
Ooh, is there Venomo?
Yeah, he's okay.
He's all right.
There we go.
Whoa!
Whoa, okay.
That's unlucky.
you i didn't realize i was taking millions of damage here
that's on me that's actually on me i didn't realize how much
damage i was taking i thought i was i thought i was
invincible guys i legit thought i was king of the world oh i
got you i got you cloak i don't know about you though I got
you
Yeah, cloak all right, okay, it's okay
All right, it's okay.
What?
Let me out first What is that my scent?
It's not me
It's okay not me but to Oh my
god, it's just...
Alright, not me though.
Oh, shit.
Hey, what's going on?
Well, I hope I live.
You know, I hope I...
Okay, she lives.
Well, one of us has to die and it's not me not yet now i'll
whoa i'm looking i'm going inside i'm going inside i'm
holy maybe i should have stayed outside maybe i should have
stayed outside i don't know my bad i should have stayed
outside.
I got insta-deleted, dude.
That was crazy.
I actually got insta-deleted.
Oh, is our venom okay?
I'm a little worried.
No, I'm not on one healing.
They was just fucking around, you know?
JK you know
what all right let's go over this man there you go wait got
you there we go oh my god there we go oh
he wants to oh so badly when he's a Live?
How?
I am ready to put on a show.
Can you look tired?
Oh, shit.
I can't even see him.
That wolf?
Yeah.
I had a feeling.
Oh, my God.
That wolf?
Yeah.
That sounds like we're so...
Ooh, we're so ultable.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ooh, whoa.
We're so vulnerable and ultable.
Any moment now.
You know you want to.
I need a bit more power.
Bro, they're still going?
I like how our guys shut the fuck up
Bro, it's just him Him against the world Nobody else is
saying anything at that point
Please heal That's unlucky I got hard dove there
Maybe we're not so different You and I Ha ha ha
You're not fucking, let's go!
Let's go!
What's going?
Oh my god!
Oh, I guess I die here.
It's okay.
It's not Ignite Band, so I have this.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Who is he letting it out on?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
He's doing it!
Oh my god!
I am ready to put on a show!
He's doing it!
Ah shit, that's me!
It's okay, it's okay, we're still doing it.
We're so healthy.
I had to reload, but it's okay.
We're still doing it.
Oh my god, we did it.
We're so healthy.
We're so well.
Hey, you and Bucky would be good friends.
What?
Oh my god.
Wait, what, what's going on?
Yeah.
Welcome to Marvel Rivals, baby.
Welcome to Marvel Rivals.
Yeah.
Oh
What a fun game
That's what I'm talking about guys.
I would cry if I I would cry if I was on that team I
wouldn't cry but you know what I mean, you know what I mean
I was on that team, you know Bro was writing a fucking
story.
God, I wasn't a target there.
If I was off stream I would cry.
Alright.
My whole ass essay.
That's what I mean.
people are damn.
This guy was not happy this guy was not happy at all oh
there's a reason why he was there's a reason why he was not
happy guy oh hey oh is pizza here pizza did you want to play
bro i'll ditch gomez pizza
like literally download re-downloaded rivals too no pizza i
i would ditch you i would ditch gomez pizza come on bro you
even re-downloaded a game too that's up i know live on
stream
Pizza's a real, bro.
Yeah, honestly.
Come on, pizza, get on.
Get on.
I'll invite you and I'll leave and then we'll kick him out.
He already left rivals.
I'm good, son.
All right.
Q up.
Why are you question marking?
I'm not.
Plan B, that's way too high.
There's a couple of letters after that.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I wonder what I want to be.
I want to play Mantis.
Ow.
Me mantis.
Me gonna mantis.
I need water.
Oh wait, I do have water.
Let me rehydrate real quick.
Guys, okay, don't judge me.
And then every time I say that, you're like, we're gonna
judge you.
I might not have had lunch yet.
I took a bite out of like an egg bite, but I haven't eaten
lunch yet.
Or food.
But I'm not hungry.
i think it's just because i ate too much yesterday i'm not
even hungry at all
all right guys you don't understand you guys gonna bang
something i i'll tap for two guys don't understand i ate so
much on the cruise guys buffet almost every day do something
adam adam they get black cat right oh crap we banned adam is
they have a runs at him when he's losing i just wanted to
take out his alternative strategy and then he takes my oh my
god all right i'm done bro i'm done let's see that's fair
that's fair guys it's because i pretty sure we can find a
way to work together though guys i believe i believe oh whoa
make BP work whoa guys yeah what if I am like a camel I can
heal her tank if we just run no we need to make the BP work
yeah make the BP work I just want to hero bastard you
bastard all right here we go the bp will not work
spoiler the bp will not work oh my god oh never mind all
right here we go
even so it's always nice to have a couple and they got a
penny bro there's a spider-man guys watch out whoa okay that
map freaked me out there well goodbye bros
guys don't worry the bp's gonna work it's everybody but the
bp working right now it's it's everybody but the bp that's
working NZ.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Guys, everything but the BP is working right now.
Don't want to reload.
No, I have to reload.
I did everything I could.
Oh my god.
Don't.
Oh, don't worry.
There is a res though.
There's a res.
No, some words.
No some words.
I killed.
We're gonna make the ball.
Shit.
I literally saw the mines too.
I saw the mines.
I saw the mines in front of me and I knew it was gonna be Oh
my god I lived as long as I could
Surely the BP will work Guys the BP is gonna work guys Damn
it Luna Luna is on point Oh my god.
Oh
Guys the BP is gonna work guys
Okay, it's fine right?
Can't bring her I didn't rock in this one There you go Don't
worry PP's gonna work, guys.
I'm 80 to Luna.
You know what?
Watch this.
20 is all.
It's fine.
It still works.
Oh, look at that placement!
I leave.
Y'all admit, that was a sexy-ass fucking placement, right?
Oh, we did not need that.
Y'all admit, he is here why are you still here why this guy
this guy actually followed me everywhere how how was he
there how i was like in quarters i mean that's fine he's mad
as well i was lit oh hey how did he hello i was legit like
How?
I was in a fucking house.
Oh, he's coming.
That's how you feel.
This is how, that's what I mean.
This is how you feel.
Like, going through that, that shit's not fun.
It didn't matter.
And then...
She had to play that.
Can I get a, like, snowflake or something so I can get up?
Bye.
put it in you know thank you thank you thank you he's gonna
make he's gonna he's gonna make it work guys he's gonna want
to rocket guys he's gonna mix bottom at work let's go
okay I can't even if I freeze that spidey we gotta kill that
motherfucker you guys gonna go in or what don't worry we're
gonna make make vp work we're gonna make vp work don't worry
the whole plan is to make vp work and we're gonna make it
work here i am ready one shot all right
first don't worry maybe not oh no it dies i'm behind him on
my shift just right behind on your learner by the eye of our
god nice popping luna on the low right side he has all he
has all i could i tried i tried i tried i tried i tried do
not worry we're gonna make bp work
You gotta make me see him.
You just walk with Luna.
Oh.
Guys!
It's gonna work eventually.
Do I have to... I feel like oh mantises ain't gonna have to
be fun for me.
Guys, do not worry.
He said he's gonna make It work and I believe in him guys
When he said he'll make it work.
I know damn well.
It's gonna work
I know I know it's gonna work guys guys is gonna work
Guys is gonna make it work
He's gonna make it work I don't get him guys guys I don't
understand why it's not work guys I'm shooting his ass up in
the air because we have fucking storm BP guys I don't get it
i don't i don't understand what's not working why is i don't
understand dude they're so low bro spec and heal i don't
understand bro i just don't understand
He's so right.
What's not working?
What could it be?
I just don't understand.
Okay.
Oh.
Yeah!
Oh!
okay we do might need i should have been on bucky i just
don't understand
oh my god maybe he should have been on bucky a w bubble oh
my gosh i don't understand maybe maybe i'll pop something
pop something Bob what?
No heals.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should have been on Bunky.
You're thinking it was Twitch Prime thinking thank you.
I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
He almost, what was it called when, when, when AI like
realized they're real, like, LOL just go triple tank easy
win when he like became yeah he became sentient he finally
became yeah he became sentience yeah I don't know dude I
haven't seen either of them from you if I can gain sentience
there well maybe I should have been a buggy I forgot oh hell
no wait oh my god we're running triple tank run like angel
or something yeah that that's slow realization oh my god
maybe i maybe i should have been i could have been playing a
king that's like insane
Oh, I hear Spooner Man.
Don't you love it in your Marvel Rivals game when your
players gain sentience mid-game and realize they were the
problem?
That wild moment when they realized they were the problem.
it's crazy oh you got my reds oh it's because it broke right
behind
sometimes you gotta wait for it until it clicks that's so
low
that's actually crazy i did not it's very rare when a player
gains sentience it's it's very rare for that to happen so so
it's always a welcome welcome moment in life you know just
to be like oh my god it happens it actually happens I got a
support oh we're down to support Spidey on her we have Luna
soon anyway she'll be five Yes, he should be fine.
All right, let's see if she's... Oh my god, really?
Oh my...
Where did I... Oh my god.
Okay, whatever.
Okay.
All right, Mike, look at Mike, look at Mike, look at Mike.
oh my god oh my god that trapped in that room bro you should
have looked at him
i don't know how i lived i lived longer than i should have
that spider-man was trying to hard cap me for so long the
fact that i actually lived through that is crazy I think we
might need to get off Iron Man.
Yeah, I love you.
Yeah, I was going to say the same thing.
I want to put out my rose.
She definitely has all.
Yeah.
Are you serious?
Me!
Instead of the Luna!
A fucking corset's me.
Me!
He like gets so lulled at me.
Look at course he did.
Oh, there he comes again.
Buddy back for it.
All right, watch my my rose is just going to get destroyed
again.
I'll patch you up.
They have plenty of health.
Thanks for the shield.
Oh my god.
I have Luna.
Bro, this is hell.
This is hell.
I have rest.
Slide your first.
There we go.
Oh my god, two minutes of this.
Maybe potential for...
No.
They both, yeah.
we almost have a rocket we can go from there
oh my that's fine that's fine I'll take that I'll take that
I'll take that I'll take that
I'll take that.
I'll take the spoils for that.
That was worth it.
Don't worry.
Oh, he lives.
He lives.
I threw that just for him.
He went.
Oh, guys.
Please like, please like, please like, please like.
Oh my god, another one.
Oh my god.
Wow.
much easier oh my god he got another one looks funny as old
the fact is like wait i got another kill there i'm like how
we're just too scattered here
like easy okay i'm i'm getting away from
bro bro okay there's nothing i could do any heels i need
heels oh my god what do you want i need heels i'm right
clicking galore i've never kept up like no offense guys but
holy crap
really i'm with the team and i'm dying i'm right click hide
if you opened up your eyes you would and then the res is
gone so then we have we have a no pressure in the front line
because I'm dead oh no but it feels though it feels I'm not
blaming on heels I'm just saying like no no no you're saying
just shut up I can't match I cannot match it's a nuke right
there that's a fucking i need to luna walk him down walk him
down bro i don't know what to do bro i don't know i feel
like i'm not kidding i'm like what do you i cannot right
click any harder not gonna lie i wish i could i wish there
was an option to turn intensity up like that's crazy
like like see bro i have a lot to look at man i'm like holy
crap i'm behind mag too i'm not ulting for this i have my
name back up back up back up damage
You guys, you guys, the hood dies.
Magin, Magin.
Or Mag.
Hoodlow.
I got him.
I'm cooked.
I want him.
No support.
You're down two healers.
Yay!
I watch you straight line in the open and you play heals.
Do you just not know positioning at all?
that has four buttons that give you shields every single
time i don't know i just don't know i'm not getting healed
i'm not i just like i was just like i don't know we're
talking about healing he's like i don't know why no one's
healing me i say as i'm fucking chucking orbs into his back
i'm just like what do i do
That's crazy.
I'm like, there's no way.
What is it?
Is it me?
No, it's the heels.
No, I will make BP work.
There isn't a heel doll to get more heels for his healers
from the healers.
Bro.
beef guys beefy was gonna work guys trust us the moment he
realized he could have picked bucky the moment he gained
sentient that was a crit you don't get that often in marvel
rivals but when you do but when you do it is a wonderful
time yeah it
was like a sleeper agent it was gonna work watch out guys
they're gonna have someone on the enemy team that's forcing
BP storm
guys I bet you it's gonna finally work but but it's going to
work on his team on the enemy team of course yeah i bet you
it's going to finally work but it's going to work but he's
not on my team there's somebody called daddy angela so
that's why we just go thing and press right click on her the
whole game i don't play thing i'll do it too late not like i
can play my main role anyway
Ha ha ha!
Healy?
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Way up, Manta's open.
Alright, GG.
Triple tank time.
Yay!
Triple tank!
I just triggered.
I didn't even ban anybody.
Alright, here we go.
Play Luna, coward.
I don't like playing Luna anymore.
She's not as...
fun anymore yeah we play rocket mantis we might be
unkillable i didn't even ban anybody i don't know you said
my random ben there yeah the answer to the ban was your guys
ban on uh otp i said it was random to make him mad oh okay
it's not as fun anymore
Luna's not as fun anymore.
She's like miserable to play.
Since you had to expect... Oh, there it is!
Don't worry guys, gonna...
No, I bet you it's actually gonna work though.
I bet you.
It's actually gonna work because it's on the enemy team.
Like...
Let's have some sentience if we're gonna be doing this.
I'm at the swap.
I actually might have to swap.
And it's not enough heals.
Yeah, we don't have enough healing for that combo.
Oh, they're not gonna run the beat.
Oh, now then, oh, this is a storm Iron Man duo.
What a weird duo.
I don't think I'm making it in time.
There's no way.
Well, actually, yeah, yeah, yeah.
going going
oh my god oh
my god i just got it i don't know where that is i don't know
what that is i was blinded
oh that's unlucky that was such a good line too that was
such a good Okay, I'm gonna have to go mega some shit.
Yeah, if I could see it, I would be able to fucking run away
We need some hitty scan boys, I feel I mean, we definitely
don't need a fantastic air Oh, this is bad
Are we gonna be okay?
Oh, whoops.
I missed it
Oh my god, they made it happen halfway.
Oh, I'm gonna...
Oh my god.
Please do something with that.
What is going on?
What is happening?
I can't see anything!
I'm out of damage.
Like, it's really hard to stay here and play.
Oh my god, can we even touch?
Can we even touch?
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Crazy hard dude.
They had a lot of healing.
Or we just aren't doing anything.
We're not doing any damage.
Maximum pulse.
Oh that has a good...
I would love to be able to...
Oh yeah, we're gonna heal.
You know what?
Okay, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Let's run it.
I'm tired of getting pushed up.
Let's do something about that.
And I'll swap to... I don't know, I'll swap to Invisors.
Oh, maybe I should have saved.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
What the... What is going on?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my...
Oh, that was not where I expected it to be.
I was gonna die on point.
I was gonna die.
I'm just gonna die on point.
Oh, I don't know.
Invis?
You know what?
It's time.
What I learned from the tournament.
I died.
This is what I learned from the tournament.
tournament.
That's insane, huh?
Oh my god, where is it?
Where is that?
Oh my god, what?
I did not see that.
What angle?
Oh, there.
Oh, Eva, thank you.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
a good stream not really well it doesn't really matter i
hope you had a good stream thank you for the raid why did he
yell both of these characters aren't bad why did he yell
dokey bird like i'm a pokey man
go dokey bird
All right, here we go.
All right, I guess I'll play Cloak for the...
Maybe we'll just need more healers.
Who knows?
We went from two tanks and they're like we need more damage
and now now all right Three DPS I feel bad for our mag Guys,
we don't have enough damage
There's only one thing to do when that happens yet Clearly
this
it's the only way whoops I double tapped it JK it's not what
I was trying to now I don't know guys do we maybe have oh
wait I don't even have the hood like I don't believe oh I
just realized there's no reason for me to be close there's
no hood I just almost made it I almost made it too.
Why am I even playing cloak?
There's no reason.
Whatever.
It's alright.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my.
Oh.
Team.
do you think I should ult this I should ult this let's fight
let's do it goodbye
that's I don't know about that mag honestly look I either
die to the mag or I die if I get what's good I either die to
the mag or I die to the iron man there's no it didn't help
that our mag fucking yeah that that was not ideal
oh i forgot to surrender it didn't matter anywhere
i'm gonna die here yep if only i got to live a little longer
it's fine hey guys they as long as they didn't make they did
guys guys they didn't make BP work and that's a moral
victory that's just remember they didn't make they didn't
make BP work and that's a itself if you think about it
that's like that's a victory there guys just remember what
the fuck we have a portal
Oh What why do we all back out?
That's okay the entire it's the entire team's fault
The entire team had problems Sometimes sometimes a team just
you know know sometimes a team just doesn't work and those
are one of those moments sometimes sometimes a team just
doesn't work you know sometimes sometimes some teams are
just it's okay i'm pretty sure my entire that entire team
avoided each other so i'll never have i'll maybe see one of
them one or two of them again but like it's all right just
not meant to be meant to be guys yeah sometimes you win
sometimes you lose
cool oh okay alright well I need to pee I'll be right back
guys
is it still bugged or can wait why is it on okay let's see
is it still bugged or do they still is do they fix Well, I
feel like Jeff is fixed.
I know Jeff is fixed.
All right, I go pee now for it real.
Pop, pop.
All right, I'll be right back.
Yeah!
I'll take another bite of the egg bite.
I don't like it.
It's gross.
no it's not bad i don't know i just didn't like it i just
didn't i bought it just because i was like okay i'll get a
little breakfast because it was so early and i was just like
nope that wouldn't taste that good oh hey my daughter lost
eternity or not eternity one above uh yay we're all losing
yay
Yippee!
Hey, we...
I know, team suffering.
It's like the husband and wife duo.
I'm sorry, that's a low blow.
I'm sorry.
That's a low blow.
Also, I'm surprised.
Not gonna lie.
I'm so surprised.
like okay gail's team is so stacked with um stacked for him
because his support player is literally his girlfriend that
he plays with 24 7 so it's like i'm surprised nobody stole
the girlfriend like you know i feel like i feel like if like
i think it's funny too you know obviously gail would want to
draft his girlfriend on his team so like i'm so surprised
that like no one thought about because it'd be so funny, you
know, like, you know, girlfriend versus boyfriend, you know?
Nobody stole the girlfriend pick, you know?
He wasn't first, I don't think he was first draft, because
he was in the middle draft.
He drafted, he was the middle, he picked in the, he was the
middle.
So nobody picked the girlfriend, yeah.
That would've been peak, but now like, oh, now it's so, now
it's so romantic.
boyfriend and girlfriend on the same team and winning games
together I'm so happy for you I no now it gets to be
romantic like oh yeah
I think it would have been funny though I but no like his
team is literally like you know he has jitward and he has
his girlfriend who he who he plays with every almost every
day in rank so they already have um they already have like
synergy together you know oh yeah no he didn't first pick
his girlfriend he first picked jitward he he didn't even
first pick he didn't first pick his girlfriend he first
picked jitward though
damn yeah yeah yeah yeah but then he risted all he risted
all being like no one's gonna pick my girlfriend till i pick
her that's fucked what if some i i'm so surprised that's
what i'm saying i'm so because she's not like she's one
above all she's the one above all support player that plays
this game every single day so i'm that's why i'm like super
surprised um i'm super that like no one else like picked her
until like i mean they i mean gail picked her but you know
like the people before or after gail didn't pick her before
gail could
so his team is like super synergized you know like he like
you know they both know how they each of each of the they
both know how they each play
so i'm saying i'm saying like why did no one steal the
girlfriend It would have been so funny, you know?
It would have been so silly.
Oh, we're done.
No, we didn't win, but we weren't last, so that's all that
matters.
We weren't second last either.
Yeah, all the couples got to be in the same team together.
Where's the drama?
the suspense pick
your hero or villain I'm not judging I'm not the type who
fades well you know I mean oh we're running wolf so I guess
I have to play Luna I don't really want to play the Loki I
don't even know Loki's yam is good anymore I
get a jump head going white box is always with me in spirit
30 seconds before what happened thank you thank you whoa
it's lunar time it's lunar time I got it I want to do it for
the world oh whatever I don't even want it anyway Oh my god,
Gomez playing Star Lord.
I should have not...
I feel like Star Lord hasn't, like, really been played a
lot.
Should we be practicing Apex?
Yes.
After your rivals.
And then I'll practice Apex.
I guess.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Jesus Christ.
That's a lot of damage.
He's off.
Oh my god, he is.
Oh my god.
So much damage.
Okay.
I guess I should play it.
And then reload.
Wait, all right.
Okay.
All right.
I release him.
Oh
my god, I'm strong.
The thing just swap off.
I don't know how to put anything into full.
How did we lose that?
We don't have anything to take damage.
I don't think...
It's a double pull.
I don't know.
I think it might be a thing thing.
Possibly.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I don't even know if we should...
I'm not fucking... I'm not doing...
I'm not alting that.
That's no reason for me to alt that.
Yeah.
Well, maybe I should play Loki.
Maybe it's a...
Maybe it's a Loki angle.
It's not like there's a tank that fully fucking counters
him.
No, there's no way there is What
the fuck happened?
Don't shit
Should we, can we, I think he copied, I think he copied, uh,
he definitely did not copy the gambit Maybe go Mag Okay,
thank you so much for some reason Mag is banned for some
reason we banned them oh my god we're actually um yeah
amazing we're illiterates yep it's us we did it
oh my god this thing is pushing can i kill this guy hell boy
hell boy can i shoot shoot the emma hello oh
We did it, we shot him!
Let's see it.
Why do you go the biggest character into Punisher of Bucky?
Sometimes, sometimes that's just life.
Sometimes that's just life.
Sometimes, that's how we go.
This guy is out of BC banned Magneto and he picks Dino
Thing.
That is not world.
That is pure stinkage.
This guy does not shower.
Oh my god, wait, he did.
He banned Mag.
you see still okay stop playing oh yeah good luck guys
i don't even know if he does he batting mag but leaving pun
open does he we are hope and i don't even i go play dive
dive counter spoke do you know any dive tanks well the guy's
not i'm trying to follow up with every single one of your
dives is just that map it's kind of hard for that if you can
do it here i mean it'll be better it's not gonna work bruce
we should just like hard focus the people i'm grabbing no
they're just walking away
like what is true alive so you get double hit scan mokey
gambit and what do we get we got a thing
you get double hit scan if we get thick.
This life.
It's just life.
At that point.
Oh my god, he went back in?
Crazy.
I thought we, I thought our plan was the guy.
I thought we had a plan and it was the guy.
all right well there he goes there he goes oh he's alive
there he goes there he just pressed into all of them oh
no man i i'm not using that oh my god it couldn't do
anything oh my god all of the century I'm back in the fight
Yeah, I did it The craziest all I've ever seen You know,
I'll just give it to him.
You know what?
I'll just give it to this thing How would you right now?
Well
All right What?
We'll take what we can get at this point.
Well, you know how you're just like, I'll take what we can
get.
Sometimes that's life.
We just gotta give what God gives us.
Oh my god.
Oh my, I don't want to be there.
be there we didn't build it oh my god we'll do it as soon as
i hot it why you already saw five people dead
well well now we know who to avoid yeah all right i mean
sure
Guys...
Ah...
Oh my god.
I didn't even realize there was a bucky up.
It is.
Fantastic.
But 2-11, 2-11, 2-11, 2-11, 2-11, 2-11.
The thing ain't going nowhere.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
Hey, hey.
At least I'm dragging people down.
Avoid the 2-11 terrorists.
I'm just wondering at this point maybe he just doesn't speak
English you know maybe he just doesn't speak English I mean
so there's no I fucked up I added him
wait I'm gonna I'm trackering this guy I'm bringing out the
tracker now and I know the website we are everyone up there
knows the website i need to know who you are buddy i need to
know how have you oh my god wait no it was more than that
look at look at our wolves damage what oh not bad
he's a gambit player this wait i'm
is it gabby no not the gambit player look at our wolf
look at both of them all three of them all three of them
there's many problems look there's many problems with
everybody but all right look all right i'm analyzing
analyzing he saw he saw the he saw the tracker he saw you
can the moment you tell you know that he opened the link to
the tracker when
the tracker hits which hero
do you think you want to be
if you know you know if you know the website you know i
looked him up he has an 80 win rate on on gambit but because
we also we had another gambit player yo yo that wasn't the
the same person.
Uncle, I think it was Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Meow.
Who did that?
Oh, meow.
Meow in my ear.
That's funny, though.
Holy shit.
Yeah, this guy is like a full-on gambit player.
No, stop purring.
I don't care.
I don't care all the emails.
I did not want to see a meow on DPS.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah, the thing guy was just a full-on gambit player.
He plays nothing else.
Oh, we're not at PA.
I was in this.
Kill him as you tank.
Kakapata's a little madigan if you want to play something
else.
Yep.
I'm in streaming for it.
team up oh a while let's do it let's do it why are you
getting off of it no no i don't trust myself i just like the
team up for tp i don't even know what the next one does i'll
play cook no i'll play cook not fuck it i'm doing it keep
yelling start purring Whoa.
Let me have voice pack in Discord.
I'll put it on my soundboard.
Lock in, lock in, yo.
It's too gay for him.
He's like, bro.
There's no homo.
Just say no homo after.
That's how it works.
He's like, bro, buddy.
Too much, buddy.
Black with the flanking.
I need help Jan he's hot he's still there he's one oh my god
yeah my fault where the fuck is he still there oh
my oh my god
oh my i'm so scared i am so scared black one on the right oh
they have okay all right here we go let's hope he doesn't
have it
all right um okay all right good luck loki good luck if they
have mag in our metal just for you!
Good luck!
It's for you!
It's not for me!
He's always on the left.
He's always on the left, what is he?
Good luck!
Don't be!
It's okay.
I might have to...
And I got ulted.
By the end, I couldn't ult it.
It's fine.
I might have to go invis for him.
I don't think he...
I don't think...
I don't think he'll survive.
It's not me!
Oh shit.
As long as it's not me.
Oh shit, he swapped off Dewey.
Perfect precision.
Oh shit.
What is going on?
Bro, what the fuck is this man?
Oh, it's dead!
Bro, yeah, I don't know, man.
I'm just kidding.
Where's our TV?
They put me in the exact same place.
Dude, what?
Oh, he's so dead.
Oh, God, and hope.
Oh, my God.
I don't think that was a good play.
Oh, and then...
Alright, that was an accident.
Do I have one?
Oh.
Mag, mag.
I have a...
We're doing the right, she's one.
Gonna shoot an Ironman.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Oh, here's the meows.
I'm gonna play, I'm gonna flag with him out.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Rocket.
I thought you be okay no one died
who's who's first all right rocket you go first rocket i
believe
nah boy that's fine i don't even know i don't even know all
right Like, ow, I'm in there.
Maximum pulse!
Not me, at least.
It's okay, not me.
All right.
Okay, now we have Black Widow.
We'll figure this out, guys.
We'll figure it out.
We're gonna we're gonna figure it out guys what we need.
We're gonna figure it out My sorry, I looked away that was
my bad.
I actually trolled there I looked to the chat.
I didn't realize widow was right beside me That rocket must
be so mad now
Actually looked at chat there whoops see this is why being
concrete is hard
all right there is a widow black of the one on the right
nice black widow was to the right that's good that's good
we're stabilizing that's what we like to see some
stabilization clearly
you need to clear the way I am Oh, we don't have anything
for that.
I got all up to this.
What the fuck is going to shield, but...
Oh my god.
Okay, we don't have to use this then.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's no longer fine.
Okay.
All right.
Sorry, I was not expecting that.
big no thank
god for the res thank god nobody portal thank god everybody
was so egotistical that nobody portal that came from the
song it did I was like no not
here you go watch i show speed that guy you can you can try
to mimic his barks he like does it from the from the gut you
gotta like you gotta make sure like you sound like you want
to do it have you heard joe rogan bark joe rogan bark yes
he's good bro he's a tall guy yeah yeah yeah i've tagged a
hot spot wolf wolf gotta go bark on him Damn, you're
learning a lot of Marvel rivals.
Yo, that who's just going?
Woof, woof.
Good boy.
Fucking loser.
Well, we got a little freebie.
I need to sound like a pussy there.
I'll do it better.
Oh.
Good boy.
Fuck you.
Wait, that was my rocket?
That's good enough.
You could say it's a little twizzy.
At least, hey, we'll...
At least like, it's... we got the vibes going on, you know?
At least...
No matter what, at least they're...
Oh, shit.
No, I'm like...
She's still behind.
No, she's not.
Can you hold me a little bit?
Wait, there's a...
Widow one.
Why is this widow still there?
Oh my god.
That widow is still behind.
I don't know why.
This storm is like getting with murder.
We have to like shoot him.
No, I was trying.
I don't know what to do.
Might go Emma too to be honest.
We'll see.
Wait, why am I even playing Invis?
I'm gonna look at that.
Three, two, one, walk, walk, walk, walk.
There's a sniper right over there.
A hard one.
I don't have anyone like shooting in the front line.
that like a full star of attention you're gonna die you
might die he did die i never say i'm gonna only play one
game i want to swap characters it's clear i'm still needed
here
i'll go to the luna oh my god rocket's still alive how
You're not old.
I'm home.
We're ready.
We're so ready.
Get our yarn on.
Oh, no.
Yo, like, what was your plan there for them?
Can we like fight?
If I didn't get stunned, I have my E.
Can we like- Can someone pop something?
I don't know.
oh my god we're popping everything i guess oh thank you me
up oh no he doesn't know where i am i guess what are you
doing what are you what's happening i don't my rocket just
I swap I don't know why you're not you're going everything
by Emma I don't know if Emma's gonna help us like we gotta
mark these off angles no because my DPS are like shooting
their backline and not the front line whenever we do diving
guys I don't think it's winnable anymore I guys I don't
think I even we have our meows you know despite everything
wait there's things still behind us what is he got to do
something bro like you can't just do fucking nothing what is
he not behind us no DPS players I'm not even a tank player
and these guys just I I could have played it should have
should have let me solo tank bro where does the widow not
behind us new ability teleport 12k damage who oh that guy
I'll him.
Put your money where your meow is.
The survival by doing nothing.
It's all right.
I can always get it back.
The meow deeper.
I don't even think he was the problem.
He was doing fine.
He was honestly doing fine.
I let him die that one time because I was looking at chat.
That was on me, I take full responsibility on that.
I did look at chat.
I will say, I did look at chat.
My bad.
Yeah, apparently meowing is not the meta.
I think the meowing is a pup.
Oh, oh.
Oh, the game did not want me to see Jeff shake his booty.
It's understandable.
Understandable.
It's like no more shaking booty for you.
I was like, alright.
That's fine.
I didn't want to do it anyway.
Go Mr. Ink to Celestial 3.
Perhaps washed?
I'm ready.
I have to disassociate a little bit.
I play thing.
Now I understand when they were telling me that rank got...
I don't know.
It feels similar.
Rank has always been like bad.
Doesn't feel like any good, any better.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
We bad hood.
Interesting.
Pick your hero.
or villain i'm not judging um we want to play maybe it's my
turn to put oh wait mantis is open mantis is open yippee
it's always a treat
i feel like games have either been like a stomp or uh a
stomp or uh on either side there's no or it's one or it's
one stop in the next stop stop we're getting stopped yeah
honestly oh my god oh my god amazon music was playing in the
background i was like why am i hearing
you know the front page it auto played oh I hope yeah I was
like why am I listening all right let's hope this is oh I
hear I hear daredevil oh shit that guy got deleted who's
with me who's with me who's with me okay okay oh my god i'm
lagging i'm lagging here oh bye i'm actually lagging i i was
tp what the fuck see like you know you understand time right
when i said like you was not having a good time like imagine
like like having to deal with that for her and i'm having a
rough time because it's like
like no one has fun
oh my god what the is going
all right no thankful can die nice oh nice
Oh, it's this guy.
Meow?
Oh, it's...
It's Meow guy!
It's him!
He's gonna meow!
I think he's meowing right now to motivate.
Oh, shit.
I don't have to use anything there.
He's having fun meowing I didn't even avoid Oh, I wonder if
Gomez avoided him
Hello, buddy Time to go to bed First timing this shit, this
shit's easy What the fuck
That shit is so OP I'm having a fun time
Alright Alright I'll I have um I used to have an alt account
that goes that's me alt first so I can I don't have to say
anything just read my account name oh yeah remember someone
was like who else first and I wrote back my read my account
name me alt first so I never have to say anything That is
all right.
It helps.
Oh, avoid blade.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
I'm ready.
I'm so, so burnt.
Me up first.
I don't have to talk to anyone.
Just me up first.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Me up first.
Maybe I shouldn't have just altered that.
I don't know.
I got slow though.
I mean it works.
Me up first works.
Oh shit.
Poor guy.
Oh my god.
Go in, go in!
Yeah!
Oh no, he's gonna pick one of us, and it's me, picked me,
picked me!
He's gonna
pick one of us, and he picked me!
I'll have all of you.
Yeah.
What?
I mean all right I'm fine with that I don't even I did build
all fast I didn't win all
right damage boost damage boost let's go I wanted to take
the elevator my turn
practice apex
I was planning on like flying back tomorrow but that was
just like it's fine I feel like okay volume wise guys how
how's vol like I don't know sound team said it's what do you
guys think how do you guys think about the sound like I know
it's like you know it's not my setup obviously it's like it
could be better like Yeah, it was like, it's, yeah, I felt
like, you know,
it sounds retro.
I'm about to say it's good.
I thought it was, oh my god.
Oh, awesome.
There was no way to save it.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I don't know if I want to.
play all right i don't know if i want to play with mantis oh
i almost killed luna all right do we stay mad actually we're
on the whole thing now with mantis
oh no i feel like you should play a hood or anything
might play hood or not hood, uh, cloak I'm walking on their
mag he can die oh my god I have no slam I'm on a new guy
you're serious oh my god oh my god he slams his half bp1 bp1
oh i'm just we're trying to so
mag one i'm on cart alone they even a tank oh my god
we lived that
jesus christ i'm i'm just surprised
where is he
oh my god i'm backing out now oh we have jubilee all at
least
All right, I gotta focus up.
I gotta focus up.
That's good.
We win the fight if we just don't die.
Mantis, I'm gonna ult.
I don't know.
That's fucking stupid.
I didn't.
Looking bad as widow.
He's playing fucking.
Bro is playing Dino.
Bro is fucking playing Dino and they're like bro.
We are bad as widow bro I'll push guard Electric thank you
for the raid.
Thank you.
We had a good stream
All right, I'm just gonna BPM me Where is he?
Oh, there he is
What the fuck since when can you do that dude?
I have never seen that shit before.
There's like this random moon night there.
I don't know what's going on.
I can't see shit.
Oh, they agreed to surrender?
We just got here.
Yay!
everyone in this game avoid our ultron which one God I was
talking about the pro play I wonder who it was
I wonder who our pro was like are we serious
God need a bad mama Super Gomez doesn't carry I guess
oh yeah this guy who is the this guy was pretty good at uh
bp
all right what do we have yeah who was i guess we'll never
know who that pro was i guess we'll never know it's a
mystery does someone make bp work no i'm Unfortunately, I
have yet to see someone make BP work.
Oh my god, the double aura.
I should have champ.
I have champ Luna, and I took that shit off.
I ain't putting that shit on, bro.
I have champ Luna because of the hours I spent playing Luna
beginning of the season.
Why?
It's just embarrassing.
Bro, I have...
Okay.
Look at this.
There's a reason why I'm not putting Chap Luna on here.
This is my season 9.
Last season, Luna win rate.
It ain't pretty.
You're like, can't be that bad.
Oh, it's not pretty at all.
I'll show it to you guys.
Let's see.
There's desktop.
I'm going to save random shit on my friend's PC.
Alright.
This is the reason why this is last season
This is why I don't put chat Luna icon on
Oh, but look at my rocket and mantis win rate though.
Okay, but my rocket and mantis win rate.
But my, guys, guys, my mantis and rocket though.
Guys, mantis and rocket.
Actually, what happened?
you're adamant in this that's why that's why i don't put my
chap luna on it's not pretty
wait how come we aren't using uh the cloak head came up yeah
she's broken no it is she doesn't know that's a chat that's
a not all cloak players guys remember not all cloak players
but somehow all cloak players what the fuck
what's going on i'm so okay i'm actually so confused there
everybody was so split up okay let's use the hood team up
Thank you.
I don't think she knows what it does.
Don't worry, I didn't either.
Don't worry, I did not know either, so it's not...
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
The Thor came out of downtown!
Oh my god, he got the stupid red shit.
It's okay, we got a cloak.
See, look at that!
Is she okay?
She's okay.
I'm not I want to All
right, it's fine She has all this fat.
I'm gonna help her
What oh my god, oh my get away from me Can you ride that was
just
Oh my god, how do I live that?
That was 20 ults.
There was no way to live that.
There's a lot.
Yeah, I'm not living through that.
I think that he did as well.
Yeah, there's Mantis, Rookie Starward.
Emma, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
I was just like, I wish I could.
I wish I knew what it was like to be alive.
Killed Starlight.
I killed Starlight.
Oh, nice.
Uh, walk this.
We can walk with Mantis, though, honestly.
Alright, well.
I don't think we need it.
Yeah, I wasn't planning.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
That's already...
I don't know why I thought that was like...
I was like, break that wall!
The wall!
Guys, I might have played too much rivals.
I think I played too much rivals today.
I was like, guys, we need to break that wall.
Don't...
Okay.
Alright.
I'm back really quickly.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on.
try oh my oh
i'm getting on here oh my i'm getting on here i think you
played two little rivals everyone was so split up i don't
know what to do there i hope we're healing him
all right Is
he okay?
Oh, I don't know about you.
They doubled.
Just live.
Oh, he's trapped.
Very easy to do.
Oh my god, he fucking hit the wall.
He hit the wall.
Go down.
Go down, Mantis.
But like, when we come through this portal.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Somebody anchor for him.
He's so close.
No!
We jumped off!
Wait, does my fade?
Does my fade make me not touch point?
It's a fade.
we're so close alright what was I was playing Mantis I don't
know I don't know I'll try I'm doing like an unbelievable
amount of like pressure I need my DPS to hold the M1 button
and kill them I'm gonna oh wait yeah I'll go Luna or not
like Invis
all right let's see i don't know i don't know if that just
works for us here just just too much oh i guess the sleep on
the thor maybe bro that's what i'm seeing guys guys no
there's no pros in celestial
i told you i just No, there's no pros in Celestial yet.
Oh my god, I'm trying to help our fucking hell out of here
now.
Hitting both I'm in three, two, one.
I'm on Mantis.
I got him.
I killed Mantis.
I killed that.
You see there's an emmer there.
They're down to Mantis, guys.
Lock in.
Okay, I was gonna sit.
We'll do it.
Come on, we're so close to an all right now.
There's a power on the upper left.
We got fun, we got fun.
Oh my god.
Please, I had this.
I had this.
I'm not trolling, literally trolling.
Oh my god!
God!
Why is someone helping me?
Just getting walked on by Emma and Thor.
I'm gonna need people, but I need the floor back.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
It's my mic.
No, we'll go.
Thor's gonna die.
Can't nice walk with that, please.
I'm hitting a nice walk with that, please.
I'm hitting back on in three, three, one.
Can we walk up, please?
I'm not seeing the backline.
Oh, can you fade?
Uh, blind up?
Anthe's dead.
Bucky behind, Bucky behind.
Or am I still...
Am I still crunchy?
George, on my left.
Am I...
I'll prevent him.
He captured more than half of the mission area.
Keep going.
Alexa.
Okay, mark this door and don't let me get through our
backline, please.
That's like either my DPS drop.
I'm going on the backline.
Mantis is dead.
Taz, we can kill them.
We can kill them.
They're down Mantis.
Bulk has no cooldowns.
Look at Cloak, wherever she is.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
I'm still needed here.
I feast for my crows.
Control lost.
I killed Cloak.
Oh, my god.
Feel the pull.
Coyotic surge.
Foggy's more.
Their team's capture progress has passed the halfway.
Okay.
Okay, we have Punisher off.
I think we could have used that for a lot of her.
Walk with them guys, walk.
Hell unleash!
I am
ready to put on a show!
I'll fight for my family until the end.
Do you want a Punisher TP?
They're
winning, but you've still got a chance.
No winner yet.
Going to overtime.
They got a chance.
Awesome.
Well,
you can't expect to win them all.
How about now?
Yay!
So,
so basically what happened was they saw me shit talking.
They saw these shit talking.
They came up, unplugged the power, and then it fit.
You guys heard the beep-boop.
Beep-boop.
I thought it was a microphone issue.
and yeah it actually just it actually was just unplug and
replay
and you just get a new cable i don't and just get a new
cable
i thought it was the microphone
I thought it was the microphone cable.
I didn't realize it was the power cable fixes it.
What kind of power cable?
I'm louder than before.
I'm fine.
All right.
am i a little louder than before
i don't even know
yeah okay all right it might have it might have went up
because i was trying to unplug everything i didn't realize
it was the power cable
i didn't know it was power you would think you okay okay You
would think, because I've had these issues before, when
something's crunchy, you would unplug, you would unplug the
mic cables, right?
That makes sense.
You would try the mic cable.
So I was unplugging both sides of the mic cable, because you
would think if it's crunchy, that's the issue.
Not the fucking power cable.
How is that supposed to know that?
Oh yeah, anyway, I was gonna show you guys this one too.
Let's see Because you guys were like why don't you put champ
on Luna because
Because this is my other account
This is this is the alt account
How bad is it?
Oh, you'll see oh don't worry you'll see
this is on the oak and this is the and this is the main it's
been true true true it's better than the main account that's
so true it is better than the main So you can tell why I try
I don't I try not to play Luna anymore But it's like a
cycle, you know, you don't play Luna and then you keep
getting worse on Luna because you don't play Luna So it's
like a continuous cycle of abuse Because I don't play Luna
so I lose more Luna skills and then It just gets worse yeah
I just don't put me on Luna guys that's better put me on
everything but Luna
but that's that's yeah it's not pretty
I became the the thing I've hated the most but I haven't
visited you know I haven't visited time square in a long
time I haven't checked it out in a while.
What's going on over there?
Oh no!
I just want to know what's going on!
Oh there's a sea- oh hey it's Olive!
Wait, she's still streaming?
I didn't realize she was still going at it.
Did she get out of C3?
Bring on her.
your friend
who am i gonna banish from this map i have i mean i was at
the bahamas but have you met the rivals beaches also yes one
time as they have two melee players they do oh because they
ban bucky that makes sense yeah it's iron fist and black
panther i'm sorry to everyone's ears i fucking ruined today
i'm sorry guys
oh what the how do i know this information don't worry about
it i believe you i know you saw you heard that if you're
sniping them are they sniping us i don't know I don't know
who's stream who's who's streaming right now
I wonder it's okay I'm on streamer mode EPS rocket in the
house I'm on streamer mode guys it's okay they won't know
yeah no it looks like they have three melee minute if
they're if they're stream sniping and i'm stream sniping
then who's playing the game for real allegedly as i say
all right here you go where's the caveman i'm saying i'm not
even streaming before i mean guys i haven't been streaming
you know guys guys it's been a while since i've streamed So,
like, we're getting it all...
I'm getting all out of the system, you know?
Guys, you guys did say you guys missed me, right?
Do you miss me enough to watch 7 plus hours of Marvel
Rivals?
Like...
How badly did you miss me?
Yes.
Apparently, yes.
That's right.
Do you miss me enough to watch 7 plus hours of Marvel
Rivals?
I'm sure it should play cloak though.
I feel like cloak is just so broken.
I might just...
Alright, nice.
Oh, you solo.
I need those.
You're right.
Alright, but do you miss me enough to watch eight hours of
Marvel Rivals?
Hmm?
What of eight hours of my horizon?
What are they aiming at?
Oh, okay.
I mean, that's fine.
Y 'all first.
All right.
Ours is better.
Welp.
I saved his life.
I did save his life when it happened.
Oh, we don't have res.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, I probably should have saved for her.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Look at magic.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm against dive.
Spider-Man, Spider-Man.
Oh, the way I got you.
Oh, whoa.
I don't think we have res though.
Oh, he's going to have.
Oh, my God.
You're beautiful.
I'm looking at that.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, please don't.
Oh, I'm trying to.
I almost got out.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm running.
Wait, kill the mantis.
Wait, stagger, stagger, stagger, stagger.
I ran against the wall.
Oh, my God.
Four, thank you for 25 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Yo, I'm blind.
It's okay.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
I know I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive.
The motherfuckers staggered.
Oh my god, what was that?
Oh my god, we're...
All right.
We're gonna have to...
Strangers on.
Nice.
Oh my god, look at...
There's a half Deadpool.
Still alive.
Oh my god, I ran out mouse pad space.
I ran out mouse pad space.
I was like, where's my mouse?
Where did my mouse go?
I don't give two shits, I'm gonna leave my second support to
die.
I get my value.
No.
Oh.
Why would Doki Bird play this game?
She's not even sponsored, Maya.
And even if she was sponsored, then, you know, she would be
asking for, like, Twitch subs, you know, like, Twitch Prime.
Go ahead, think of the 25 gifted.
Oh, I already said that.
Go ahead, take it with the 100 videos.
Thank you.
It's free every month.
30 seconds before you attack.
Did I heard that the real Doki bird that was like really
good at fighting games, no?
I heard that too.
I heard that Doki bird was bald, I don't know.
Is that true?
Bald?
Maybe?
That is true.
Like Mr. Queen type bald, like bald bald.
I got the name first.
You got the name first?
You know, they tried to trick everyone that she's a
different type of bird, but she's a bald eagle.
No, I gotta be bald.
Like, like, like crazy bald.
Damn.
Hey, less guys, you can spend less money on shampoo though.
Imagine, is that true?
No, you have to motion, you have to lotion your head, right?
Or you'd get like, you have to put sun, I guess the
alternative is that.
It's not a straight line.
You have to put like sunscreen on your head all the time
where you get sunburned on.
Or you get sunburned or some shit.
Oh, shit, nice.
I'm really walking.
Change, look, change, skills.
I'm like.
jaylock now look at methes dead there's a look rocket rat on
point rat on point right on point that's not on point
anymore maybe oh one above their portaling they're portaling
they're portaling where would they porter oh right oh my god
where did he go oh my god i'm the best building I don't know
what they're talking about.
I was here for a sound.
That bitch, Doki stole my name.
Imagine, though.
Imagine if you're like, you have a name, you have a
username, but some other famous content creator started
becoming famous with your username.
And then every time you go around playing games, god are you
that person and you're like bro chad fucking i've had this
username since like fifth grade like there has to be someone
that had that happen to them oh hey all of ggs what the hell
is here i've actually had that wait no that did happen it
was me okay before I was dokeybird I had another username
and I don't remember what that user that actually happened
to me but it happened to someone else because okay okay no I
wasn't the one who was like oh man oh man who is this person
that okay so this is why I also had to change my username
because people were harassing this poor girl because they
shared my username so it was me i that happened to me my
spidey senses are tickling me right now again so what
happened was um they have a bp hover what happened was um i
was getting popular in overwatch like because i was like i
played a lot of overwatch and had this username and it was
also my old twitter handle too and and people were like i do
not let also play who's this girl and they were like i hate
black panther no no no stop why why anyway um anyway so so
they started like harassing this poor girl on instagram
because they also had my username but they were there first
that's the thing that girl had my username first so people
started sending her messages and like started me like is
this is this jokekeeper before i was joking he's like is
this her is this her and i felt so bad so i changed my own
username because like she obviously had it first you know i
i was like it's fine oh we didn't ban bp no we didn't ban BB
just
peer okay we got the thing I could but yeah that does happen
it happened to me the battle starts in five four three two i
could go cloak ways cloak oh the bad cloak never mind
but guys do you guys miss me enough to watch uh nine hours
of rivals it just keeps going up a little magic oh my god
really looks like the mission area is going Oh my
god Holy shit there's so much damage There is so much damage
right now
Nice Oh my Oh my god That is so much damage I don't know
what I could do to change fate
I did not mean to jump there Oh my god, where is everybody
going though?
Oh my god.
What is going on?
What the fuck is going on?
Don't!
We're having...
Oh, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Let me explode.
Thought you wouldn't see me again.
Well, Rake, it's like Celestia.
I'm coming back.
I hope my team.
I mean, yeah, let's go.
Hey, if they used the portals, I used the portals.
Oh my!
Okay.
Oh,
my God, oh, my God, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I don't give
up so easily.
All right, back I go.
Back I go to hell, to the pits of hell.
It's okay.
Oh my god, he's solo.
He's actually solo.
Oh my god, what can I do?
Don't make me play my 33% win rate on Luna.
Don't make me do it.
Oh.
It's time to...
Let's make it.
I get it.
Nowhere yet.
Going to overtime.
Oh.
Holy shit.
It's...
Bring out the item.
The fuck.
Oh,
you are talking in lowercase.
I can't understand you.
I can't understand you, man.
Can't be serious.
Just speak up with your voice.
That's so fun.
No, I still can't hear you.
you sound like those shitty like all like audio audio porn
like things you know what i'm talking about if you're
talking in lowercase you're such a you're such a good sage
brother brother brother that's a new one that's crazy bro's
talking in lowercase two one
Oh my god, my third time to go my 33% win rate Luna.
I make that 30%.
I was ready for 30% Luna.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so scared.
You're never supposed to leave the other support alone.
Are
we serious?
We didn't.
Oh my god.
Why didn't we push up?
Yeah, I'm not fucking... I'm not going up I'm not alting
that if you win is 34% true true what if I keep forcing Luna
it should eventually go up that's how that oh I got hit
that's how that's how probability works guys oh my god oh my
god really what the fuck i'm not ulting that
it will go up once yeah you're right you're right you're
right if i keep playing it'll eventually go up right
I think people okay the thing is everyone uses trackers now
so they could see they could see the 30% win rate too that's
the worst part like I don't think they would let me I legit
think they won't even let me touch Luna if it goes any lower
if it I'm pretty sure
if it goes any lower and they'll be like cheat cheese she's
throwing and i'm like i swear the guy i'm not intentional
it's not intentional i swear to god i've just been very
unlucky with my games on luna i swear
and i don't know i've just been very unlucky with her i'm
like okay like literally it's just
oh my god
oh my god oh
my god what the fuck is going on
it's just a cycle you know like i keep getting i keep losing
on her and then like it just keeps going down and then it's
just not pretty it's just it's just not ideal and then it
makes me demotivated to play Luna and you know like I get
demotivated to play her oh
my god no I got chain
well she doesn't have another chain so it should be fine oh
my god oh my god
please tell me there's other people on here okay thank god
all right three four three two one oh my god hello
See, guys.
Guys, this is why I don't play Luna.
This is why.
This is why guys, guys.
This is why I don't play Luna anymore.
It's just the cycle.
The Luna curse continues.
I bet if it was any other game.
If it was any other character, if it was any other
character, I do fine.
If it was any other character.
What hero do you think you want to be today?
It's just not Luna.
It's just, I can't.
I don't know what to do anymore.
I used to be decent at Luna.
Self-fulfilling prophecy.
This is because I don't play Luna, so I get worse at Luna.
And I get worse at Luna when I do play Luna.
It's not good enough yet.
Doesn't work.
God help.
I just threw a bait out there.
Throw bait.
Holy Jeff, man.
Damn.
He's just gonna be like, god, cursed, and alien.
I feel like this guy's underwhelming as fuck.
Like what?
What do you want to do, cat?
I mean, it's a cat who widows do gambit.
You know, something lethal.
I don't know what to do.
Do you think widow is the best hits gauntlet?
Yeah, I think.
I don't know what to do.
Just play more loot.
I don't know what to just play more.
I don't know what to do.
I guess it's just, you know, impossible.
Horse widows fucking OP Let's play more Luna Wow Guys I need
reasonable advice here Guys I need like Actual advice here
You should have been the first fan Be honest Oh bad Luna
it's so true If I bad Luna nobody will play Luna I could
never I can never I heard some Faint cries so I'm going to
do this Wait, we don't even have hood.
Gotta play tank, don't miss.
It's not like you feel like you want to play sport.
Oh, I ain't playing sport.
All right.
That's cloak and dagger time.
Gamma is open, by the way.
Oh, wait, Gamma is open.
Yeah, that's what I was worried about.
I don't play, I don't play Gambit.
That's the thing.
Wait.
simple just play i i don't know what you're talking about
what do you normally play go best i play the shooting
characters do you want dps oh man no i guess like a dps no i
feel like i heard your name on an announcement before on an
announcement before i'm relevant i heard you on the news I
don't know, I don't know if I'm aware of it.
Did you guys know the rivals guide guy is the guy who makes
League of Legends guides?
Did you know that?
What the fuck?
Mama got that.
Oh.
What do you guys think about Flash tier list?
Let's just ignore that you set that.
My graphic looks serious right now.
What the fuck did I do?
What happened?
Carly, Gamma's just a healer bot now.
I got the team up.
I got the bucket team up.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I can heal more than that, guys.
Holy shit.
That arrow could be, bro.
Oh my.
Oh, I fucking put that in the wrong area.
Banjo back.
Banjo.
Holy shit.
Oh, I hate this map.
This map is like a little laggy sometimes.
Are they over here?
What the fuck happened?
Alright, it's fine.
What?
What's going on?
Please don't.
Don't peek at me.
What's going on?
all right it's fine guys I don't think we're turning guys I
don't think we're turning around guys I don't think we're
turning around I don't think we're
not i like that it was like guys guys everyone turn around
we all just just went forward
guys i like the part where we all definitely turned around
oh wait what the fuck it's five
i think that was my favorite part you know we all started
turning around
play close engine 3, 2 they're running at him it's so iconic
I know when they turn around
go go go go oh we're close my god it's me and the raccoon
don't turn Wait, don't do Oh, he's a Katie player.
He's a Katie player That man's a Katie's I'm not giving us
five more extra percentages fuck that bro
Guys guys guys guys guys he's so Person I forgot Guys turn
around
Guys, look at this mag, guys.
Guys, yes, yes.
Oh my god, where's my rocket?
Oh my god, there it is.
There it actually is.
It's a little exposed.
Oh my god.
guys remember when we all turn around again the guys you
guys remember we all turn around for the mag guys you guys
remember that give game a little
i'm not so far i've got res we can right here Broke
touching.
Broke touching is hard.
I have to use that.
Oh, I had a feeling that was going to happen.
Oh, I got this.
Oh, no.
I think we need to start turning around for GAMP, for MAG,
guys.
I think maybe.
We need Portland, or?
We need Portland.
We don't have a Portland.
up oh
no we need to start turning around not we only lost that
because i forgot i don't play this game anymore and my third
person ass game where i shoot i like put my crosshair on
them and then it hits the left wall we need to get 45 give
the subs thank you yeah i love third person i appreciate
meep as if maybe we turn around maybe guys guys guys is a
wild concept maybe we turn around i know it's pretty crazy
but me turning around would be all right raccoon is begging
for his life right now all right that's an insane concept no
way but guys imagine if we turn around
that's so crazy it just might work
I know it is a pretty crazy concept
oh fuck there's a fucking yo there's a fucking uh behind us
behind us yes lord yes lord oh my god oh my god is he
turning around again is he is he turned oh
my god why can't we turn around why did we turn around why
do we never turn around he's flanking us with sword but he
killed the whole team they use
That's crazy.
Does that bubble heal or no?
Can't be.
Oh my god.
You got it.
I got it.
Oh.
That's a one person.
I'm back.
Oh my god.
I just got C.
I just got C2.
If only we would turn him around!
That's fucking behind me.
Oh my god, I wonder who's behind us.
I wonder who's behind us.
I wonder who's behind us, guys.
I'm so unlucky.
I died for that.
for that too I died for that for us it's fine I got us at
one extra second that's all that matters guys maybe oh the
gambit all here all right I didn't get that wait what now
you do the same for me we Holy shit.
I swear to God if this happens, I swear to God.
Oh my god, I'm not turning around.
I'm not, if no one's turning around, I'm not turning around.
That's my motto.
If no one's turning around, I'm not turning around.
Oh my god, I couldn't hit anybody.
I'm not.
Oh, I'm doing...
How does he have it?
It's fine.
Do you play anything other than Fantastic?
I feel like we need something else to do, Tess.
I'm not gonna lie, the things I'm seeing him do, he's doing
completely fine.
All right.
Oh my god.
Oh, please don't let him take everything.
Please don't let him take everything.
Please!
What do I do?
Heal her this.
Should I?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
OK.
Oh, my God, he's.
Oh, my.
How does he still have it?
Oh.
I don't Yeah, we gotta either Band Elsa or play it Can't
play Fantastic Band I don't He just kept having Gavin never
buzzed Wow I don't know
Well at least they're happy The other fucking whore And mad
Oh whore i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not salty whatsoever
guys i'm not whoa whoa i'm not salty or anything
toky calm down No, of course not Guys, do you guys miss me
enough for a nine-hour stream?
It can always go up.
That's the best part about streaming And to no one's
surprise Gail wins first
To no one's surprise and I have damage from this match.
I might have an out of player.
Is it Friday?
I've lost track of the days.
Not gonna lie.
I've actually lost track of the days.
Hey, Gimbetsu while we're at it.
I'm getting Apex practice.
Yeah, I ain't going to get any Kings practice.
Okay, Apex is more like aim wise, I feel like.
I play Apex so much that like, it's just muscle memory.
I have Apex tomorrow.
Let me message Mac real quick.
Hey, are you free right now?
No, you didn't.
Rivals tournament tomorrow.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Even so, I gotta, I can only practice solo.
Now, I'm pretty sure it is.
I'm pretty sure.
sure it is.
Is it Mumble Man?
Is he back?
Oh yeah, Starlord.
I'm solo.
I'm just enjoying life.
I think it can be a better rivalous player if I play as
gamer frequently and actually get coaching.
Everything I learn is just through regurgitation like
through watching other people play but I think if I got
actual coaching I won't be surprised if I like I can
actually improve as a player that's about that's for any
game though you know yeah
tap nope nope nope don't have time for that though Oh,
he's coming in.
Okay.
I don't even, I don't know how that happened.
Not going to lie.
Nice.
Look at one.
Look at the lamps.
Oh, shit.
There's a world.
Bro, I can't.
That was three.
That was three leaves, guys.
No, no, no.
I don't know what I can give more of
Yeah, we're in the passive.
Nice.
Are you serious?
Lucky one lucky one no mag bubble.
Oh my god.
That's just meant just in the back lane.
Can we get some of this girl?
Oh my god, free stack of cooldown
Holy shit, that's Thanos.
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Thanos is to coming.
Yeah, coach on stream.
Maybe.
I'm mad.
All right, guys.
Do you see where I'm at?
I would love to maybe do like coaching streams on Twitch or
some shit.
I do.
I just, oh, I do want to like...
Oh my god.
Oh crap.
Stop.
Please not again.
I saw it.
We all saw it.
What's your name?
What's your name buddy?
You heard me laugh.
That's karma, that's actually karma for me, that's karma,
that's, no, I deserve that.
I deserve that after laughing at him.
To be fair, it was funny, though.
Okay, I deserve, it was funny, though.
Come on.
Alright, daredevil is getting fucked up.
right now.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh, what?
I get counterslip.
It's fine.
I mean, it's fine.
Hey, guys.
Thank you.
Oh,
sure.
like what is going on please i can't i cannot heal that i
the chip i'm going the combo with we just have fucking star
lord if you go bucky we just win this game hard
uh whatever
all right i think maybe i think maybe gomez just start
playing dps maybe I can I can hit four man grabs every
single time, but oh my gosh because I laughed at him Yeah,
you can play Starzord.
Aren't you the Starzord player and the super Gomez?
Warming the grabs.
Oh No, I just don't stand next to me.
Oh, look at me.
Look at me.
That's not about them
All right, we're just down to right now
He's on a good rest there.
I'm not lifting that.
I need him to start playing DPS.
Okay.
One minute can die, one more time, no passive.
Alright.
Oh, this guy definitely has ult though.
That Wolverine's looking for it.
Alright, here we go.
Do we have Wolverine here?
Bomb twist.
He has a better ult.
We are undefeatable.
Halting after this, okay?
Goodbye, I knew it.
I knew it was gonna happen.
I knew it was gonna happen to me.
That's it.
Are we gonna put it?
I don't know.
This is reset.
It looks like we're outstuck here.
I was scared over the fucking wolf arena.
I don't know why we're doing that.
We're outstuck here.
Equal brains are doing anything.
Honestly.
He's right there.
Get him.
Oh my god.
And he's blinded, guys.
What more?
Look at Bucky.
Look at
Bucky.
Blind!
Let's get this fucking claw in the back of my bro.
Please.
There's also that, uh, healer.
We are undefeatable.
What?
Oh my god, I'm not fucking being there.
I'm not fucking staying there.
That's right.
We go, we get off of the two bad characters in the comp and
we start winning.
What?
Oh, and then we feed and then we start losing.
Oh my god.
He was on point.
He's literally on a card.
oh my god oh my god oh my god thank god how is oh i don't
want to be there
i'm a tp out tp out all right no we don't need it no don't
just say we don't need it and fucking pussy out okay he's
hanging on mantis right now in the back
Please, please, please, please, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I just got that.
He's six.
All I've been doing was healing.
What more can I heal?
I just joined me.
I healed so much.
One, two, zero.
You can update me, bro.
He'll hide.
This is me awful.
Why were we fucking...
We are hope and fear.
How much more can I use?
Uh...
I feel like I have to play Raccoon here just because we have
Penny now.
You'll see what I mean.
Oh my god, we're going to make Black Panther work.
Or are you going to make Black Panther work this time?
I think it's also because, like, our...
I was competing, like, healing with...
I was competing heals with our raccoon, so I couldn't build
it into...
Cat.
Oh, where's he gonna put it?
Where's he gonna put it?
Where's the nest?
Guys, I don't think we're getting C1 back today.
Once in the sleep.
Alright.
I don't think he's making Black Panther work, guys.
I don't think he's making Black Panther work.
worried it's not making it's not making it work what was i
oh it's the black path there
what was that was that the mantis was that what the what the
What the fuck?
There's a fucking mantis behind us, bro.
Exactly.
What the fuck?
I'll go for.
Why?
That's what I was saying.
Oh my god, you killed him.
I should have expected that.
Fucking flanking mantis, bro.
Yeah, me too.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna run out of punish her here right now.
The back wall rain.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
All right.
That...
Surprising me, that worked.
Whoa.
The back wall rain.
Yeah, there lies.
Not a gaming wall.
Holy shit.
Yeah, he is not like that.
Look at this wall.
What the fuck?
What's going on?
Surely they won't see my res.
That's right over here.
Oh, she saw it.
He saw it.
I should have relocated.
I was a little too confident.
She's dead.
Amanda isn't actually flanking for once.
Look at this guy.
He's so scared.
We are undefeatable!
This is real!
Oh shit.
I'm gonna play up here.
Oh my god, this is this is time.
Oh, that Groot has all he's looking for it He is hundred
percent looking for it guys Oh, no, mawa
He's definitely looking for it Oh, no.
Oh, that group still has a... I'm so scared right now.
I am so very scared.
Trying so hard to heal through this.
You guys have no idea!
Oh, no.
Oh, man.
Oh my God.
What else can I do?
Oh, you're so strange.
What do I do?
Just let them chase me, bro.
Oh my God, the movie's on me.
There are Wolverines somewhere.
I don't think he's making black hat there.
I I don't know.
I don't think he's making it work guys I'm having a feeling
he's not making it work guys
Oh no, it's just my thoughts right now.
He doesn't look like he's making it work I don't know it's
okay wait where's the where is he oh I didn't even realize
we had portal I chucked that in sorry my bad I thought this
was it was I heard this was GG's and I was just like, it is.
If this was the way up the tanks.
Okay, I might have definitely thrown that.
That's worth, that's worth.
Oh, just fucking.
No, I did a merry-go-round.
It's never G...
I guess it's never GG's.
If only I kept my rocket up.
guys i was like ggs let me just check this my bet that my
bet if we lose that's on me that's actually 100 on me that's
actually 100 on me i bro look it's the they said ggs
look when i hear ggs i assume it's probably the baddest ult
of all time if we lose this if we this i'm rachel okay okay
you guys need to go do some coax go get some professor flats
you guys are dog oh my god i didn't get punished i didn't
get punished let's go yay i didn't get punished for what i
never punished oh thank god thank fucking god literally
literally they're like ggs oh it's ggs let me just throw my
alt out since it's over it was the fire of the plant
thank god thank fucking god i got worried there i got
worried i was gonna get it get punished thank god i love i
love not getting punished i almost threw but almost throwing
is not actually throwing also i need to use the bath number
back oh i'm gonna play
that dan boy if you ban magneto i'm gonna get mad i'm gonna
get mad
you stupid bitch what happened what what happened see Whoa!
Oh, they bad mag.
That's why he angie.
Why is he not playing?
Why is our cloak not playing hood?
Hood is so much better.
Oh, Groot.
Oh, I can not play Groot with Cloak, I think.
Oh, I know you have team up, never mind.
Not the hook.
team up actually don't know is cloak even good about the
hood team up I don't even know they will never see this rose
I wonder the BP strat will work here guys surprisingly
surprisingly BP strat has not worked I don't know why I know
it's It's so surprising who would have thought the BP strat
not working
I'll make sure he's okay
He is I'm still trying to make sure he's okay
I hope I don't have to look up Oh my god, oh my god
Oh my god my res who looks at who looks at res there I guess
everybody that res is not very sneaky not gonna That res is
not sneaky at all
I'm just surprised I live I'll patch you up I don't want to
look up but
Oh shit, the guy looked up.
Okay, that's like, what can I do there for him?
I don't think I could do anything.
Oh my god.
There's no way they see my res right here, right?
There's no way.
my very sneaky res, but actually I can make it sneakier.
Okay, okay, there's no way they'll know they'll see my res
right here.
There's no way.
Oh my God, it's okay, it's okay.
There's no, we got the res this time.
Look at that.
Told you, there's no way.
Is she okay?
Oh my God, I thought she was gonna help.
I thought she was gonna ult.
That's my bad.
I legit thought she was gonna ult that.
No, I legit thought she was gonna ult.
I did not, I was like, oh, oh, oh!
I was like, come on, do something.
All right, here we go.
All right.
I don't remember how to play it's fine it's fine all
right I can go back to what was I even playing I don't even
did fuck it huh so this is how Johnny feels all right take
toky's track I don't know why she didn't oh that's all I'm
gonna say I'm not, I'm not going Luna guys.
I'm not going Luna guys.
Oh, I thought that should have been a pull I hear, I hear
footsteps right Right below me Why here?
I hear it What is like get away get away I don't know.
I hope she's living.
That's all I hope for her.
I hope she's alive.
Oh my god, she's alive.
Oh my god, what?
Why are you in there?
Holy shit, why?
Please, oh my god, you're alive.
Oh my god.
she lives despite it all despite it all she lives holy shit
she actually lived that she was like walking in a 20 people
and she lived that I'm older this shit
Oh, I didn't have my shield.
I didn't have my shield.
I went in hoping my shield was there like I was like don't
worry My shield will save me do not I swear to god Yeah,
bro's playing and bro's playing right now In a tunnel I'll
take it
Oh, I didn't think he did.
Will she up?
Will she...
Well, no, maybe...
Let's hope she doesn't up.
I legit thought she was gonna up, but I guess it's fine.
We don't need it.
I killed both supports, so if you guys lose this, you guys
suck.
The eternal question.
Will she up?
I repeat, both supports are dead.
Well, I think their supports are coming.
coming back now.
Why are we still waiting in choke?
He's scared.
Oh.
Sir.
I don't think our team's gonna win anymore.
It's fine.
I'll die with you.
I'm surprised she didn't all during that fight with me and
Bucky what the fuck is she okay is she okay she's not happy
not all cloak and dagger players but oh he's one nice guy
She's requesting too much, man.
Like, we literally...
What the fuck?
I got fucking pulled the shit up right there.
Alright, here we go.
Please let me heal.
Cloak, please.
Cloak, are you fucking stooped?
Cloak.
Oh my god, Cloak.
I just...
All you had to do is...
Are you serious?
Nice.
Oh my god.
Not using it yet.
I'm not using it.
It's just one iron fist.
There you go.
Oh my god, what is going on?
oh what
there's no way there's no way there's no way
oh my god
there's no way i'm fucking begging for my life right now
there's i'm fucking playing for my fucking life oh my god
keeping the dream alive including which side you're at the
time that's just holding down left click oh my god i'm just
like there's no way there's no way where all these games
feel like i play for but it's life or death
maybe you need to play deep remember remember that game
where you were on widow and you got 90 kills
do you remember
who would stop being happy was equaling being able to play
DPS but we're not to be happy.
You're everything rivaled.
Happiness with that.
My rivals will continue till tomorrow.
Oh, you get it.
You get it.
I hope our tanks.
What is she I don't even know I don't even know she's
beaming.
I don't see any strange yet
Who oh go man What
oh shit get him out of here get him out of here no Loki
thought I could go one well he got me out of there he got me
out of there unfortunately bro what is going on what
is he got killed by a rocket now that's embarrassing now
that's
Oh That's unlucky.
I'm pushing for it Just keep me up, please.
Oh My god, please he's he's just punching
Oh my god, it's fine.
It's fine.
He doesn't know they don't see it.
Oh my god
Oh my god, what were how?
Where did I go?
Okay, I didn't see this.
Oh my god, I traveled 80 miles.
I actually traveled 80 miles per hour.
Guys, I'm just as confused as you.
But he didn't even get him.
He didn't even get him.
He didn't even.
I got him.
He didn't get him.
Please,
please.
Oh, my God.
The fact that I knew you too.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, I don't know what's going on.
I don't know what's going on.
I had to, I'm sorry.
I had to.
Please just.
No!
Oh, she's so dead.
I still need it here.
I unleash the Vashanti power.
Oh my god, please just kill somebody.
Please.
Kill them.
Oh my god, I couldn't do it.
I'm sorry, bro.
I swear to God, I was healing you.
Oh my god, how much more can you get punched?
How much more can you get punched?
Alright, alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
oh
my god what's going on what's going on who does he oh my god
hey guys why I mean I'll push the card here that's fine you
think they're okay I don't know oh that's huge.
I'm backing out though.
Dive.
Yeah, C9.
Oh my god, I'll take that.
I'll take that.
C9.
Oh my, these games.
I feel like I'm fighting for my life.
These Celeste should not be in W by C9.
I do feel like I'm fighting like it's a life or death
situation like if I lose it's like GG's it's like you start
losing like you start losing a piece of your finger every
time these people are playing harder than they play than
I've seen in any of the tournament these these rank matches
are more serious than any tournament I played
what's the match history looking like it's like not that bad
honestly it's not that bad
hey you played martha raffles rick with nothing on the line
apparently i just i'm doing it right now
he said last game which hero do you think you want to be
today Game makes me sad if we win, if we win two games in a
row, I get seen one back.
Thoughts?
.
what what argue with me change my mind but that's how losers
think
you're literally in the same rank as me mr pro x pro player
who was on
teams in the world but somehow stuck in my ego
that's messed up i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know what you're talking about how are the games going
great not me I have a 30%...
Where's the percentage win-win on here?
Why the fuck?
Why would I...
Why the duck would I have...
50 Lord.
I can't say fuck, guys.
I have to say...
Duck.
Who needs enemies when you...
Guys, if I say... If I type fuck out...
The entire thing would get censored and what's the point of
us the entire
Look I Did get my message across I had to get my fucking
message across I
Oh Is everything fine up there?
I hear some I hear lots of sounds right now.
Why is there a flanking Magneto Out of any character that
should be flanking?
Magneto should not be one of them
Like what is going oh my god, what is going on right now?
Oh Oh my god.
Well, we're stuck here, I guess.
Alright, I almost have alt though.
We have blade and, uh, we have a blade.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna win it.
Gomez keeps fucking filling the sabotaging room.
my game it's like he doesn't want us to win that fucked up
oh they double support all they double support all i'll take
those you know i'll take a double support all you know i
just get absolutely
free my boy you think i'm gonna call it after he leaves
that's
quitter talk that's on him for playing support oh
my god like what can I do god
why we stream until morale okay he definitely should not we
should not we should not put him on support
that's right I'll find another one to try I have I can find
another one to drag down with me and then I'll play apex
after guys I don't think we're winning this I think they're
fine right oh my I was gonna be over here Like, I'm just
gonna put, I mean, sure.
Like, I'm not hungry, that's the thing.
I really would love to use the cloak shit.
Oh, my.
Oh, my God, they double support all did again!
Oh, my God, I just want him to be alive.
all right i either die here i live i live there we go there
we go oh my god they double support ulted again i just need
him to do that four more times they just need to do it four
more times guys
he got no one how do you get You are a champ, Elsa.
That, not gonna lie, that's impressive.
That's impressive.
Oh my god, this Elsa also got no one.
That's crazy.
I just think it's very impressive.
Okay, I must manage to fucking stall it for one second.
So I hope they win that.
I need Gomez to farm his ult right now.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh, I just made it.
I just made it.
Oh my god, what damage?
That damage!
Groot's always with me.
You'll see what I mean.
Okay, that's fine.
Just a little.
Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
It's no longer fight.
Slightly.
Thank you for the Twitch prompt.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Guys.
I told you guys.
The win count was they needed to fucking do that.
They need a double support out five more times.
I don't understand why that didn't, why they didn't do that,
guys.
I don't understand.
Good night, DPS, pretty please.
I'm getting very bored.
I will pick a Luna for now.
I'm not the type of faith.
I don't even know.
I don't.
Oh my god, we're at not guys guys Do you miss me enough to
watch me for ten watch rivals for ten?
10 out hell yeah how I guess
yes don't worry there's still apex after I'll do that
off-street
oh my oh my god
All right, here we go.
When do I get to go into hell myself?
Oh my god, just feeling the bubble.
Oh, there's the flanking bag again.
There he is.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I can't heal more than that Legit I all I did was left click
guys I did nothing but left click you can't blame this on me
Just heal harder
He's got a soft feeling that's all I'm gonna say he really's
got a stop feeling.
Hey guys, I have uh, they might have mag up, but I have ult
though.
Maybe they'll have bubble, you know?
If I'm lucky, they'll have bubble for me, right?
Got it.
You know what?
Let's do it.
Oh, he doesn't have a...
Oh my god, he doesn't have ult?
He...
What's going?
What is...
Oh my...
Please help me.
Please.
There we go.
How is that possible?
He doesn't have all...
That's right.
I'm going to stay over here.
Oh my god.
When did we get a black...
Oh, there he goes.
Oh my god.
I need time.
Please fight in this orb.
BP's got...
This is it.
This is the moment where BP's gonna work.
Oh my god.
He's still there.
guys there's no way this guy is still there there's no all
right
it's finally it's time please room so close up because i'm
just almost there please there's no way he has mag up
oh my god get me out of here get me Actually, get me out of
here, though.
Get me out of here.
I don't want to be there.
Guys, there's this mag that's just sad.
Guys, I don't understand.
I don't know if mags are just somehow invisible to the naked
eye.
He's just...
I don't know.
It feels like every mag is just invisible to the naked eye
for some reason.
the old buff or some shit like you just can't the older that
you are the more invisible you get I think that's it I think
I like to call it the old buff oh I hope they're they're not
alive I'm like hope they live you can only see them if he's
been motioned
But yeah, our mag gets seen.
But yet somehow people can see our mag.
Oh, shit.
What the?
Don't talk it.
I'm sorry.
Oh, my God.
Please tell me we at least kill him.
Please tell me.
Okay, we kill that guy at least
all right
Well, we used a lot of ults there
We we might have oh We might have used a lot of ults there
To be fair to be fair oh my god he how do you not see him
okay yeah oh no oh
my god I there was so many heels going in that's all I'll
say it was it was a lot of heels
I tried, I tried, I tried, I tried, I really did.
Please save him, please save him.
Oh
my god, you're alive.
No!
I couldn't get the queue going.
I wanted the queue so badly.
Oh my god, please live, please live No I just got it Why did
we no one turn around for the mag?
I swear to God That mag was literally just I every enemy mag
that just flanked in the back line
Did nobody knows how to turn around I don't understand why
does no one know how to turn around I don't understand I
didn't realize it was such a unique concept that people need
to learn I still feel bad for that one guy that was like hey
turn turn around turn around there's a mag turn around turn
around and then instead of turning around everyone just
walked forward like i felt like i was in a fucking
simulation there i really did
what if that hits that did not hit guys It would have been
cool if it did.
Oh my god, I do not want to...
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm...
He lost, he lost, GG.
How do I...
I'm fucking...
I'm not playing Mantis with...
Yeah, I'm not playing Mantis with that.
I...
Yeah, like, I'm not playing that.
If we're getting dive, I need something to help me.
I hope you live.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying.
Don't get me in me too.
I'm sorry, but do not get near me do not play near me.
That's all I do not play next to me
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, thanks Invis.
Thanks for all thing when we're all fucking dead
That could have been me.
That could have.
That is me.
Keep these coming.
Down point, down point.
Come on, Rocket.
I know we almost got it.
Come on.
No, Rocket, don't die, please.
I'm trying.
No!
I tried.
I did.
tried they all ran at me oh
my god i'm just a little guy
just a little guy trying to make it in this big scary world
oh i hear him too that's the worst part
oh i got in time i clearly i knew you know what i totally
knew she was gonna do that i i definitely knew she was gonna
fucking yeah i definitely knew that was gonna happen
I definitely knew she was good.
Alright.
Perfectly predicted, guys.
For sure.
Alright, nice.
I can hear the spider-man next to me.
I'm gonna try and let her.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I can't see it because I have the, oh, the stupid
OLED protection.
I can't see my, oh, I don't know where my old is.
Guys, tell me what I have, tell me what I have all.
I can't see my old, I have an OLED protection screen right
now.
It's fine, it's fine.
That's fine.
Oh, I can press tab.
I could press tab.
I could press tab
I'll just okay.
It's gone.
It's got
Like why are we copying here?
We're up five people As if you're perfect Oh my god Yo Okay,
I think Okay, what did I do?
I do!
Okay, all right, you can't you can't lump me into this.
You can't lump me into this.
I didn't do nothing
Why am I lumped into this category?
Oh my god
There was nowhere else to, I will say, there was nowhere
else to put that.
Oh, he has all of this soul.
Oh, my.
Oh, my God.
I will say it.
Like, how am I?
Why am I lumped up into here?
I mean, I feel like I can play Mantis now.
we're on triple.
Yeah.
All right.
Just keep going forward, guys.
Oh, no.
There is the classic not go forward when getting dope.
Oh, wait.
He got him.
That's fine.
Okay.
Oh my god, that wad looked so sleepy guys, you don't
understand.
That wad.
Oh no.
That.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm at 81.
I'm 81.74.
Oh my god, please, please don't.
Don't.
Oh my god.
Please someone touch point.
this is mo this is your moment copy me copy me
oh my god oh my god
just copy now is the time time to switch things i clutch
nice
was very very eepy you don't understand he was a very eepy
wall he
was very very eepy I feel like I'm holding someone hostage
right now I feel like I'm holding someone hostage like
Gomez or us I'm not sure yet.
You holding the moderate.
As in tomorrow.
But guys, this is to make up for the fact that I was gone
for seven plus days.
Guys, is that not what you wanted?
I thought you wanted more dokyum.
Guys, it's just not what you wanted.
I don't understand.
exactly what you guys wanted oh that's not what i want to do
oops oh
my okay
me going there was actually a really good idea all right
all right you better kill him okay all right you got as much
pocket as you needed you that's enough pocket for you
as much pocket as you deserve at that point.
Oh, shed him.
Oh, I didn't see him.
Oh my god.
Please heal him, please.
Oh, please.
I've done so much to heal him.
Just heal him.
oh my god dono save him are you
serious oh my god i don't
oh my god what's going on i'm getting off of mantis fuck
this what what is i mean oh oh
Oh, but I can't say shit when...
Oh, when he fucking whiffs, I can't say anything.
I know you guys are celestial and I'm trying to like win
this game now.
I'm doing too much.
You guys need to do something.
Why do we let him play Storm?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Like you, you two, you other DPS are terrible.
What?
What did I do?
No, just go be a bitch and play tank or support.
Like if you don't have fucking hands, then why are you
playing the fucking character?
Oh, oh my god!
Guys, I might have broken this man.
I've broken him.
No, my god.
This is your fault, Toki.
This is my fault.
What am I laughing, though?
Is it truly my fault if I'm laughing?
Oh my god, please.
All right guys, we got a TP coming with Rocket.
Wait, do we need TP?
Do we need TP?
DP.
GG, guys.
Both my other DPSs, I want to play their main characters,
can't play their main characters.
Go fucking support and thank for the rest of your lives.
Wow.
You can't expect to win them all.
I'm good vibes.
Good, good, good vibes.
It's good vibes, guys.
I don't know why This guy swapped off support.
It was working.
Good vibes, everybody.
Good vibes.
Immaculate vibes.
Do you think he's so cute and nothing?
You want to know something, Doki?
You want to know?
I was literally tracking their spider-man going a mock speed
in every single fight.
I'm going for a backline kills.
I'm going for a dps kills.
Oh no, my guy wants to play storm because it's secretly
meta.
Oh, it's so smart.
It's so smart.
Like these celestial fucking dickheads don't know how to
fucking play their characters.
He's wrecking, raging on pub, raging in public now.
This game is terrible.
All these players are fucking terrible.
All of them.
No fight.
Whoa.
Especially like this Yuki person who or that is at all.
Yeah, I don't know why you would say that.
That was kind of weird.
Toki freed this.
He can leave whenever he wants.
Yeah.
You'll be a top-notch team to win this one.
I have not played this game in five seasons.
What is your excuse other than that?
I go to another game and I make LAN.
You know what you do?
You're jerking off playing fucking support at 11 p.m.
We might have to cut him loose.
Snowflake like Luna Snow.
Oh my god.
Wait, am I missing something?
What's the conversation, bro?
Yeah, what is the conversation?
We might have to cut this mad loose.
I'm free up from his chains.
Do you guys like this new season?
Do you think the hood is good?
I'm free of breath taking it to the five.
There's a fucking guy right here.
I mean, chair.
This guy is low as hell.
You'll push behind Timmy, Timmy.
He's gonna block.
I can lamp us up in five.
Into their back line.
just going all right let's go you know my body and soul oh
my god they're gonna tp here yeah nice what it was that
portal what what happened cancelled i can't follow you guys
what the fuck was that I guess I'll push the cart.
Fuck me, I'll guess.
It's dokey bird.
It's like the V-tuber.
That's, oh shit, the V-tuber?
You're very powerful.
Wait, maybe?
Here, copy me if you need to.
I'm letting him copy me.
Hey, Matt.
This is it.
Alright, this is it.
Wait a minute, it's your drive.
Oh,
that was close.
You can have things on here for us.
That was close.
That was pretty close.
Oh shit, wait, they had another one?
I didn't even notice they had a lot oh my god I'm a lot
just the top left
bro I don't know how much heals you need but but we've been
flower powering up that's for sure
Oh my god, that poor Mantis.
You think he's okay?
He's all right.
All right.
Oh, I need to remember to use my C, guys.
My bad.
Might have low key been sort of throwing that a little.
Look at this line here.
Just go block.
Don't worry, I know I have C again.
I always forget the C.
It's just me on whenever I have to play Gambit.
I don't know.
Oh my God.
That's my bad.
The one time, that was my bad.
I thought it was me first.
I got, that was my bad.
Yeah, these are my, almost, we're playing triple.
I'm not alting first anymore.
I didn't realize she had it.
Our tank for some reason.
I didn't realize we had all up there.
He's mad now.
I'm not popping.
Just come back.
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Oh, what?
They're gonna have.
That's how it's really, aren't it?
I'm like waiting for the cleanse.
Oh, our tank is mad now.
Our X tank.
What?
Oh my god.
have freedom.
I should have freedom.
That's my bad.
I'm sorry.
I just want to play.
I just want to play more rivals.
Is that too much to ask for?
Apparently it is.
I'm just dead so our gamble would be heavy.
No possible way you can stack.
I'm back in one, I think, early.
I'm hoping you can do that.
You can just go draw up and go.
Alright.
Oh my god.
He's just punching me.
He's just punching me!
Guys.
I think I might have.
Bro, too mad.
Oh my god, I hope he got me.
I hope he got me.
I've got spawn camp.
Oh my god.
What can I do?
They don't have a DPS.
I've just been spawned.
Yeah.
Oh shit, my seat.
That's on me.
I fucking... God damn it.
I keep forgetting my seat, guys.
That's on me.
There, I got it.
I used it.
Sorry.
That's on me.
That's actually on me.
I couldn't.
That's...
Guys, I will admit, this is my 10th hour on Rival.
Oh, come on.
I just wanted to play.
I wanted to play not Gambit.
But for some reason, we didn't ban Gambit.
I was ready to play Ultron Why are you putting me on gap?
There we go.
Are we really playing low?
Oh my god, I really don't want fucking.
I hate this.
this is an unconsensual gambit play right here
kanga thank you for the five gift themselves thank you thank
you i did not consent to this i i literally picked
everything but like if you don't want gambit if you don't
ban gambit i swear you should be the one to play gambit like
i that's all i'm saying if you're not going to play gap if
you are not um playing gambit you should be playing yeah
then you should be playing gambit the fact that nobody they
didn't ban gambit and required me to ban play gambit
like how did i get put into the situation where i have to
play a gambit
no whatever i hope we're getting I'm getting patty kicked.
Please, please, please!
Ow, there's no other support looking at me!
Can we just stock against the Iron Fist?
Like, there's no way you should be telling anyone.
Oh, I'm not doing that, Loki, kind of.
I don't know.
There's no way I...
You know he wears mine too.
That looks like.
I have many places.
Oh my god, I'm fucking walking this way.
Fuck this.
Oh my god, thank god.
The whole my I will use that just to keep myself alive.
I would absolutely use that.
Oh my.
Oh my god.
All right, she's alting first.
Me understand.
I think she's alting first.
I think she's alting first, guys.
I think she's alting.
Okay.
Oh my god, what?
How did I explode?
Okay, I don't even know how I exploded there They have a
trink over us We're gonna have to TP Like how did that
happen?
I legit just alted and then I just don't exist anymore I
guess Like fuck me Okay I got this point I don't even know
what I can do differently there
Please live Oh,
we don't make Don't take it, don't take it, we don't make
It's alright You don't make it, bro Okay Okay Like all,
yeah, all six of them turn around just to shoot me.
I ulted and then I didn't exist in one second.
In one fucking second.
It was crazy.
Oh my
god, please.
Okay.
Oh, we don't even have Gambit no more.
Oh, I don't even want to look at this.
Oh, my.
All right.
It's okay.
It's...
They wanted to play Gambit.
That's their point.
punishment
That's their punishment Oh
All right That's my their punishment for playing gambit
Oh, I'm so scared
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no!
Okay, I have to mute now.
I can't, how?
Oh my God.
I'm so sad.
I even fucking, I knew he was gonna do it too.
Like, how did that happen to me twice?
Every time, why is it me?
why not her why can't she get comboed why is it me getting
comboed why couldn't she i got comboed four times why
couldn't anyone else get comboed like no one else got
comboed like me
Like You're not Legit No one Release I think Gomez has to be
released He doesn't care I don't understand Why I didn't see
any other, my teammates didn't get comboed.
I pressed button, I explode.
I threw was no outplay ability.
There's no,
it's okay.
You can stop killing.
I don't understand.
That actually tilted me.
that actually tilted me so hard because it's like i i i
don't know what i guess i should have just been like 80
miles away from my team and it was like i just don't it was
i felt like there was just no ability there he's in far too
deep oh no now he doesn't want to leave but yeah no that
tilted me because i was just like like what do i i what do i
do I literally got fucking convoked so hard.
I guess I should have pre-copied.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
They literally just wanted to like...
Yeah.
I felt like I I like played safer and I still got convoked.
That's okay guys.
It's okay.
You guys?
guys missed me, right?
Did you miss me enough for 11 hours of rivals?
Wait.
You missed me enough for more 11 hours of rivals?
Actually, let me check what time I have to play rivals,
actually.
Where's the thing?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, we're good.
Never mind.
I
could do cook because we have hood.
Oh, shit.
What was my battlefly password?
Fuck.
I don't fucking know.
This?
Round one.
Don't waste it.
I'll figure it out later.
Let's end this quick.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
Oh, I have food.
Don't worry.
Alright.
No worries.
I have food.
It's in the fridge.
The battle starts in five.
Three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Right, here we go.
Oh, my God, was that a fucking office?
There he is.
Oh, and a sidewalk?
Happy birthday to me.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to me!
Oh!
Happy birthday!
To me!
Alright.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna save this for now.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so sorry with what happened to you.
I'm so Please tell me I can reach this at least
Hello, I am scared
Just you and me Oh, I'm keeping you up as long as I could
Did we make a portal we made a portal that's good.
That's good
Oh my god
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I don't know if we live this.
I don't know if we live this
Please you have one right oh my god
We're so dead.
We're so dead where's our iron fist though Maya
Give me out of here.
Give me out of here Give me out of here
Please someone kill that sila Okay, okay, they got me out of
here
Okay Holy shit that guy zoom
I'm sorry, I'm sorry I really am
Oh my god.
It can't be out of here.
It can't be out of here!
Please.
Look at me.
just look at me just look at me just look at me just look at
me okay all right
we're in death scenario please the current score is zero to
zero i i'm surprised when you actually held that yeah I felt
like I don't know how we held that I felt like we should
have lost that at least like five separate times oh my god
that should it should have been lost five separate times
I'm surprised they only ulted once not gonna lie they the
the Scythe like only ulted once that was the thing that
surprises me the most You look at me as if you know The
power champ try guys have tried so hard to free him but
don't worry you're you guys aren't freed not last not fifth
place baby yeah there it was eight teams eight teams with
plays right get
in here get in here oh get in here get
in here get in this little or oh my god oh my i need you to
stop taking damage guys i'm i'm fucking leaving i'm sorry
you're gonna die here
oh my god i have not stopped healing oh mag please you're
gonna give me a little heart attack don't worry it's coming
the heels are coming do not worry the heels have not stopped
coming all right here we go right into the depths there we
go and that's That's how you do it.
The heals never stopped coming.
Oh,
are they poorly near or not?
Totally.
My god.
Oh my god.
Okay, he almost lost that 1v1.
He almost lost that.
He almost lost that 1v1.
Avoid Jubilee.
guys oh jubilee 30 win rate that's crazy that's me on luna
that's me on luna bro what the fuck our luna was getting
hard bullied right there
oh guys i broke her i broke the man
I told you Do I still have my log From earlier Do I still
have No Where I was like Yeah Where was it That's what
people Who lose Elo say to cope That
I told you.
Oh, Rake is just a number.
Rake.
Etoke the Elo Terrorist.
Which hero do you think you want to be in there?
The Goblet Mask has taken over.
I guess rank isn't just a number guys I it's never just a
number I told you it's what people say to go when they're
losing that's
what they all say rank is just a number to quitters he
had his chance let's change my title
evil terrorist is back you'll need a top-notch game for the
next one here we go
let's see what is time what is the time of this oh
shit is Oh, yay!
Alright, what are we doing?
Oh, that, you know, you know he's giving up when you stop
filling.
I like snacking.
I never really liked to snack.
I don't know.
I'm just not a snacker.
I just like eating meals.
I'm also not hungry.
I hunger for Elo.
and trust me it's a hell of a lot the only thing i hunger is
you know why should
what the fuck oh my god we're all alive holy shit that got
fucked up
what oh my god She just portaled just like that.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know, but why are we getting so many storm
plays?
Might not.
She don't want to play.
Mansa.
We've got, like, so many storm players.
Alright, come on, guys.
Do something.
Oh my god!
He hooked the only person.
The only person that can't do anything about it.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Oh my god!
If nothing kills them, maybe...
Okay, this might be...
All right, hey, you know what we can do to win this fight?
Let's just use all our ults.
Again!
I don't know, that might be the key to winning.
What if we just use all our ults?
Oh yeah, no, he's fucking dead.
Come on, that's strange.
Oh, nice, nice.
That's me.
Nice to me.
Good job, Doki.
Nice, Doki.
I got myself.
Watch this.
That predicted.
Damn, did you guys watch that?
That was pretty sick.
I don't even know who I hit.
What?
Oh shit.
Fuck it.
Fuck it, let's go.
Let's fight.
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
That's fine.
We're down.
We're even, actually.
They don't have a racket.
Okay, that has just been, like, free-framing us up there.
Is she still up there?
Nah.
I don't think she saw me.
That's stupid.
Oh.
not nice not nice not nice oh i did everything i could i
actually did everything i could to fix what the fuck
okay oh my god you oh my god is he still behind us
oh nice i think he's still behind us he did all that he's
been behind us for 20 years just to die like that that's
crazy i know i hit you i know i hit you
Woo!
Where is she?
She's still there?
Oh.
Go again!
Yay!
That was his master flat.
Okay.
I just need you to live.
It's fine.
We go again!
Ah.
Well, not like...
Well, I can't do...
Well, I hope he's okay.
I don't think he's okay, guys.
I'll just die here.
I...
That's okay.
They use both support ults.
Oh, they're on triple support.
Alright, they still have one more.
Oh, wait.
No, they went DPS pull up.
Never mind.
Okay, they only used one support, then.
There's no way they have another again.
Who's he trying to kill?
Oh my god.
No.
Please, you gotta keep the door.
Third healing.
not our third healer it's okay we have res just come back
oh not again ah yes the solution if storm isn't working oh
please oh please he's just jumping around oh ready to put on
a show we are undefined okay
who did i fucking slap oh my god all right that's fine it's
fine oh no our carries god the only one
oh my god miss not that though
Oh my god, Rocket, you are fucking wild for standing there.
All right, here I go.
Here I go.
Fucking portaling.
It's okay, I did my job.
I walked forward and got my ass beat.
The right heroes could make all...
I don't even know if I should play math.
I'll do math is first fight first first point and then if
it's not great.
Well, we'll swap to the Invis.
I think we need more heals, honestly.
Wait, is cloak bad?
No, wait, I should just.
What am I doing?
We have hood.
Yeah, yeah, we move really really once the new team.
It's really good apparently from what the pros were saying
They put me on cloak during the tournament because of how
good it was
Maddie's always been good.
Well not really there was a point there was she was good
only for a triple support But she works in double support
now The battle starts in five four three two one uh she's
good in a way where but only if your team is coordinated and
enough for it but um her her uh this is really good see i'm
sorry guys help me help me help me help me help me help me
help me someone with gun help me someone with a gun
that's someone with a gun to do something
oh my god oh
Oh!
Just come, just come here, come here, come here.
We leave, we leave.
Our Luna got absolutely fucked up there.
Oh my god, no Luna, stop.
Okay.
This is not good for me.
This is not good for me!
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy Oh my uh, and my fucking Luna stop
frontlining
I'm dead.
No
No That's so unlucky for me.
That's so unlucky for me No, I was this close.
Guys, I was this close to the door.
I was almost there.
I was, I tasted, I saw the door.
I saw the door.
Oh my god.
I saw the door guys.
Oh yeah, we're so fucking dead.
Unless...
Oh my...
Oh my god.
It's just us, Luna.
It literally is just us.
Oh, I'm so scared of...
I need a swap off cloak because they have...
I mean, maybe.
Maybe unless...
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, look at him go.
I didn't fucking go okay you gotta get fucking scared of the
shit up do you use it he used it he used it this is it this
is it oh my god this is not it this is I'm swapping I'm
swapping I'm swapping I was not, to be fair, I was not
expecting the grab.
I should, that was, I was like, this is it.
They used Maggle.
Get older.
I should have, I should have just fucking, I really should
have just fucking went, played it safe.
Behold the god of thunds.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, okay, okay, this is it.
Sonic crap.
It's like a series of unfortunate events right there.
Okay.
Maybe I should have played Iron Man from...
Not Iron Man.
In this from the beginning.
guys it
definitely has a hold too
oh okay
we are this
is it oh this is it this is it oh my god this is it
i gotta see see she should have swapped off look That's all
I'm seeing.
Maybe she should have swapped off Cloak.
I see, look at that, guys.
I was willing to swap.
I thought he was going to miss.
Not going to lie.
That looked like it was not going to hit.
Should have swapped off Cloak.
Got grabbed.
That's like it's over.
I'm not doing that again.
I'm not fucking going through that again.
maybe if she swapped off gloop she could have lived she got
oh he got back c2 you you aren't freed now but you're not
chat you're not free he's freed
you're not freed how many to see one how many actually told
this is not um we're 48 48 out of a hundred we're exactly
where we want to be I don't know how to calculate calculate
it let's see I started playing at four
road to c1 oh yeah you need 40 yeah 40 more minutes till you
get your dd skin right
all right i'm gonna get water i'll be right back guys
wait super go miss
which hero do you think you want to be today who
am i gonna banish from this match
hey guys you guys can only hear me right now I am so
unbelievably tilted it is a crime
but the thing is that I'm aiming good so I'm not stopping
anyway ciao
I made it what did he say good things you'll need a top
notch team to win this one
What do you say?
Is he trauma dumping?
See, this is why we have chat.
It's like free therapy.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
How is that throwing?
How did I throw?
I played my role.
Sometimes.
Okay, I might have thrown some games.
Accidentally, though.
Accidentally.
But it was like not on purpose.
I'm not, I don't know.
This map's weird.
Petting the cat.
get petted wait they left wait somebody left oh they're back
oh my god why is it always him oh
my god I'm like this oh my god I'm lagging a little bit here
I hate when that happens all
right it's fine oh it's a mirror match right now Oh my god,
please.
No!
I tried, bro.
You just need to stand the same way as me.
What?
What do you mean?
I got booped up!
I got fucking booped backwards!
I sw- I sw- Oh!
Oh!
That shit tilts me so much.
You know?
That tilts me so much, you know, because it's like I clearly
it's like if he what didn't fade I would have got that, you
know type deal
There we go Yeah, that's right.
Oh, it's okay.
He doesn't die here that guy has oh, though I could tell
Yeah, oh Can I just be here?
Alright.
I hope people are doing stuff.
Oh shit!
Get me out of here.
Oh my god, it's me.
It's me.
Alright.
I don't know how rival players play this game every day for
oh my god how where am I okay it's fine
play this game every day oh that would have been sick if you
got also that they're spy man as all though I'm a little
scared is it to me no
all right well we have to die here
We...
Moxie's brother, Moxie.
I don't know how people play this.
Like, I just get, like, my fix.
You know how you get your fix, and then you're good to go?
That's me.
I get my 10-hour fix per month, and then I'm good to go.
Okay, you know what?
That's fine.
That's, like, 20 ults.
I'm fine with that.
It's like a button like every they're also down to support
all so we should just walk
Yeah, we need to start pushing up took down the healer and
we just use math Yeah, we can Let's go Let's fucking go.
Okay.
I'm think thing thing thing thing thing thing Jubilee
jubilee jubilee.
Yeah Boop all right what the fuck there we go yeah yeah just
play until i hit my quota of the year of the month and then
i'll see you next month i'm gonna freeze him
as per
tradition yeah i get my marvel rivals quota and my twitch
quota both at the same time get that double whammy
all right that's cool oh my god wait that was a crazy hook
that's actually a crazy hook right there where
I got you guys oh shit where is he gonna what it's okay it's
okay you know double I made a double it's it's all right you
know he gets one I have all two he gets one I get I have 20
and he gets one it's fine push push push so close that works
goodbye oh shit she lives nice I don't know who I slept but
let's do it it's okay I'm pushing the card guys oh my god
1v1 him oh he's does pussy I'm pushing cards still I think
he's winning that 1v1 is he still fighting him oh my okay he
won I was gonna say that'll be very embarrassing if you lost
that okay
it's fine it's right we're so healthy we're so healthy oh
that's lucky that's so unlucky oh
he's won each beat oh it's okay it's okay we get two we get
two we get it's okay Gomez gets two gets the fuck up twice
we did not see him up nothing just now guys guys we
Definitely did not see a whole nothing there
Guys guys remember he gets two gets the fuck up twice.
Oh my god.
What is this?
He ulted for the aura
I mean I can pour it on this So was it oh never mind it's
not where it's pouring Can we make it?
I think we can make it.
We can make it.
We can hundred.
You're sweaty.
Go touch.
We touch.
To be fair, I went to try and...
Oh my.
Did she have her alt again?
What the fuck?
I made that one twice.
It's like...
I think it was more...
But that juke, it has her alt.
Three other five.
No!
Okay, now I...
portal okay now our portal yes where
the fuck is this place what what
what happened what pressed it no I didn't I pressed left
click I actually pressed left click I did not cancel I I did
not cancel it I what
happened it actually cancelled by itself that happens if the
place if the game decides I'm in a bad area it cancels?
That happens?
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Erectile portal dysfunction like I didn't realize that was a
real thing all the fuck are you mbp I'm literally 39 and
zero 37 did that uh new character buff yeah you're
definitely you're definitely doing a lot I didn't realize
that yeah I realized that was something that can happen it
was just like the maps like no no no I'm gonna cancel that
now that's a bad area did
not realize that fuck that existed nice oh but I was sick of
we killed there there that was like legit just go miss do
you still get early access to the new season and ship oh
that's unlucky yeah strange just had performance issues
there that's crazy sorry i'm still i'm looking i'm locking
i'm locking in i i just i i i don't know i was that like
surprised me so much that i stopped locking in that's my bad
The plot, bro.
All this Spider-Man can do is just peel for them.
What the fuck is going on?
Okay.
There you go.
You got your MVP.
Only took being 46-0, though.
That's fucking ridiculous.
What's going on?
What is going?
Oh, my God.
What is going on?
What is...
Oh.
Let's go.
Come on.
Where's my next stand down?
There's my again.
Oh, whoops.
It's all right.
Whoop.
Oh, they have Phoenix up.
All right, here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm about to have Luna all just kite, just kite, just
kite.
I think is he kiting it?
Do you think he's okay?
Okay, he got it.
He got it.
Can we kill Jubilee in the back?
Oh shit.
That's karma.
That's that's karma.
That might be that might have been karma.
Okay, so they use the hood, both support odds, Phoenix.
Yeah, I'm gonna have my that's on me.
Oh, he's looking for it.
I think he's looking for it.
Yo, Ducky dropped.
Well, I got him.
Oh my god.
Oh, I could not do anything else.
I dropped!
Wait, we won that foot.
Too much, man.
Yeah, I'll give her speed boost let her zoom in she's zoom
in she's so fast Oh fuck stupid ass cloak.
Yeah, dokey hop All right One shot
All right, it's fine.
It's fine We're so healthy We're so healthy
We've always been so healthy okay whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hey guys hey guys hey guys whoa whoa
we're so healthy you deserve it Gomez I'm sorry yeah you
definitely did a lot that game you definitely did a lot
almost seen I almost ran away Just to be like, do I care
about my life more than this point?
I knew I had to go back.
I had to die for the cause.
I was like, I was like, oh shit.
Oh, I guess I'll die for the cause.
I guess I'll die for my team.
I guess.
How deep are we?
Look at how long this stream's been.
it's so noble
i'm a team player
let me finally a victory we won the last game too why is up
with all these storm players the fact is our storm is this
their home is this ela where they live am i gonna vanish
from this match
it is storm hour I know I was like I I think I bumped into
like seven storm mains which is very surprising you normally
I've normally never is wait does she got a buff or something
is that it does she get a insane buff that I'm not aware of
they're all just the same guy on 20 old accounts I'm
just wondering if she like she got like an insane buff or
something that wasn't where existed
pick your hero or villain i'm not judging all right here
i'll go
maybe you'll show your luna if we lose you're gonna be like
dokeybird 25 win rate luna ggs guys the thing is everyone
uses trackers too now like in this elo Almost everybody uses
trackers so they can see the trackers.
Let you see the win rates, too, of your characters.
And I ain't going to be...
I mean, letting that happen.
I ain't letting that happen, guys.
It's going to be on my terms.
Those weather powers of yours could really come in handy in
the field.
They often do, Natasha.
I'm yeah if I'm learning to happen off stream
all right back at it again
I'm scared to go up not gonna lie
oh my god nice
oh my god okay I dropped down maybe I shouldn't have but I
dropped down
I knew I shouldn't have dropped down only because
oh I don't know if I I feel like I should play white fox
here even though I don't play white fox that much sure you
do all right here we go flower power she okay here she goes
flower power I don't want to play mantis right now okay I
need to make sure I save the leaves for when we get dope
all right oh flower power
oh my god no so close come on come on in this this is your
time
why Luna win rate so bad because every time I'm forced to
play Luna they're on a hard dive That's why I've just been
very unlucky.
I swear to God, if I had to die there, I swear to God.
So it's like, I've been very unlucky because of that.
Like it's literally people play super hard dive and it's
like, it's very very hard to play on Luna.
It's very frustrating to play.
Oh, she's ulting first.
She's ulting first.
Do you guys see that?
She's ulting first Oh, sorry
She doesn't know it's not my fault.
She's ulting first
Is she okay?
Oh my god.
What was that sound?
I'm so scared Made a little click
she's all tick first she's all tick first
hope i live oh my okay um let's hope i all
right oh shit don't shit oh shit
I hope that all actually went to them when I was on the
ground I'm praying to God I didn't just alt nothing there
what the fuck all right
it's fine we're so healthy Oh my god, we're still so
healthy.
Alright.
Goodbye, everyone.
Goodbye.
I can't see my ult, so I hope everybody's okay.
I can't see my ult right now, so I hope everybody's okay.
Alright, it's fine.
Yay!
Oh, you guys can't see it either.
Oh yeah, why do I tell you guys tell me when I, I've, uh,
we did, I forgot you guys also can't see my own.
Yeah.
It worked out, it worked out, guys.
It worked out still.
It's okay, it's okay, it worked out.
Yippee.
about doom and the time stream entanglement chronovium has
driven cracoa insane we have to figure it out on our own
uh armada thank you for the rain thank you thank you we have
a good stream hello everybody i'm on my 11th hour of rivals
i'm having a great time i'm at my 11th hour of marvel
Honestly, what are you doing playing rivals for 11?
I don't know just just for just for fun, you know, just fuck
it Oh my god that that barrier was so sleepy
You know just moments where Uh, I'm just getting my one
month of rival quota up.
You don't see me after a month
She'll be fine She's alting first.
She says she's alting first.
She said she'll al first.
Hey, where's my, where's my first alt?
I was promised the first alt.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
okay there it is there's the first assault
we still have a tank oh we do oh my god oh i'm fucking in
please please i'm right here okay all right here we go here
we go don't you just want to wake up sometimes and be like
i'm gonna play marvel rivals for 11 fucking hours not just
any marvel but freak Marvel Rivals and Celestia.
Oh,
I'm fine with that.
I mean, I can do that too.
Oh my god!
I don't know about that anymore.
I don't know what he wants.
Oh, we've lost the point.
We got so scared.
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
That might have been too many Marvel Rivals hours.
I...
That's my bad.
I don't know why I did that.
I just slept a fucking ghost.
That's definitely too many Marvel Rival hours.
Targeted for extermination.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, she's getting closer.
Oh my god.
That's okay.
We win this, right?
Yeah, we win this.
We still haven't.
It's just me and this widow.
Oh, never mind.
Our Deadpool got caught.
But you.
Okay, I slept a bunch of I was like a ghost I got scared of
a ghost just now
Okay, I need to stop I need not do that actually It's
actually really bad
Oh my god
All right, we gotta go up a little bit more are they
portaling they will portals soon oh he's cut oh my where is
he where No, I couldn't tell where...
Oh, no.
That was my bad.
I needed to know where my Invis was.
I didn't know where she was.
I fucked up there.
It's okay.
Someone's gonna...
Nobody's gonna portal.
No one's gonna portal, guys.
Guys.
Okay, I just made it.
I just made it.
Oh my god.
Okay, I will die for the cause.
I will die for the cause.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, I hope he's died for the cause.
He better die for the cause.
That wasn't that bad.
One step closer.
I better see him die for this.
So easy.
You could tell that he's like in the flow state because he
stopped talking.
He's like he's just in the flow state now.
guys it's like the monkey paw you're like i wish joki would
stream again i miss her this is what you get i came back
from the bahamas i'm like guys 11 hours of rivals not even
at my own house not that's the best part but not even at my
own setup get one day then guys
use this and then you have to play two more games huh it
will be a shame
imagine guys imagine that's what happens oh my god oh my god
a camper
we're trying we're trying our bestie oh my god do you have
another fade for chance oh my I hope you have another fade
okay here we go here we go holy shit here we go they do have
what the fuck oh shit it's fine it pleases me to be helped
be a shame it would be a shame if if we lose this and you
play two more games I said don't say it I said don't say it
that's scary I'm tried I tried to get you I really did I'm
so scared I'm so scared Oh my god.
I'm trying so hard here.
Oh, I don't have any more huts.
Oh my god!
I'm at 69!
Nice.
Just peek me.
oh i just got here guys oh my god oh my god i just got here
i i was so close to oh my god that you just got here i don't
even know if i I could have like lived.
Oh, whoa.
I'm tempted to go a different character just cause like
there's so much damage right now.
Oh my God, guys, please.
Here we go, here, this is it.
This is your moment of shot.
This, oh my God.
We got push up guys.
Nice don't be ashamed.
I press key right now.
I don't know if that's a little too much maybe
Did y'all avoid me?
I'm gonna worry for him
I got backing out.
I'm backing out.
I'm back.
I don't want to be here no more.
I feel like back yeah oh no I take went the wrong way I
don't want to be here no more oh god ah okay I'm okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay God, this boy had to
somehow stop was alive for one second.
That's unlucky.
Not gonna lie.
That's pretty unlucky.
Okay, but they're like right there on our doors.
Oh, please get him out of here.
where's her other tank
what's going on
oh he's over there what is he doing over there wait where is
he now oh
we should be killing this guy come on come on come on I
shouldn't be turning around and killing for you come on
alright that's fine
Oh shit, shit, oh my god, oh my god, I lagged there, that's,
I don't know what happened there, that was crazy, um, what
the fuck, they actually all turned around for me, oh my god,
also Clover, thank you for the raid, thank you, thank you,
oh, we had a good stream, Oh my gosh, like, I don't know
what happened.
My buttons went all over the place.
Well, he has like 78%.
Simple Geometry?
They bursted me.
They literally all turned around for me.
I thought my team was gonna move forward.
I guess not.
Oh my god.
I'm just stuck in the hard place.
I don't want a cloak hold anymore I don't know why can't our
team do that why can't that's all I'm gonna say why can't
they why can't they turn around on their cloak player
it's not fair why is they allowed to turn around on me it's
fucked up that are not contesting this shit
all right don't worry I'm helping don't worry I'm helping
you know what let's go let's fucking go please please please
don't I think that's I'll take that I'll take that oh
my god okay
I would thought the Invis would come like come over but she
she just stayed in the back for some reason I was like if
it's got to heal the rest of the team I think we're done
patty kicking I think I don't have the rivals play this is
still pretty bad I did I thought that what
the fuck happened to her what happened to her I I keep her
heels I keep her heels in everything oh my god she got
fucking deleted
Okay, I don't think it's not fair.
It's not fair that...
Oh my god.
I think it's a little not fair that they didn't kill their
cloak, but their...
Their man killed me.
It's not fair.
That's all I'm saying.
It's not fair that they're able to kill.
cloak they're not able to kill the cloak but they kill me
sometimes life is not fair sometimes is just not fair it
really is I
don't know I thought the mag would come for me.
I don't know.
I miss the thing.
Not fair at all.
Life is just not fair.
Sometimes life is just not fair.
What can I say?
Sometimes life is just not fair I want to play cloak I
didn't even want to play cloak they fucking forced me on to
it I think I why couldn't I play mantis because they told me
to play cloak I I was just like that's not fair they're
running mantis cloak why me I was on mantis I I missed the
door I okay to be fair I was I was honestly autopilot thing
because like if I was just like oh they're not gonna mag up
so I didn't go for the door and then I heard fear but it was
too Wait, I was, I already went through my trajectory.
Like, I already, I, to be fair, I heard, I altered, I was
like, I'm not going through the door.
I don't, they don't have mag out.
They did not say fear.
And then they mag out in the middle of it, and I was too
late for me.
I, I was like, oh, well, guess I'm gonna die.
I'm like, I didn't head to the door.
Okay, I go pee after this game.
I just...
Why?
Every
time...
Pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
Every time I want to play...
I want to play Mantis.
well not every time i should have no all right one more one
more time maybe it'll be different this time guys maybe
maybe it'll be different maybe
maybe this time
now's your chance to prove yourself hood don't waste 30
seconds before you attack get ready
whispering to you from the shadows isn't it what no why well
okay maybe it's just part of being a vampire but wait how do
you what the fuck Yuri the battle starts in five four three
two one all you need to do is capture the mission area got
it all right here we go maybe it'll be different guys maybe
it'll be different maybe they have mag it will not be
different they're all blind maybe
it'll be different maybe
it'll be different guys oh my god this is the fight of the
century this is truly the fight of the century guys oh my
god this is the fight of the century oh they have a penny
they had a penny oh my god wait she does all right here we
go here we go all right i trust what the fuck oh my god she
has all me carry me carry me Is she...
All blind, all blind, six man blind.
Ha ha ha ha, my turn.
They don't have mangled, I can't, I am free.
I'm free.
They don't have mangled.
I'm good to live my life.
You're matching the droolie.
I get to live my life.
You cast more than half of the mission area.
Keep going.
Oh my god.
What is this world?
I get to play Cloak and not get Magelton.
What a wild.
Truly wild experience.
There's somebody on point.
Can I get help?
Sure.
What the fuck?
Maybe it was him being a problem.
Guys don't say that.
Don't jinx this guys.
It's never over.
Guys you.
Oh my god.
It's him.
Wait.
He's still playing too.
It's him.
It's the thing man.
He's still.
Playing!
He's...
It's him!
I'm already appointed!
He's already passed my avoid list!
Now's your chance to prove yourself.
My fucking god, you little baka.
There is another point.
It's him!
It's thing, man!
20 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Oh my god.
He's very... what's the word?
Not flamboyant.
There's a word for it.
A very...
Not slay.
Very...
Not eccentric.
There's a word for it.
It starts with an S.
Zesty.
Yeah, that's a Zesty Jubilee player.
A very Zesty Jubilee player.
Oh man, I'm worried it's all gonna turn around now that they
have Punisher.
Because that's sort of what happened last time.
Oh my god.
Kirby,
Kirby, Kirby.
I'm trying to.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He's doing it!
Why could he do that before?
Oh my god, he's doing it.
He's actually doing it.
Maybe he does deserve to be here.
We're starting to believe he's redeeming himself.
I think I'm still gonna avoid him.
I'm still...
Guys, guys, I'm still gonna avoid him.
Kill him, kill him.
what the fuck is this penny player doing here
all right i swear to god i swear to god i didn't want to oh
oh oh equivalent exchange
actual equivalent exchange right here oh
The wa give-th and the wa-thake-th.
Okay.
I'm so bored.
The G-G.
Oh my god.
You already...
Okay.
Our Jubilee is actually pretty good.
Because you already got another...
Oh, that fast.
Oh my god!
Oh, my gosh.
I think we got a little...
too zesty.
We never got a little too zesty there.
Yeah, it might be a little too forward with our push.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
Have no fear.
Jokey bird is here.
I'm a little, I'm fearing a little bit on the mines because
I don't know where the mines are.
I think that's what I'm worried about the most.
Well, now we know the mines are everywhere.
Okay, nice.
Lining?
Oh my god, they poured.
Oh my god, please do this to, please.
That's not fair.
What is he doing here?
All right, there you go.
There you go.
It's okay.
See, everything's okay.
All right.
Okay.
We're doing it.
All right.
I got you.
I got...
another bathroom break guys wait 84 plus 19 okay all right
why you stop overwatching your name hood i need a hood every
game give me that duo who's our hood damn bro coming in
strong bro yeah bro you're coming in a little desperate yeah
got ease up on that I'm gonna pee real quick.
I'll be right back
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
I'm back back just in time.
Let me play mag on tank.
Oh, you want to solo tank up to you Maybe it's rocket time
Maybe it's my time.
Oh, how do you play?
How do you like decide to play Bucky after you don't get
mag?
How?
Like, we're, okay.
All right, I mean, that's the closest.
What is the closest to a mag?
A guy with a gun.
That's almost like a mag.
It's just like the mag we want.
Bullets are metal, true.
Bullets have...
bullets have metal metal is control can be controlled by
magneto i don't know they have spooderman puck issues
projectiles like magneto
all right no it's not the same zesty jubilee too
i'm gonna put it here it'll be fine Imagine?
No, I should not put it up there.
I'm not up there with you guys.
You only have rocket heels.
I'm pushing cart.
Oh, God.
That's hot now.
Okay, me.
Okay, now I'll put it here.
Who's over there?
Oh, it's our invins.
How did she get over there?
Wait a minute.
I'm grabbing the vehicle though.
Alright, don't worry, I got you guys.
I thought, I should really use the squirrel girl thing more.
Don't worry, you're so healthy.
Oh, I definitely need to get rid of this.
Oh, I hear somebody.
Alright, here we go.
is going on I mean three on cart guys three on cart what
what are we okay it's not mystery hero I didn't accidentally
queue quickly I'm so confused is she okay you're okay are
you okay you're oh are you okay like behind us on cart hood
is still on cart we need to get with the hood Don't worry,
I'm here.
I have gun.
Do not worry.
I have gun Don't worry gun down
Oh shit, what the what the fuck golden Freddy?
Oh, it's him.
Oh shit
I'm trying
I'm on you know fuck it let's go you know what let's go
let's no longer go let's no longer go let's no longer go
let's oh I thought okay not gonna lie I saw four people dead
and then in my head I was like oh shit guys we did it we
killed everybody i didn't realize that he was still alive i
did i thought they were all i was like oh my god everyone we
did it they're all dead oh that is awesome this we can die
here if that is fun well you know i'll take that i legit
came back i i actually walked back because i thought
I walked back because I thought it was over.
We did it.
Let's see their entire team feels like it's just running
right down.
They're coming at us one by one.
I get him out of here.
Okay, nice.
Did he just salt?
Right behind you, right behind you.
He's going to go up there.
Just behind you.
He's coming top left.
Is he here?
I have Oat here still.
Behind this.
How do I tell this?
Don't worry, I got you.
I can't see you.
You're like right in front of the cart.
Please move out.
Thank you.
I was like, what do you mean you can't see him?
He's right there.
All right, guys.
I did.
I did do what you turned back into.
I legitimately thought I was safe.
I can also win the fight.
I think I'm going to three, two, three, two, one.
Yep.
Where is she at?
I'm gonna try to push her out.
Oh my god, and then I get pushed out my bed.
Guys, I think this fight is lost.
Are we gonna die?
Oh shit!
Okay, I deserve that.
I deserve that.
I thought I would live.
I just thought I would live, guys.
I swear.
I was like, yippee!
I'm gonna live.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
It's my bad.
I got a little too cocky there.
I see you in there.
I got
a little too cocky.
I got a little too cocky.
Hey, I'm pushing cart.
I'm pushing cart.
Wait, maybe those...
Yeah!
Yeah.
very good push
Apex switch well Mac is online now he just woke up I won't
be streaming Apex I'm just gonna practice a little bit 12 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 9 10 okay 13 hours till Apex and smooth push if
they if they surrender we'll be free all of us will be free
until tomorrow where I play Apex I'll be playing Apex on
YouTube though YouTube I'll be doing on YouTube not on Not
on On Twitch I got my quote I'm gonna run Benny You're
running Yeah, we just run so long I'm legit watching for
tips Bro, I play Rocket from Fruit of Vibes Might not be the
best person For that, guys
I'm on the 12 Almost 12 hour mark Might not be the time to
watch out of that might not be like the moment to watch me
oh not me being egoed who is he talking to maybe
look he doesn't really talk that much like a lot of wait he
was talking to me i didn't even notice i was talking i used
to be a fan what happened We can hold this off and go for it
or whatever.
What do you mean used to be a fan?
Bro, you know what?
Used to?
It says people just say anything these days.
A lot of things happen.
Apparently so.
I mean, the point where there used to be a fan.
Oh, they're behind us.
They put up behind us.
He's fine.
Oh, my God.
But will I be fine?
Wait.
Alright, I defended myself.
Yeah, it's still used to be.
to be a fan now thank you for the tier one sub thank you
thank you yeah used to be a fan when played more than once a
month true true when i used to stream rivals every other day
back when i still have hope in my eyes
What do you mean?
What?
What do you mean, guys?
Guys, I'm doing it for the drops.
What the fuck is he doing?
Oh, I had res.
Just like that.
We're coming up on... Oh, no.
Sorry, man.
I'm not up there with you guys.
I'm playing low ground.
I pulled back in.
No, you should die here.
Nice.
I have res.
Don't move.
Down point.
Even Venmo app is a Doki fan.
Yeah, see?
He's not used to be a Doki fan.
Not a portal.
I have res.
Why wouldn't I support all total this space?
Because I have a res and you have two extra support.
You mean okay?
Don't worry.
I have my raccoon res.
Yeah, you got res by my raccoon res.
I'm not up there for you guys.
Can we drop down?
bro he has bro what is going what is going guys do we all do
we all or not do we all or not where is he you have friends
yeah yeah yeah where is he oh it's okay oh okay yes got it
okay all right all
right here we go wait mag you're actually better insane oh
sure neko thank you for the red thank you thank you oh i
love you so much i had to be there i'm so sorry oh he's
still she's still that thank you for the red thank you thank
you that we're just we're we're on a 12 hour i cannot i
cannot she cannot she cannot oh she have a res too she died
there that is unfortunate
don't worry guys i haven't there yeah i think they're
trolling because they're like yeah they're just oh my god
wait he lives that not him jk not that guy i swear to god i
swear to god i swear to god i swear to god i'm alive If it
could hit anybody, of course it would hit me.
It...
All right.
Well, yeah, thank you for the raid, Nick.
We had a good stream.
Kill the streamer.
Kill the streamer so I can clip it and then be like, Mag all
on Doki food.
GG, have a great night, everybody.
What do you...
You mean you still?
What happened?
I couldn't say anything You know I I deleted Twitch I stream
on YouTube What do you mean?
I deleted Twitch That doesn't Wait see one bro what one more
bro i'm a youtube streamer we did it
back he doesn't want to be free no
He makes me lose C.
Oh my god!
Why did you make me kill her?
We have three support players.
They're from the Twitch stream for diamond.
I did!
And then he held me hostage now.
See?
Wait, I'm C1.
One more.
all right he got stockham syndrome it's the stockham
syndrome yes there's never actually one more
you lose lose this one when next when again the cycle never
stops
that is not true i literally stream project uh sec guy
that's not true and I played power world yesterday I did
other stuff yeah
but what about the power I stream power world let's see
actually if it doesn't work I'm tempted to actually hmm I
want I was thinking if I should do rocket or not
Who is oh, I know it's the guy that used to be my my fan
I don't talk to X fans
That's right, yeah, I said it.
Oh my god, that guy.
That guy.
That guy, please.
Oh my god.
What do you mean I have to deal with?
I'll try.
What?
Oh, they have Jubilee.
They have Jubilee.
Yeah, no, that, I ain't winning that.
He had to take me back, Dale.
Okay.
He had Jubilee team up.
Wow.
You know what?
We take those, because I didn't want to play this anyways.
Breathe, no loss, I guess.
I don't have to lose my E though.
I hope not.
If you're doing with him, tell him not to come back.
Like, no trade.
I'm sure he's great.
He's coming back.
I'm kidding.
Wait, I don't think they...
Oh, okay, thank God.
Oh, don't...
I think
he was one game off of raking up too he's got
that's fair I mean that's fair I think I think he got
snapped yeah
he actually made me that saved my c1 i was gonna stay in c1
regardless but he is a freak man now that that's that's fair
you know what happens that's yeah you literally just alt f4
yeah we got c1 back guys What a journey.
Did you guys enjoy my monthly Marvel Rival stream?
Got it out of the system.
That was...
Yay!
I'll see you guys tomorrow for the Apex tournament.
Don't worry, I'll play more.
I'll play Apex off stream.
I'll get back in cool.
But that was fun.
I had a...
great time i hope you guys had a great time hang out with me
today um we played for a while we played for a long time 12
hours of marvel rivals um but it was fun though it was a
good time um honestly i had a good time at the tournament i
really liked the team i was in even though we didn't get
like we don't even though we didn't make it to um we didn't
make it to the final finals you know like top four i enjoyed
the team and i enjoyed meeting new i enjoyed meeting the new
people and everything the vibes were great um and everything
um i know like you know the tournament might have been like
a little like not a little i mean one team literally was so
unhappy about the balancing but you know it's the first
tournament from Ashlyn and it was I thought my team was fun
you know I've had tournaments where we were you know didn't
do so well but vibes were terrible and I had miserable time
but even though for this one we might have got fifth place
out of eight teams at least we all had a good time and we're
all learning our team was like you know we had two players
that are relatively like ranked or new at the game and I
think we performed really well despite like um despite like
you know uh how some you know some teams had insane insane
teammates and everything where they're all eternity plus who
is this no thank you um yeah two play or three players we
had three players from EU by the way it was Necro's Bougar
and us they were all three of them were european players as
well um so um despite all of that um i think we did really
well and i had a great time with them and i it was cool
learning about dead by daylight i didn't realize he was a
really famous dead by daylight creator apparently like from
what you guys were telling me and what uh i heard um he was
like you know one of the big one is it one of the biggest
dead by daily creators um so it was very interesting to
learn uh and to find out that um you know he was a big
creator from in that game he's the face of it oh that's
super interesting yeah that's super interesting it's nice to
um uh nice to learn about it anyway guys i'm gonna head off
now i'm gonna get food finally my first meal of the day um
and but thank y'all for watching um i had a fun time i
actually had a really fun time in rink today except for that
one day um out of all the games uh yeah i i was not hungry
at all i don't know why i think today i was just running off
the drill and i just was not hungry today um but i'll go eat
my first meal of the day um and um what's i'm gonna say fuck
um but I actually had a really fun time with all my rank
games today, even the ones that didn't go so well, except
for that one game where I got ultra comboed three times in a
row whenever I wanted to alt.
It was crazy.
I felt like there was no outplayability there.
I legitimately just, I copied, and then I fucking died in
0.1.
I was so tilt.
That actually tilted me so much because I felt like I was
like, get that treatment you know legit pop gabbo and then I
exploded like I couldn't even dash anywhere I just go like
what yeah yeah but despite yeah like what happened like what
happened to me it happened three times that was so tilted at
that um yeah and then but like other than that i had a
wonderful time playing the game we had some funny he he ha
ha moments there too you know um we had some very silly
moments uh with people flaming each other but not at least
it wasn't at me you know that one time when we when it was
just people were people were flaming on both teams but then
the other team was the that surrendered even though my team
was also yelling at each other and calling themselves like
calling the other person pedos and everything i was like
whoa what's going on yeah i was just like whoa whoa whoa
whoa anyway if you're new here you don't know why i do um
what my content is i usually stream on youtube so please
check me out there that's my main stream um um and uh
tomorrow i'm actually doing the apex tournament i'll be
streaming that on youtube i'm actually not at home right now
but tomorrow will be my last stream where i'm at my friend's
place and i'm flying back home um just wanted to like get
all the stuff out of the way here and then go i feel like i
don't know i really like the frames i really like that have
really good frames right now despite everything um it's
really nice not gonna lie not to play with a hundred
yeah um i was like 200 plus frames in rivals while streaming
while having my vtuber uh skin suit on screen like what is
it what i didn't even think that was possible like um but
yeah uh please check me out on youtube i want to support
movie enemies i do have merch check out dokey merch and
Check out Doki merch to support me there.
You want to know whenever I stream on Twitch?
Follow me on Twitter.
Exclamation point, Twitter.
I always tweet about whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
Yeah, and also I have other stuff like GamerSubcode, Doki
Bird, Fortnite Code, Doki Bird, Apex Code, Doki Bird.
I think that's everything.
Anyways, I'm going to head off now.
I don't know if I'm rating anything.
I'll let you guys know.
I'll be dispersed if I'm not rating anyone.
But I'll let you guys know.
As always, everybody say, hydrated, pause, check, get up,
and move around.
You got that blood flowing.
You say it for me?
Head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.